dr chuck is one of the best people in
the world to create an internet history
and technology course
he's lived through it and has
interviewed many of the most important
people that helped create the internet
we know today
you are going to learn so much in this
course
welcome to internet history technology
and security my name is charles
severance and i'm a faculty member at
the university of michigan school of
information
i have been working on this course one
way or another for nearly 20 years
for me it actually goes back to when the
internet first started
that was in the mid 90s and in the mid
90s i had the good fortune to have some
friends that decided to help me go on
television uh john liske amy leahy and
richard wiggins and we had a television
show first it was called internet tci
and then later it was called
nothing but net and then we called it
north coast digital but it gave me an
excuse in the mid 90s to make a bunch of
videos and film folks and
just ultimately create a an interesting
oral history of the internet this is in
the 90s and we didn't even know how it
was all going to turn out so i we were
walking around rich wiggins and i were
walking around and filming all kinds of
things
another thing that i did in the late 90s
was to build a technology for teaching
and learning on the internet i hold the
distinction of being one of the first
people to stream an entire semester
online i streamed it so early
that i couldn't even stream video i
could stream audio using real audio and
i had a set of slides that would flip
every few minutes and you see a
terrifying picture of me staring at you
because there was no video in the upper
left hand corner of the screen
i went from the michigan state
university to university of michigan in
1999 and i rebuilt a new lecture capture
system that captured cameras and
document cameras and screen capture and
allowed for annotation and i called that
clipboard 2000. everything back then was
called something 2000.
in 2010 i was part of a group that
was going to convert ieee computer
magazine from
paper magazine to a digital magazine and
one of the ideas was is we should have
some videos so what i would do for about
five years is add
add a few days to a business trip and
take my camera and go somewhere i had
two cameras and a little backpack and
some lighting kit back in 2010 11 12 13
um
and interview various people and and
that let me complete my uh
set of interesting people uh in the
internet so
this
this all culminated in 2013 when
coursero was founded and i
was invited to be one of the first six
people at the university of michigan
to to be
on coursera and create a course and so i
created this course internet history
technology and security and back then we
didn't know
where this was all going to go but for
me
i just looked at it as a fun opportunity
to share nearly 20 years of my oral
history materials and also try to teach
people something about the internet the
idea is is that the course is supposed
to
hook you with a little bit of history
but then teach you tcpip and other
things and one of the things that i did
i always sort of have a media bent to
everything i do is i would go around the
country there's you can go to find these
at doctorchuck.com
office
and you can see
70 videos from all over the world of me
meeting my students since 2013 when i
first started teaching
and so that leads us to this version of
the class which is uh updated version
but again this is part of the beginning
of a technology oriented curriculum with
very liberal arts kind of focus and you
may have seen some of my other courses
python for everybody django for
everybody web applications for everybody
postgres for everybody and you know who
knows i've got a whole bunch of things
in the hopper that i'm working on so by
the time you're watching this this might
be
more and keep an eye on programming for
everybody
www.pr4e.com for this and upcoming
materials
so let's talk a little bit about the
course at from at
ihts.pr4e.com that's internet history
technology and security programming for
everybody so ihts.pr4e.com
as i said
the idea is that we can't look at
technology without understanding history
and i want those with a liberal arts
background to have a way into
understanding technology because
technology is not exist in a vacuum
technology has continued to change and
is going to continue to change and if we
don't take a look back we better we will
have no good idea about how to deal with
the future and so we need to understand
the past as we look toward the future
so this material came from a course i
taught from 2009 to 2017. most of the
course was a python course but about
halfway through right after the midterm
exam i gave everybody a break from
python and taught a couple of weeks of
internet history technology and security
and so that's what this course is this
course is the break from python now in
my programming for everybody curriculum
i kind of think of this as the first
course the place that you start
so the outline is starting with world
war ii going through 1999 as our history
then we look at the technology from the
arpanet to the internet tcpip and all
those protocols and then we take a look
at the layer of security that makes
all the kinds of commerce etc that we do
on the internet
possible
so we start back in the beginning at i
think of the beginning of computation
communication
that that is the internet and the
technology we use on the internet is
going back to bletchley park and so uh i
love bletchley park i've often met my
students at bletchley park
and i look forward to the next time i
get to go to bletchley park in the
second part of the course we actually
and believe me you'll be able to get it
don't worry we're not going to teach you
any math we're going to teach you things
like what the layered network model is
tcp and what's ethernet and what's wi-fi
and how do those things work and how do
i p addresses work and how do various
applications work and so that's the
middle part and then what we do is we
figure out
take a a look at
what it takes to protect the information
that's moving back and forth across the
shared internet the key to the internet
is that shared by all of us but we got
to keep our data separate and then we
got to keep our data
secure from prying eyes so we talk about
the technologies and math again now no
big math but just like the basic
concepts um
there's a companion website
ihts.pr4e.com
and it gives you the same course
material in a nice modular form with a
bunch of links to all the references and
quizzes to test your knowledge and if
you want there's some threaded
discussions if you log in that you can
participate in
so it's not practical for me to interact
with the
scalable class with hundreds if not
millions of students and so my classes
do have millions of students i mean i
watch things but twitter is probably the
best way to get me
and i do want to know if something's
broken i don't i don't i want to fix
things as fast as possible
so just a little bit about me if you're
still listening
i do have two tattoos these are real
tattoos
on my
on my left shoulder is my
research and on my right shoulder is my
education and i've got three degrees
from michigan state university and
engineering and my faculty position is
at the university of michigan in a in
the school of library science that's
currently called the school of
information on my
on my right shoulder is my research and
my research since 1997 has been in uh
building and using educational
technology to teach
and the the this all the logos are the
what i call the learning tools
interoperability ring of compliance
and lti is how we plug in all of my auto
graders etc into these
teaching systems and so my research has
been how to best teach with technology
literally from 1995 until the present
time
i have a race car which is one of my
hobbies and my other hobby is
hockey and so that's a little bit about
me i have a number of folks to thank a
lot of the material here was the work i
did for ieee computer magazine while i
was a while i was a writer for ieee
computer magazine they given me some
permission to reuse some bits of it uh
richard wiggins
my lifelong friend who passed away sadly
he has allowed me to use all of his
video material and
the copyright clearance is an important
part of any free online course and open
michigan
helped me with all of that so with that
let's go ahead and get started at
ihts.pr4e.com
hello and welcome to our first real
lecture of internet history technology
and security we're going to start of
course with internet history and i'm
charles severance and i'm your
instructor we're going to start at the
dawn of electronic computing i mean
computing started you know early with
abacuses and humans but we're going to
start with the moment that electronic
computing in particular because it was
the moment where computing and conv con
computing and communication sort of were
sort of co-born at the same time
then communication
before the internet became normal uh
then early internet research and then
the internet itself that was academia
and then of course
for uh went went out into the real world
and then the web which really took all
this connectivity and made it easy to
use for everybody it's really what their
view now this network is very much
through the web and then uh from that
point forward we
look at sort of the commercialization of
it and the ubiquity of it the widespread
use of it
so the first picture the first video
that i want to show you it's a little
longer than most of the other videos
it is about bletchley park and um there
are many heroes at bletchley park
of course this was a top secret code
breaking effort by the british
government during world war ii
um
world war ii i mean if you think about
it in history perhaps there's no time in
history
uh quite like world war ii if you go
back to
what kind of technologies were using in
1910 and 1920 to the technologies we
were using in 1940 it's an amazing
difference you know jet airplanes radio
radar so many things were invented and
made
made usable and made production quality
during that period of time war of course
is terrible
but it does cause governments to fear
for their lives
and invest heavily very heavily in
research
and so we in some sense uh even though
the war is a terrible thing
we sort of benefit from the extensive
research they were trying to solve
wartime problems but they ultimately
solve problems that have changed our
peacetime world in wonderful ways so
blessedly park is
north of london
between oxford and cambridge in england
and it's uh it was a code breaking
effort and at one point there were over
ten thousand people working on
top secret efforts to decode uh
encrypted messages uh initially from
germans uh as they were using radio so
they call world war ii a world war
mostly because it touched geographically
more than any other war had ever touched
that since
before or since really um
you know
alaska united states
italy africa russia japan
philippines
you know it just it truly was
geographically distributed and it was
necessary to do community unprecedented
communications just to
effectively pursue the war and this
meant that communications had to be
wireless
and the problem with wireless is anyone
can put up an antenna and listen to the
wireless signal there's no way to hide
the wireless signal unlike a wire that
you could hide it and if no one had
access to the wire you can't see what's
in it
but if you're using wireless and fast
moving armies in long distances
then someone can intercept the wireless
signal and they can so the trick of
course was to create an encrypted
wireless signal so they could see
everything you sent but it didn't make
any sense to them it's all sounded like
gibberish unless you of course know the
code
and so this was the a key technology was
building codes and code making machines
a good example this was the enigma made
by germany which is uh we'll talk about
these in this last part very last part
of the class and the security part of
the class how these codes and ciphers
work but they scramble material in a way
that's generally unintelligible
and of course the really bright folks at
bletchley park alan turing one of many
really bright people at bletchley park
um
used you know mathematics to to say you
know these codes may be more more
crackable than we think
uh there was folks from poland
uh who also informed the them to say
look we let me let's show what we did to
crack it right before poland was
involved they were working heavily on
the mathematics of cracking and so then
they built these machines
and so in this video that i'm about to
show you it's really what i try to do is
i try to contrast the the two machines
and one is an extremely fast mechanical
computer with relays and
switches and things that spin and gears
that move back and forth it's a very
physical computer that's uh that's
looking for patterns and as it's
spinning it's checking for possible
encoding combinations to try to just do
a brute force checking of lots of
different possibilities and so it was a
mechanical computer the bomba was a
mechanical computer and then
as the german encryption improved and
they used different techniques with more
sophisticated encryption they just
couldn't decrypt it with a mechanical
computer anymore
so they just
were forced to build something faster
and that faster thing
was the first truly powerful general
purpose electronic computer in the world
of course it was kept secret until the
certainly kept secret until the 60s and
the 70s and much of it was still kept
secret until even the 90s and so its
place in history is is kind of a recent
uh recent understanding you can look at
early history texts that talk about the
first computer and they don't mention
this one well that's because it was a
secret until a long time
so the bomba was a powerful mechanical
computer the colossus was a powerful
electronic computer but
i had this picture that was drawn by an
artist for me and um
in addition to showcasing sort of the
moment where a mechanical computer no
matter how hard you tried wouldn't work
fast enough and
the electronic computer was sort of
forcefully created out of a tremendous
need what's also really interesting is
the fact that bletchley park during this
time with 10 000 people
had
all kinds of people you know language
experts mathematicians
engineers welders and it's a really
cross-disciplinary activity and they
were solving a problem of decrypting
german transmissions but they ultimately
solved a problem
in the pursuit of that of electronic
communications and computation
and so this picture is really trying to
show how
you know a lot you know alan turing was
really very critical and but there are
other people like gordon welshman and
doc keane and and the folks from poland
that informed all of this
university colleagues and this whole
thing was a very much a connected
collective group of really bright people
highly motivated well-funded and they
created this so um so let me go ahead
and uh and pause now and let you take a
look at
at this film
[Music]
do
today we're at bletchley park in honor
of alan turing's 100th birthday
bletchley park just north of london in
between cambridge and oxford was
considered by many as the birthplace of
modern computer science in 1938 uh
again anticipation of war the government
code and cyprus girl uh through an in in
the main their operational director a
gentleman called aleister dennison had
drawn up a list he had sent two people
out to troll through the uh people at
oxford and primarily cambridge and some
extent oxford and drew up a list of
people who they approached who agreed in
an event of war uh would uh report
immediately the blood street park
britain declared war on september 3rd
1939 the following day september 4th
touring
and several others reported to bletchley
park as the requirement for more people
was needed uh some predominantly a
gentleman called gordon welchman who had
all he had been on the initial list he'd
arrived the same day as turing he went
back to cambridge and he started
recruiting all his best students and in
effect what they created here was the
world's first skunk works a secret
innovative organization where there were
no rules eventually uh their main
benefactor became the prime minister
winston churchill uh and they persuaded
churchill that this place needed uh
more resources churchill agreed and he
wrote a famous uh a letter was written
by welchman turing and the two deputies
to churchill and one other number a
gentleman called stuart milner berry
actually delivered it in person the
downing street churchill amazingly rece
read the letter the same day it was
delivered he put a famous action this
day stamp on it with a handwritten note
to his chief of staff a chap called
general dismay which said expedite with
extreme priority and report to me when
it is done and really from that point
september 1941 bletchley park got all
the resources that they needed they
threw in effect the smartest people
together in britain and said here's the
budget
this is the end game
and that's why they invented some of
these technologies that probably
wouldn't have been invented for years in
many ways bletchley park was an early
version of a multi-disciplinary science
center much like cern where ncsa is
today
many brilliant people with different
skills and backgrounds were brought
together to solve difficult problems
the combination of the skills and
collaborative environment resulted not
in just solving the problems of
cryptography that they were facing but
in addition solved broader problems for
all of computing in all of society when
the people arrived here they knew when
they arrived that the germans had taken
a machine a a machine which we tend to
call enigma enigma was a particular
variant of an encryption machine
that machine was modified from the
commercial version and it allowed them
to encrypt messages this was going to
become a machine to be used for
operational communications very short
200 250 character messages hitler had
conceived and as generals a type of
warfare never seen before which became
known as blitzkrieg very fast movement
50 miles a day particularly when they
invaded france
and the latter stages of their invasion
of poland you couldn't use fixed line
communications you needed to use
wireless communications here was a
device which was portable weigh 25
pounds ran off a battery you could
encrypt messages and then it's a
separate process they could be sent
using the fairly new technology of
wireless radio it was the polls who were
the first to recognize that the age of
machine cryptography had arrived and the
sort of people who would be good at
dealing with it were mathematicians
in fact they even went so far as to put
on a course in cryptography at the
university of pause man uh invited 20 or
30 young german-speaking mathematicians
to enroll it was very difficult course
and by the time the course was finished
there were really only three graduates
who they recruited uh their names were
mario rodriguevsky hendrick zakalski and
yazzie orozinski
and these three were the core of this
team
and they are the ones who really made
the early breakthroughs they convened
the conference at their secret
headquarters this was actually july 39
and at that conference they gave the
british everything they revealed what
they had done they gave them a replica
enigma machine and all of their work
that information came back to bletchley
park and once they were established in
bletchley park they then used the polish
method to break the enigma machine the
polls had actually built some machines
themselves one of which was called a
bomba that machine the name
apparently comes from a polish ice cream
dessert of the same name it's an effect
vanilla ice cream with
chocolate sauce around it this machine
was called bomb in honor of what the
polls did
but the polls technique was based on the
particular way that at that time the
germans incited their messages
they at that point were repeating the
message header and that was the attack
which the polls developed on it they
believed correctly that went when the
war would start that the germans would
change the way they were doing that and
they called for help they told chewing
and the people here everything they'd
done which we are
and should be very grateful but they
also proved that it was possible and
that i think was the spur that kicked
the brits into actually doing something
about it
now turing understood the weaknesses of
the way they'd done it and developed a
clip-based mechanism based on the fact
that every military organization in the
world cannot stop itself sending
stereotyped messages
he then talked to
a brilliant team of engineers led by dr
keane
who told him roughly the speed that it
would be possible to examine potential
stops for
so between between them they then
designed the machine called bomb which
would look for that and do so in
sensible time
here is an
example where we have intercepted this
message snmkg we're pretty sure that
that is because this particular operator
always did this this is his morning
weather forecast so here we have the
guest german plain text vetter
web forecast
and the two are lined up at that point
the enigmas ability or inability to
encode letters itself is useful because
you can make sure you've got no caches
here
and from these guest letters
we
that the crib makers would derive a
picture like this called the menu where
you'll notice that at position z e here
g
is encoded as e so we have g going to e
at z p at the end here e goes to v
this is reversible of course we can
describe this other way up so here's e
to v
that's z g here
s
is going to a
sorry s is going to be excuse me so
here's another link and eventually we
can go all the way around and we can
close this loop
like that it was the closed loops that
they were looking for the operation of
the bomb was simply that if there is a
letter
which you can feed in at this point and
which comes around through a string of
one two three four five six enigmas and
comes back as that same letter
then it's possible the position of these
wheels match the position of the wheels
when gunther started encoding his
message on his enigma it turned out to
be a bit more picky about loops and
menus than
um perhaps they had hoped although it
worked and at that point welchman added
a completely left-field master stroke
called the diagonal board
which i think it is fair to say made the
difference between success and failure
to turing's original idea and here are
my three diagonal boards that's one
that's the other this is the third one
coming in a place where you can't see it
but can can you see z down to a okay um
there's nothing connecting that to the
machine it just bolted there for
convenience the only connections to the
machine are when you connect
x into one of the enigmas what will
happen is when we turn the machine on
you'll see it will run up to speed
okay um
the motor will be running and the clutch
will drop in then you'll see the various
carry mechanisms happening
and then
when we stop the machine you'll see it
slow down
and then the clutch drops out so tony if
you'd run it up for us please
okay
would you turn on carry hole
so what you saw there was the
middle carry then we switched on carry
home to make the slow carry work all the
time so these bars are just pushing
around all the drums and you can see
that all the 36 enigmas are just in step
they're all just turning and they are a
resource
these are the very fast relays the three
banks actually four for the chains that
do the detection
here
this is the control logic
okay and then these are this is the 26
bit register that notes a stop and then
allows the machine to slow down before
it stops allele
our favorite statistic is the sheer
amount of wire in the thing there's no
we've lost count but it's somewhere
between 10 and 12 miles of wire
in each one of these
germans really there was two main
systems they were using enigma was their
operational system that was being used
for all specific operational
communications again very short maximum
of 250 characters uh instructions orders
for panzer division to move from one
location to other orders for a submarine
to attack a convoy for aircraft to
during the battle of britain to attack
specific targets
the germans started to introduce through
probably 1941 a different system
the intercept service which britain had
put into place to intercept these
messages started hearing traffic which
was clearly not enigma traffic a
negative traffic was morse code easily
identifiable
people can be trained fairly clear
simply to transcribe to listen to morse
code and transcribe the letters this was
a totally different signal it was not
discernible it was not transcribable
this was adaf hitler's communication
channel to his army general so very
long-winded communications top secret uh
and so this was an even more daunting
task arguably than enigma because uh
this encryption machine that was used
with this system uh there were various
uh ones of them hitler referred to these
as heim
his secret writers several companies
siemens uh that exists today making
we're making a machine haglin but there
was also the lorenz company and that was
the primary machine particularly
lawrence said 42
that machine unlike enigma that had
three encryption wheels had 12
encryption wheels
they approached the post office research
lab at dulles hill in london
a young engineer called tommy flowers
right into the project uh he was in
effect told well go ahead if you can get
approval flowers went back to the post
office got approval put a small core
team together and in less than a year
had a working prototype uh quite a
remarkable achievement
the first class colossus as this machine
became known the mark 1 had 1 500 valves
or vacuum tubes in it they brought it to
bletchley park it worked almost right
away the people here were convinced they
asked for a more powerful computer uh
flowers already had anticipated this he
already had it in production 2 500
valves in an era when no machine had
more than that used valves had more than
about 15 here is a machine with two and
a half thousand flowers was told that
they needed the mark ii by june 1st 1944
because there was a certain date in the
diary june 5th 1944 was a scheduled day
for operation overlord d-day it actually
ended up being june 6th because of bad
weather flowers delivered the marked
first mark to the bletchley park on june
1st they switch it on it worked straight
away they immediately started decrypting
messages between the german high command
and much of the light the light they
discovered that all of the subterfuge
about the d-day landings had worked
hitler had believed that the main
invasion was going to be at the pot of
calais not at normandy that intelligence
was fed back to general eisenhower at
allied uh supreme command headquarters
and there is reasonable evidence to
conclude that the game i will not have
gone ahead on june 6 1944 without the
intelligence from bletchley park
this is the
colossus computer at fletcher park
now we're in hutch 4 at bletchley park
which was the one of the first
purpose-built computer centers and some
10 of these machines were installed here
starting in january 1944.
now
in the years previously a new way of
encrypting messages was discovered that
was being used in germany and it was
those high-level messages between hitler
and his generals and they were encrypted
on a machine called lawrence machine and
it used teleprinter traffic teleprinter
codes to actually transmit those
messages
now by 43 it was taking some six hours
sort of six weeks to actually decode
those messages and decode those messages
laboriously by hand
the problem with that is
within six weeks the usefulness of the
intelligence that you gain from those
messages is obviously gone so that
process needed to be speeded up
now some techniques have been tried from
so many electronic techniques have been
tried here at blue park
um
but this machine
when it was put into use in early 44
reduced that six week period to decode
the message down to six hours
and that's really just a phenomenal jump
the machines the
messages themselves were received at
various intercept stations around the
country and were punched onto paper tape
now there are two paper tapes on the
machine here no one that we're running
and one which is
ready for the next run
now this tape with two here if i take
one each row across the tape are punched
five holes and each of those is an
alphanumeric character and that's the
encrypted message that was received has
been punched onto tape
now although colossus has
really all the elements of a modern
electronic computer
it doesn't have the memory that
we expect in a stored program computer
so what happens is that tape
of that message some 5 000 characters
that message is actually formed in a
loop
and is read over here
with a series of photoelectric centers
and lights
and each character is red
and the 5 000 characters are set up 5000
characters a second are red
now each
clunk of the machine we can hear there
is another 5 000 characters being read
into the machine
so we're reading that same 5 000
characters each time
this is the control panel of the
colossus computer so it's this side of
the machine that would actually be the
the wrens and the wartime would actually
be using now i can set up
the particular algorithm i want to test
and routines i want to test using these
control panels
and each clunk of the machine at the
moment is another state where we're
actually
trying a new algorithm and repeating
that algorithm on that repeating 5000
characters
the results that the machine
detects are presented here
now we're doing
a
statistical analysis of that encrypted
tape
now the machine was run for some six
hours uh there are
two and a half thousand valves in this
machine
you can't see that many from the front
but once we go
between the acts of the machines you get
an idea of the scale
two and a half thousand valves
each file has a
heater a hot wire heat in the center of
the valve and operates
at about
two three hundred volts dc
now five and a half uh two and a half
thousand valves
plus the power supplies generates
over eight kilowatts of uses over 8
kilowatts of electricity and by this
point when we're standing in between the
racks you can feel the heat coming off
of these racks
[Music]
colossus is a combination of electronics
and we can see the the electronics here
in these valve
chassis numbers and also
electromechanical
switch gear so there are backs of relay
panels here
these big
single motion detectors are a sort of
motorized switch that will actually spin
around there's banks of those in the
machine the technology is
equipment that was well known for the
british post office
this machine was designed
by a chap called tommy flowers and tommy
flowers was an engineer at the
research center in london for the
british post office
tommy was asked to look at the problem
of
how to automate this task this manual
task
and tommy came up the idea of using
electronics to do this at the time the
idea of using
more than half a dozen valves in any
circuit was just simply pooh-pooh
valves had a bad reputation people had
valves in their radios at home they
failed when they switched the radios on
so the idea of using two half thousand
was just simply just phenomenal
but
tommy understood
that
it's probably it's almost certainly the
thermal shock that kills valves in the
first place so if you leave the machine
on
and don't subject it to that shock you
won't have a problem
now all the 10 colossus machines here at
bletchley park were left on permanently
the machines were operated by
wrens in in three shifts throughout the
day
we
have to be equally careful this is
obviously this is a replica of the
machine itself
but the same problems apply we need to
be
careful in bringing the supply voltages
up gradually so we don't suffer from
thermal shock and that in the same way
shutting the machine down
tommy had the idea of
generating the key because it's a key
that we're comparing with that encrypted
type generating that key electronically
and these counters here that are called
the thyrotron rings the thyrotron valves
actually hold that
that count now we describe colossus as
not having a memory
we say not having a memory in the sense
that um
modern computers have a a memory that's
common for data and for programs
well the program here is set on those
control panels at the front and that's
switch um
switch and plug programmed much like say
it's contemporary eniac machine
um but these machines these valves at
the back do act as a store in the sense
of counters and they're actually
counting the score that we're actually
getting each passed through the
algorithm
the
we can see at the back here
well certainly some of the modern
technology
um i suspect the wartime guys that were
building and debugging these machines
would have given anything for a
reliable oscilloscope and let alone a
logic analyzer but if i look into the
machine down here back you can see the
projected image that's coming off the
tape
and that's shining onto five
photo sensitive valves
and it's those valves that are actually
reading the 000 characters every second
paper tape was used well into the 1960s
and 70s at this speed was simply
phenomenal and hadn't really been
thought of before
and our original museum director techno
sale wanted to rebuild
the colossus and build a replica of the
glossary machine and this was done 20
years ago
there's very little information out
there there are a few pictures that were
kept possibly illegally
a few scraps of circuit diagrams
and just the memories of some of the
original pioneers who worked on the
machine and when tony started the plan
tommy flowers was still alive and
remembered and was able to draw circuits
of course finding the parts as well but
the important thing is the machine was
designed by a post office engineer at
the time
an engineer that was used to designing
systems for telephone switching so a lot
of the components here everything from
the relay banks to the switches
to the power supplies were common to
british post offices in the pre-war
period
so when tony
then
wants to find the components to rebuild
the replica he's lucky in the sense that
the last of those exchanges are being
decommissioned from post offices around
the country
tony was therefore able to really
back up a pickup truck at the back of
the exchange and take away all of those
components and dismantle all of those
components and they are they were
absolutely perfect and it was just that
tiny really couldn't have been better
so alan turing actually left bletchley
park after about three and a half years
his involvement really uh
finished he went to the united states of
turing became was not actually involved
in the development of colossus some of
the statistical work that he did was
used by the people
predominantly bill tutt who's the guy
that actually reconstructed the lorentz
machine quite remarkably a remarkable
feat
indeed uh cheering got involved in
things like speech scrambling systems
and went to the united states and was
involved in other projects so he wasn't
really involved in colossus at the end
of the war trey went to work for the
national physics laboratory again
pursuing these sort of ideas and then of
course he ended up at the university of
manchester where max newman who had run
the department were the colossus
computers uh had been located but she
parked also ended up as the head of
mathematics and obviously then at that
point turned became involved in the very
early uh computer developments in
britain uh gordon welchman immigrated to
the united states at the end of the war
in 1948 he immigrated to the united
states and became involved in many of
the early american competing
developments project whirlwind
weltzman worked at mit taught the first
course in computing science
at mit so cheering then was involved in
things like the manchester baby in the
franti mark one and the early uh
competing developments uh i guess this
is well known of course during
tragically uh committed suicide in 1940
1954.
[Music]
do
so i hope you enjoyed that
again i tried to showcase the the
juxtaposition of the mechanical
computers moving to the electronic
computers and how it was a collective
effort by by many different people
and so one of the things that happens
sort of after this is um after the war
they didn't need bletchley park anymore
so they shut the bletchley park down and
all these people who had worked on all
these things and built all these things
went to
various academic places like mit
manchester harvard and what happened was
is
what they had done was a secret and they
could say nothing about it but they had
realized
and they couldn't forget
that electronics
could do computation
and electronics due to computation
far more rapidly than anything we've
ever imagined before
so a series of computers came up
really fast after the war
they kind of you know relaxed the war's
over we feel good
but let's start thinking about what we
would build if we were going to do
computations like weather or other kinds
of cool computations instead of just a
wartime computations and and so these
next generation of computers that are
often thought of as the first computers
in the world which really kind of like
the follow-on computers to the computers
built at bletchley park
and so the immediate post-war period in
the 1940s took the
us and uk code breaking there were
similar things in the united states as
well and i'm sure elsewhere where that
pushed and the envelope of computation
but the folks that had
built all these things for wartime
purposes
switched and moved into academic and
peacetime purposes and so they built
i mean if you think about it they have
less pressure but they already know it's
feasible and they could kind of sit back
and relax and be like okay that would be
a little better we kind of compromised
there so they built some really elegant
computers and and you know they can they
can all sort of fight over who's the
first um
but ultimately they all pretty much came
out uh very quickly one after another
because the idea had escaped and so this
is the beginning of sort of electronic
electronic computation right the fact
that electricity can be used to
represent data and that can be used to
change data very rapidly as compared to
other things that used physical storage
for uh computer information so this was
a great time electronic computation
from the specialized to the general
purpose and these people really built
some exciting computers many of the
architectures of which are kind of still
sort of with us a lot of the
architectures were innovative the
innovative architectures that we still
use today were conceived and imagined
there
[Music]
but students get a better understanding
of something if they know the history of
it and know where it know where it's
come from that's my
my view
so when i go to class when i go to the
interface design class for instance i
can
take them down to the museum
and show them
what an early interface was you know we
talk about
interface design and they think of their
their handheld computer their laptop
their desktop and they look at the
screen and they think that's
that's an interface and sure it is but
where did you know how did we get there
what was the early interface with
computers i'm going to take them down to
the frankie sirius and they say well
what's the interface here with the
computer so it's it's um
giving them the idea of what an
interface is by by taking them back to
something that's that looks very
primitive and and then we look at the
evolution of interfaces over time we
look at the different um applications
you know we go back and look at
busy calc and word star and things like
that and to progress through the
the different versions of these
different products and
you actually have like running
physically no we don't
know
it's also from the web but i i think it
just broadens their outlook
on it and i think
it's a danger with computing students
that they become very can become very
focused on the latest and
and quickly discard the technology
they're using when the next one comes
along and forget about it and
even before we had the museum we were
lucky we had here cyrax i've mentioned
cyrax to
the world's number four digital store
program computer
it's left over used till about 65 so
about 72 or so it arrived on campus just
for storage purposes
but we put it in a display area
when i first arrived from my teaching
here in about 88 to teach
i would always take my introduction to
computer architecture students past that
it had so much
to tell students about the origin of
operating systems the primary function
of operating systems to
allocate resources and the
efficiency of use of resources with the
programming students i can show them
things like punch cards and things like
this you know how do we get information
into the computers and show them things
like that
so
it might be part of one class in a
semester
that
i use the
museum in particular for from my classes
and others use it too in similar ways
but we do have school children coming on
visits and then we have about an hour or
two and we take them
through the museum
starting with the the calculating
machines and we talk about what do
people do before computers and i've got
things like this
what is the computer where did we get
the name of computing from and i've got
this picture of women using slide rules
in 1948 i think it was in this is in
america doing their calculations and the
idea that the first computers were
people okay and and often they were
women so that's kind of an interesting
bit of social history there so trying to
connect
the computers and state of the
technology to what was happening in
society the time the physical artifacts
are very important
that idea of the physical we still carry
forward even today as we're looking to
see what we can do with the full museum
that we've created now
we've toyed with ideas of a web-based
series of exhibitions
photographing all of the artifacts and
making sure that people can sort of
browse through and move through halls
we feel that even with that
web-based
teaching methods we would still like to
have physical artifacts we've toyed with
um a box of artifacts that we would send
out to schools that are working on our
program that do an educational program
so
the physical hands-on is a very
important thing museum curators
understand it
people who aren't museum curators tend
not to
we had a
staff member in our
in our school
and when we started the museum i was
talking to her and and said oh we will
have slide rules in there now she had
done an honors degree in maths and she
had not heard she
not that she hadn't seen a side well she
didn't even know what one was and that
to me was amazing because
when i went to uni everyone carried a
schedule you know we all had this my
schedule from our universities we all
had these as science students
engineering students
we all had these tools and she was
probably 10 years
younger than me and suddenly i had no
idea what i was even talking about
hadn't heard the word so i think that
really
made me realize that histories are so
quickly forgotten
and
there's a danger that
um we just
um yeah we
we forget about these things and if we
um
don't have them around for people to see
they forget about the history of
uh you know the the technology that
they're using and i think that's a real
danger
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
also in the uh
post-war period in the 1950s as a bit of
an aside um
[Applause]
there was a there was a realization by
the
certainly the federal government united
states that
academics were kind of useful
right i mean
uh the people that really had won the
war for them were academics
not just computer people but also people
that built designed airplanes and radar
and things like that
and so there's a sense that
the safest country was the country that
had the smartest people
and in many ways the entire us
educational system was built to
find really bright scientists and
educate them very effectively
and so um
and so there was there was a a real boom
in building science departments uh
national science foundation was fun uh
created right after the war
and uh and so united states and and
other governments really
greatly invested in research
and there's this movie a beautiful mind
and i've got the url there at the bottom
it's not required but i love the movie
and it gives you a sense in particular
the scene that i'm pointing to gives you
a sense of
how mathematicians were in many ways uh
treated like celebrities so i'll pause
just for a minute in case you want to
pause this video and then go take a look
at the john nash video
[Music]
so of course john nash was a real person
he received his phd in mathematics at
princeton
at 22 years old he was a
prodigy
he was on the mathematics faculty at mit
in 1951 through 1958 and he had adult
onset schizophrenia
uh right before he was 30 years old and
uh
and it was quite a severe case and it
took it
he he spent a number of years in sort of
mental institutions homeless etc
but in his work in princeton
uh
in an area called of economics called
game theory he
did something that was quite innovative
and it really revolution revolutionized
in many ways our understanding of
economics
and
and he
sort of
he he got his schizophrenia under
control in the mid 90s and uh and he was
awarded
the nobel prize for economics in 1994
and so this is just kind of this moment
where this all this stuff was
blossoming in the 40s and the 50s now in
the 1960s
we started seeing a different way of
of
computing this was moving from the
research into the mathematics of
building computers to the applications
of the computers and
we needed to have connectivity because
you would build a computer and
you know in
1955 there might be one computer
available to a university researcher in
the entire state
and so you had to connect them together
and so we would often end up with
these things we call terminals in our
office
and they would use these dial-up modems
and they would connect perhaps for a
local call
to a local computer
or even a long distance call
a very expensive long-distance call to a
remote computer but these computers were
so central and so precious
that we didn't care about the cost of
phones and we couldn't share them i mean
we didn't everybody didn't have a
computer the way they do
uh today and so there was a couple of
different models one is that you had
people doing their work connecting to
computers over these modems um and then
more rarely you had computer to computer
connections using what are called leased
lines these lease lines were very
expensive
they were kind of like making a long
distance phone call 24 hours a day seven
days a week
they were rarely used in academic
situations because they were so
expensive it was more common for a bank
to use them to say move all their data
from their branch locations to the
central locations once a day they were
generally slow
and very expensive and they were
justifiable in certain situations and so
that's kind of how our world was we we
had something on our desk and then we
used that to connect through the phone
lines to a central computer that was
shared with many different people who
called it time sharing
and so oops
so this next video that i want to show
you uh just the first part of it you
have to watch the whole thing um
is kind of
in the 60s and
in 70s when i became involved in
computing this was kind of the way that
we perceived our computers you know we
would dial them up and they made these
clunking noises uh this teletype that
you're going to see in this video as a
is a world war ii artifact basically
um
and and my first programming personally
was on this kind of a computer making
this exact noise that you're going to
hear in this video
and i i think the the key to to
emphasize here is that
you know you it's kind of fun to look
back at this old guy with his horny rim
glasses
um but
but we really were enjoying ourselves
and you think well i got this fancy cell
phone and it does all these wonderful
things and i place angry birds on it
and
weren't these people not having fun and
the answer is we were having a great
time
we were connecting communicating
calculating computing doing all these
wonderful things we just were doing it
sort of more slowly with simpler
equipment but
but even from the beginning in the 60s
and the 70s people talking to people
were an important part of the use of
this technology
so uh take a quick look at this video
and then come on back
i'm going to show you the use of the
michigan terminal system a large
computing system at the university of
michigan computing center
using the ibm model 360 67
we will be using a standard teletype
and we will be dialing in
through the ordinary
university centrix telephone system
this system can be used by a telephone
system anywhere in the world
as long as one can dial directly into
the computer
these teletypes are not wired in
but or use the ordinary telephone system
we start
by pushing the originate button which
turns on the teletype
then we will dial using the regular
telephone dial here now there is a
handset which is available
with every teletype system
you can dial this number if you like
with the handset
either one works but as soon as you are
connected to the computer do not use the
handset for any purpose at all
now i'll push the originate button
i can control the speaker volume with
this little knob and so you can hear it
now i will dial the number
763 o 300
or in the centric system just 30300
and now the computer is coming in i will
turn the volume down
the response from the computer is the
identification of the system
the who are you is the standard teletype
communication identification and the
teletype itself answers with its own
built-in code number in this case the
teletype at the tv center
now i must
sign on to the computer and identify
myself
the number sign at the beginning of the
line is the indication that the michigan
terminal system is waiting for me
to communicate something to it
the first thing i must do is issue the
sign on command
all commands in the system start with a
dollar sign
now the keyboard
on the teletype is very much like the
keyboard of a typewriter
including a shift key
for the characters on the top of the key
we do not have upper and lowercase
letters however
so the shift key is only used to get an
additional set of characters and in this
case the dollar sign is a character
above the number four
now i will use the word sign-on which is
the official command
s-i-g-n-o-n there must be a space at
least one after every command
and now i will give my own personal
computing center number which happens to
be w010
each user of this system is issued a
computing center identification number
through his instructor if he's a student
or through the department for faculty
now this line has been typed
it is being held by the computer
but i can if i see any errors in it do
some editing and correcting we'll see
that later
i am satisfied with this line
and now i will give the end of line
character
which must be given after every line and
i will remind you each time that i'm
doing it for a while
the character for ending a line uses the
control key on the keyboard which is a
special key which
indicates that i want to use even
additional characters besides those that
are
added by the use of the shift key
i hold the control key down
and while i hold it down i can hit one
of a number of other keys
and in this case i will use the control
with the letter q
it's possible to use the letter s also
but that's right next to another key
which disconnects a teletype so i
recommend using q
i will use ctrl and q to terminate the
line
and now i'm asked to give my private
password
i'll give an incorrect password
just some nonsense characters
and of course end of line
because i must indicate that i'm
satisfied with that
i'm prompted that
i better give another password
and now since i intend to give the
correct password i will turn off the
printing so that no one can see what
mine is
the to turn off printing we use this
switch
which is
labeled hdx and fdx for half duplex and
full duplex we normally operate this the
teletype in half duplex mode
if i push it to full duplex printing is
suppressed
and now i will give my correct password
push to half duplex again
and end of line character control q
and it is accepted by the system
and i am now signed on
the information that's coming out here
is time and date of the previous sign on
and time of date of this sign-on
hello and welcome back
i just wanted to give you sort of a
sense of the actual physical experience
of connecting and communicating and
computing in the 60s and the 70s the 70s
was when i got my start and uh the lucky
people got to use a teletype like was
being used
in that video and other people used
punch cards um you also heard the
squealing sound of the data being
converted into sound and back and forth
um
you know it's
the the key goal was there would be if
you were lucky one computer within a 20
mile radius of where you were sitting so
you could use a local phone call and you
could be on all day and do things all
day long and that was really exciting
and a lot of fun
um
and this was sort of a common if you
were sort of
you know
today you have a 2 000 laptop the fancy
people had these teletypes right in
their office because then they could
conveniently sort of do computation and
and and not have to go somewhere do that
computation so that's a
pretty exciting so dial up was kind of
like the way the campus
operated but you can also do data
transfer with leased lines
and the typical thing about lease lines
is that their
uh the the phone company if it's going
between two cities um digs a hole and
puts a cable in and has some number of
copper wires in between those cities
this is back then
um of course it's fiber optic now but
back then it was copper and every time
you would make a call between those two
cities it would have to find a free
piece of wire and connect it up so that
your call the audio of your call would
go through that wire
and
if you wanted to you could pay them to
lease one of those pieces of wire
it meant that people couldn't use that
wire for phone calls you would sort of
take it out of service and if they had
500 wires between two cities and you
leased one of them then they had 499
wires and so it was rather expensive and
really very importantly the cost was
based on distance right
a mile
versus 5 miles versus 20 miles versus
100 miles the cost would kind of go up
linear based on distance and so that's a
that's a key
thing that distance is important in
these very
limited resource copper wires where you
had to dedicate a wire either to a phone
call or to data
and so
we ended up evolving in the academic
world what we called stored in forward
networking with the sole purpose
of compromising everything so that we
would keep our costs that we paid for
our phone lines to a minimum we wanted
to communicate in academia with people
all around the country and all around
the world so we had to keep the cost low
and so
we would
lease a leased line
you know so so
so here would be us sitting with
terminals in our offices and we would
use dial-up to get connected and so this
might be a few miles like one to two
miles
or one to two kilometers
um and that's what you had you had to be
live near a computer or have an office
near a computer and then you would use
the local telephone network to dial and
to do your work and then there would be
one connection out the back of that
computer to
a another computer that would also have
users on it
and then other computers with users on
it other computers with users on it so
this might for example be
michigan
this might be stanford
stanford would have a computer michigan
would have a computer the stanford
people be connected to the stanford
computer
stanford would have one little
connection out its back end and to the
rest of the world
so
you sitting here want to talk to
somebody
sitting here
so this is how it worked you were sort
of always connected so your data would
be inside you know you type an email
into the computer and then you'd say
send that out to
my colleague at stanford
and so the problem is is everyone else
was sending and so let's say for example
that somebody sent a pretty big thing
big purple circle is what they're
sending and then somebody next to you in
the office down sends a kind of
medium-sized orange circle and they're
sitting there being stored in the local
computer and then you finally finish
typing your email messages and it's kind
of a small green circle
and now the problem is is you're in a
line
the way this worked is the software
would keep a cue or a line of those who
are going to use the uh the line and
then it would sort of start streaming
this stuff out and once it started it
just kept doing the same file over and
over and over now if it died it would
just start from the beginning again and
so it takes some time for that thing to
move across the network and then would
move across the network the next message
in line would start to be sent across
the network and it would use that link
um come on finish up there we go okay it
takes a while for these things to move
across the link and then finally and
this could be ten minutes later finally
it was your turn and your stuff would
work its way through the network and get
to the next computer the problem is is
once it's in that computer you face the
same problem because if all these
messengers are going from
uh michigan oh
forgot to hit the button thing from
michigan to stanford and they're all on
the way
they got to go through all these links
because there wasn't a direct connection
because the direct connection to
stanford would be very expensive and so
you're we're in us we find ourselves in
a situation where it you're stored
you set on these computers and if there
was an outage of a network
or say this one this might be hours you
might be sitting on this computer for
hours on their disk drive right not even
in their memory you'd be sitting on
their disk drive for an hour and then
finally this would come back or maybe
this computer was down they'd come back
up and then the data would start flowing
again
so it was
haphazard i keep telling you it was
awesome
it was just slow it was awesome but slow
so don't don't don't feel sorry for us
we loved it we enjoyed it it was great
talking to colleagues all over the world
so we ended up with a network
architecture that
encouraged more hops which means it
encouraged more latency and encouraged
the likelihood of getting stuck behind
something large as it worked its way
through the network
so for example um we were going to send
a message
from east lansing to say the east coast
somewhere and we would have two
connections maybe we would have a
connection between uh michigan state
university and east lansing in ann arbor
and then we'd have a the data would get
stored in forward in ann arbor and then
we get uh further sent to cleveland and
if you think about it the the wire
between ann arbor and cleveland goes
like this right they probably buried
wires under the ground
and if we could
actually convince
toledo the cost of
the big wire versus the cost of the two
shorter wires the cost of the two
shorter wires is almost exactly
the cost of the big wire because it's
not really a big wire and so if we can
convince toledo
to join our little club
then
we don't increase the cost of our
communications because we're it's about
the same right the the wire length is
about the same but we've got one more
school for the same cost and if you keep
doing that and you keep saying oh well
let's put a school here and put a school
here and put a school here in the middle
of a lake and put a school here in the
middle of a forest
the economics draw said that you could
connect more schools
with effectively fixed cost by
shortening the distance every time you
made a connection and sometimes they
would sort of make two connections but
the way it often worked was
from
the perspective of
this whole thing is the data would sort
of tend to go
you know up to some central location and
then kind of fan back out from the
central location and uh and so these it
there wasn't a lot of redundant links in
this whole situation
so we find ourselves in a situation
where we can save more money
saving money by just simply adding hops
so in this environment
we
had a lot of email back in those days we
didn't have a lot of images computers
you know barely could do upper and lower
case sometimes it was impressive when we
finally got to upper lower case let
alone images and so for the longest time
everything we did was very text oriented
sometimes we would send small files like
programs to each other but it was either
text and these days those are tiny it's
almost like sms right it's almost like
the size of an sms message was the size
of a typical mail message back in those
days images we didn't have computers
that could even display them and so it
hardly mattered so you focused your life
on this one computer within a 20 mile
radius and it had this connection to
like a snake-like connection that sort
of went over hill and dale and to
somewhere and then i finally got to
stanford or wherever your mail had to go
but again it was
awesome to be able to sit at a keyboard
and talk to people all over the world
even though it took four hours we didn't
we didn't send as much email back then
and a number of networks came up one of
them that became sort of pretty widely
used was a thing called bitnet and it
was uh where everything kind of came
back to princeton was one of the main
hubs of bitnet and uh it worked really
well and and you know we could there was
a way to say oh i need one more school
and we'd go find the ones that are
closest and we'd make the connection
and so that's pretty much how
the average academic saw networking one
campus computer and sort of this weird
slow storm forward networking that
worked well enough but during that exact
same time from the 1960s to the 1980s
the us department of defense was
investing in a research network called
arpanet
and arpanet was funded by the military
arpa defense advanced research projects
agency
um and we'll meet
in the later in the lecture we'll meet
vince cerf we'll tell the story much
better than i can tell but i'll just
tell you a short version right now
a lot of people wonder why the
department of defense started this
project and
a lot of people say oh it's because of
the fear of nuclear
war and the project was very long and
there were various motivations
throughout the various phases of the
effort
but if based on what i've been told and
what i've read i think it's safe to say
that the primary motivation was to
improve the use of their computing
equipment that they were used for
military purposes
make it easier to access them make it so
people didn't have to travel as much
made it so that people could work from
their office on many different computers
and also so that people could actually
talk more effectively so they could send
email real fast so that the email would
move faster for military people so the
first thing is really kind of an end
user focus to make them more useful to
people and get people working together
more effectively that was the first
kind of heavy motivation
the second motivation was actually had
to do with reliably reliability and
redundancy and
resistance to partial failure
and that really wasn't so much about
nuclear attack that was more about
battlefield attacks so the notion that
once you start having all these links
and you make them wireless and you put
them in trailers on a battlefield and
you know you got a few hundred miles and
the date is moving back and forth
then we have to worry about in a
battlefield situation one of those
trailers might get hit and how would you
keep the network running if one of those
trailers got hit so the notion that we
have sort of a whole nation
and we are worried about communications
i'm sure there was some worry about that
but it wasn't really the main reason and
i mean the exciting thing to me is the
main reason was a very very
people-centered reason of people working
more effectively
but this was a rather exclusive club
rather exclusive network
because it was only for the people who
were either military or funded to build
it so in 1969
there were four hosts on it
again that's research and these were
lease lines the same ones we were all
using to do our email and they were
expensive
very expensive but because it was a
large grant they just paid it because
the research was
not about the money the research was if
you had these connections what would be
the best way to use them and how to deal
with redundancies and how to deal with
multiple paths to the same place
all that stuff is is interesting
research questions that computer
scientists spent many years
conceiving of and so by 1972 looks like
we got about 20. we got a couple of
cross country links and multiple
connections and and this looks like a
great test bed to see you know so all of
a sudden this part goes down how quickly
can we reroute around the outage and
literally these things these days
reroute
around outages in far less than a second
um and so that's really impressive our
current internet owes its history to the
research that was done in the 1960s and
1970s
but what was fundamentally different
between the story and forward networks
of bitnet and this arpanet research
network
was the notion of packet switching
so the it's a real simple concept it
just takes a little more
complex software to solve the store and
forward network would
start date sending data across the link
and then keep sending it until it was
done that would seem to be very
efficient you didn't want to like you
wanted to use it as fast as you can and
then put in the next one out put the
next one out with the next one it was
really simple and it dealt with outages
in a simple manner by storing them all
locally on the disk but what if instead
you made it so
you broke every message let me see if i
can even draw this i should probably
make a slide about this so if there's a
network here and here's here's my
computer and it's got a network
connection
it's got one really big message
broken into pieces
many pieces
and it sends the pieces one at a time
if you
show up
with a really short message with only
three pieces
all you have to do is wait for one piece
to go and then your piece goes in and
then you share for a while
right you share for a while and then
your have made it through because you
only have three packets this has like
1000 packets and then once your message
is through
they resume sending this data in order
and so you were able to sneak and bypass
the traffic jam that was this large
amount of data and so that's the idea of
packets and packets are these chunks to
say
what we're going to send is a piece
and then at the end of that we're going
to maybe send a piece of a different
message it was allowing simultaneously
multiple message to be in flight at the
same time
that's packet switching
and what happened then is we also ended
up with these special purpose computers
called routers they're still computers
but they weren't doing storing in the
same way they were just forwarding they
weren't storing forward they were merely
forwarding so we'll get back to that in
a second
[Music]
do
when you walk into the back entrance of
boulter hall on the ucla campus you may
notice a seemingly random pattern of
floor tiles in the entrance if you spend
a little time looking at the pattern it
might dawn on me that the tiles
represent zeros and ones and then you
might even figure out the tiles
represent ascii characters the
characters in the floor tiles spell out
low and behold to commemorate the
building where l and o were the first
two packets ever sent on the arpanet
from ucla to stanford research institute
on october 29th 1969.
oppa wanted a network so that they could
share the large computing resources they
had
given to their researchers across the
country
university of utah had a terrific
graphics operating system
so i had database we had simulation
university of illinois had high
performance computing and every time
opera brought on a new researcher
they'd offered to buy him a computer
fine but the researcher would say i want
the same capability all those other guys
have i want the graphics the database
and all the rest and office said we
can't afford that
if you want to do graphics you log on to
the machine at utah through a network
that we think we're going to make
so the need for the network was to do
resource sharing and not to protect the
united states against a nuclear
holocaust
when bob taylor came in as a neck
director and he recognized his need for
sharing resources by the way notice the
phrase i'm using sharing resources is
exactly what i built into network design
now they wanted to share the external
resources same idea
you have it you're not using it somebody
else you'll be able to
so they brought in larry roberts another
classmate in mind in fact an officer
made of mine at mit
to manage this project he came to me
because he knew my work he he watched me
do the simulation in fact i used his
compiler on the tx2 computer
and said len we need to know if this
thing is going to work
he knew that i had the theory so i could
show it to him it's going to work
in fact he even says he would never have
decided to spend millions of dollars of
the us government's money he wasn't sure
this thing would work
so the design began to be laid out by a
few of us in 1967
in 68 they sent out a request for
proposal the end of 68 both baranek and
newman a cambridge massachusetts firm
won the contract to produce the first
switch
of the arpanet
and we became the network measurement
center early on so we could test it out
during the design phase
some great people were there throwing
their ideas out herb baskin was there a
time sharing expert
and he said
if this network can't deliver short
messages within a half a second i can't
use it for time sharing
specifications half a second by the way
we got 200 milliseconds
and uh
westclock said
a separate computer
from communications
i said look if this is going to be an
experiment and i was also interested in
the research and experimentation we have
to build software in so we can run
experiments
artificial traffic generators
measurement hooks a place where the
measurements can be evaluated
with the software and so
howie frank began to talk about
network reliability he said this if
anything fails the network shouldn't
collapse
so we built in we so we didn't say this
should be five nines of uptime we
weren't much more pragmatic we said if
any single thing fails
everybody else can still talk
so to do that you need something called
a two connected topology two independent
pairs between every pair of nodes
built in
so all those specs went to bbn they
built the dawn thing they delivered the
switch here at ucla
on schedule eight months after they got
the contract they were to deliver this
new technology
new applications new device
they did it on time
on budget
came here
we plugged it in and bits began to move
back and forth between our timeshare
machine and that switch on the day after
labor day september 2nd 1969
but that was just a one node network
the schedule was that another one of
these switches will be delivered
at stanford research institute 400 miles
to the north
and they would connect that to their
machine
and that happened in october
so in october we had a two node network
my machine my switch
another switch 400 miles away
and the sli host okay and it wasn't one
single line it was a gang of 4.8 kilo
per second lines
so now what do you do you have a two
node network well now you can do
something
so we decided one night one night late
in october
programmer charlie klein and i were in
the room and said look let's let's
communicate between the two machines
so we got a hold of bill duvall their
program there and we said let's simply
log in from a terminal connected to our
host
to that machine the idea is these are
both time sharing systems they expect
terminals to connect in and use the
services of the machine
the big thing was sit at the terminal
here log on to your machine here and
through this wonderful network
log on here as if you're a local user
well that's easy enough
so we got all set
got charlie down at the terminal over
here
and just to be sure this worked we had a
telephone here instead in fact i
actually think i've got the here it is i
just happen to have it
that was the telephone set that's the
telephone that was a telephone we
plugged it in
we drove we derived a uh we weren't
using skype
for a knife
plugged it in we used a piece of the
high speed line for the for the phone
connection but with the interesting
thing is we were using
the defunct circuit switching technology
to prove out the new packet switching
technology and it really helped us so we
could understand what's going on so
charlie typed the l who said you get the
l bill said yup got the o
type deal you get the o we're trying to
do l o g for login get the o got the o
type the g get the g
crash
so the first message ever on the network
was
low
as in lo and behold yeah
now that's especially interesting
because if you go outside this hallway
here down under the alley and come into
another entrance to this building
and you i just discovered this about a
week ago
you you walk on on a platform
and there's a mosaic of tiles down there
and they're a strange pattern
it turns out it's the ascii code for lo
and behold
i have no idea who did that
you know it's about a year and a half
now
some very clever person put that in
that was the first message october 29
1969 to 10 30 at night
entering 1969 right now
we reproduced this room to look as it
did and smell and feel like it did
some 40-odd years ago
and if you look over here
you're looking at the first piece of
equipment ever on the internet
this is that first
interface message processor
imp number one at ucla
a honeywell mini computer
adapted by both veronica newman bbn
to operate as a switch which handles
the functionality
and this is the same physical four
square feet where it served as the
opening
note
of the internet the first piece of
equipment ever on the internet and
that's the actual one that's it i kept
it for years i tried to throw it away
many times
most of the people who had imps have
tossed them this was the one or two left
around the world but this is number one
this is the first piece
if you open this machine
you'll be
privileged
to smell it yeah it's got an unusual
odor and just brings you right back yeah
the emotion it's great
you can't slow it through it this is a
military hardware machine
this this machine was
essentially a state-of-the-art mini
computer which was adopted by bbn
and i first saw it in 1968
at one of the joint computer conference
shows
thousands of people on the big big
exhibit floor and you see these sky
hooks up here
they had one of these machines hanging
from the from the ceiling
swinging in the air
running
and there's a guy
big guy
stripped to the waist
oil skin with a sledgehammer and he was
going whack right whack to show that it
was military and it was
but the most important document of the
internet the most important document
of the entire internet is right here
you talked about who is working with me
well one of my software programs was
john pastel in fact he's this picture
and he was not a hippie
even though he appears to be
he was the one who basically disciplined
my my staff to do things properly and
keep records he said we have to keep a
record of what's going on so beginning
in october
basically a month after the improvise
arrived we started keeping an imp log
you know this is an engineer's log this
is not
you know madison avenue a piece of
doctor just scribbled we use an old sds
log and in here
we kept a record of what's going on
and the most important entry happens to
be right here
on october 29 1969
at 10 30 at night
charlie klein the programmer who's in
the room with me
made this entry talk to sri host to host
this is the only record of the very
first message ever on the internet right
here
you know we had the technology we
started making measurements we were the
first experimental node
so we we saw things happening how come
we have a 50 kilo per second line the
routing procedure either goes one way or
the other one at a time how can you get
more than 50 kilos per second between
two nodes
if there's only one path at any time
and we say oh it's obvious
that path is on now when it gets backed
up you change paths so this guy's empty
and it's packed back up while you're
sending this way they go close to 100
calibers per second right too
so i think but we could break it in
words i said and every time we did
we would call bbn and say fix it we did
this fix it because they wouldn't give
us the code
they kept it proprietary until officer
said
we paid for that code you have to open
it they did we saw it every time we got
it and it would take them six months to
fix anything right
we discovered a fault this time we had
the code we showed them how to fix it
still took six months
one of the things i was very much
interested in with design was
distributed control why right
when i was a student of shannon
and shannon's great work came when you
had a lot of things interactive long
code words for example
that's when these emergent properties
arise so i said i want to design large
networks it's not a large network you
can't have a single point to control you
have to distribute it right so what does
it mean to distribute control you're
delegating authority to all the peers
when office started funding the
principal investigators they had the
same philosophy say look you're a smart
guy here's some money go do the thing
you do best we're not going to sit on
top of you make good things happen
so here we are i'm a recipient like kind
of money what do i do with it i've got
my graduate students they're billion
kids look we need a host host protocol
here
i'm not gonna sit on top of you
gonna run with it that is not a product
mentality right that is a research and
development to create them
and it worked so well
[Music]
so my favorite analogy to talk about how
packets work is postcards so let's say
that i want to send a 30 character
message to my friend daphne at stanford
but all i have is 10 character postcards
so
off i go i break my message
into three bits of ten characters i
write each piece on a different postcard
i address with a from and a two address
from chuck to daphne and then i give a
sequence number so that when she gets
the postcards she knows what order to
put them back together
so i have to label each of these and
these are fixed width and fixed length
they you know it's like a packet right
it's i'm breaking a long message that
might be very long into nothing so that
each piece is a certain size so that we
can all share it right
and so then what i do
is i send these i put them all in my
mailbox
and then i wait
and this magical thing called the post
office
picks them up
puts them in buildings people sort them
they end up on trucks they end up on
planes on trains on donkeys
by hand
and each of my postcards might take a
different route i mean one of my
postcards
i should have a map here you know one of
my posts not that one
oops do that one of my postcards you
know goes from michigan to chicago
to kansas city
to san francisco
another of my postcards goes from
michigan to chicago to dallas
to denver to kansas city to chicago to
san francisco and my third postcard goes
uh really crazy it goes to cleveland and
it goes to atlanta then it goes to
washington dc
and then it goes to chicago
and then it goes to kansas city and then
it makes it to san francisco
now the fact that they took different
paths and they might not even arrive in
order some might get past each other
they might get stuck somewhere it
doesn't matter because each one of these
has been labeled both with the from and
the two destination so each of these
intermediate locations doesn't have to
get it to the final destination they
just have to get it closer they make
choices and even if they make the wrong
choice it can be sort of dealt with one
way or the other okay
so
this is some big mystery it's called the
post office it just takes these little
cards with labels and moves them it
doesn't know
if that's a youtube video or if it's an
email it doesn't really care it just has
these little chunks to move around that
have from and two addresses i mean
that's the essence of the network
the internet the cloud that's why that's
why we draw this picture you'll see like
oh it's a cloud and that's because it's
don't worry about what's inside here
it's all super mysterious and
don't worry about it it just comes out
so
after all that happens
daphne who happens to have the exact
same mailbox as i do
it's kind of rare we both have a mailbox
that's copyright creative comments
that's what's cool about this mailbox
at some point later these things start
appearing she goes like oh looks like
chuck is sending me a note but because
of his limitation of postcards he's only
sent me one i know who it's from and i
know who it's two and i know that's the
first of some number of messages
and then the next day out comes another
one because that was the one that sort
of went the more southerly route
and she goes well i'm missing something
i'll just sit and wait and see what
happens and then finally many many days
later the uh the one that took the circa
two is most circuit
most roundabout route um
comes and now daphne can reassemble the
messages because she has
the sequences so she simply puts them
back together one two three boom
so she puts them back together she has
it she sort of throws the postcards away
and she has the ultimate final message
that's packets
packets are breaking a big message into
small parts labeling each one of them
individually and then throwing them into
the shared network and so this is what
it looks like
the post office in this
is called a gateway
okay come on gateway
okay so that's a gateway so here's
michigan
here's stanford
stanford has a gateway too that's like
their post office
in the middle is the post office box
right
and the post office box basically the
post office has intermediate locations
and it has trucks and locations these
are links and routers
and messages can take different paths
right and then they arrive and they're
reassembled
and we have like their ability to hook
from home and stuff like that so there's
a local area network lan
lan
and then there's a sort of like internet
the network of networks
it's like the post office and it still
breaks things into packets they still
come out as packets and then daphne has
to reassemble them on her computer to
create the message
so so the research network arpanet
solved a lot of engineering problems
[Music]
so
so i was a student at mit
and i was scheduled on the wonderful
scholarship program
supported by mit lincoln labs to get a
master's degree
and it was a very rigid schedule you're
going to be done in two years
get a job at lincoln lab and do research
and so i was on the program and i was
one of the few people who actually
finished on time
and as i was finishing i scheduled to
have my first child the summer of 1958
when i'm going to be done
in that summer
my professor at the surfer mechanisms
lab at mit said you have to get a phd i
said i don't want to get a phd i've done
this program i'm scheduled my child has
just been born
so you got to do it so i kept twisting
my arm and finally i said okay i'll do
it but i'm going to do it i want to work
on something that's really significant
and not piddle around for the next three
or four years
so i decided i'm going to work for the
best professor i know at mit and that
was claude shannon
the infamous wonderful magnificent
person claude channing so i called him
up
and invited me to his house and we
chatted a bit decided yes we're going to
work together
first thing i started working on
actually was a chess playing program
just working with a man who was a
delight
he was a great engineer great
mathematician
smart as heck could solve a problem like
that
i looked around at my classmates most of
whom were working for him and most of
them were working on the kind of work he
had developed namely the field of
information theory and coding theory
and i looked at them and i'd taken those
courses
and i said you know the work that
they're doing
is the work that he left behind those
problems that are left over hard
and probably not of great significance
little bits and pieces left i said
that's not what i signed up for i wanted
something to be fun exciting challenging
and have impact
meanwhile being at mit and lincoln
laboratory i was surrounded by computers
and i recognize you know one day these
computers are going to have to talk to
each other
because this is way early nobody was
thinking about that at the time but if
they're going to talk to each other what
technology would support their
communication and the interaction
and the answer is there was nothing
available
so i had an approach
i figured the way to provide the
communications would be to provide the
ability for shared communication links
because i knew that computers when they
talk they don't talk the way i am now
continuously they go blast and they're
quiet for a while although i let it
suddenly come up and blast again
and you can't afford to dedicate a
communications connection for something
which is almost never talking
but when it wants to talk i want
immediate access
so we had to not use the telephone
network which is designed for continuous
talking the circuit switch network but
something else
and i had an approach using some
mathematical thinking namely cueing
theory
there was a model i could develop
and it just made sense to do that which
we had done in time sharing and time
sharing
you have a big computer and a lot of
people share it when you're using it i'm
not when you're not i am so we sort of
interlace each other
why not use communications the same way
we're going to set up communications
capability let everybody jump in and
share and they only get to use it when
they have something to send
this is a new technology so there's an
approach i have a mathematical tool to
do it it's clearly important it will
have impact
and nobody's looked at this yet so
there's a lot of low hanging fruit
around
it's not that hard it's not that hard so
it's perfect for me
so i started working on that problem now
this was years before anybody needed
this technology
in time sharing for example which is the
underlying technology that i adapted to
communications in time sharing
you want to let the little jobs go
before the big jobs yeah
because why should little guy wait a
long time for a big chat he's going to
get in and get out
so when jobs come in you ask them how
long are you and they're all going to
say i'm tiny
so you say okay you're tiny i'll give
you a little bit of time
and if you're tiny you'll be out of
there no i'll send you to the back of
the queue and you get another tiny shot
the notion of round robin
so you get a little bit of the time
we're going to break you into little
chunks
you got a chunk at a time
i said that's a great idea for sharing
communications
will give everybody a little bit of
communications time the little ones will
filter out the short jobs to filter out
when i say job i mean message a short
message will filter out and the long
ones will take a little longer and they
don't mind being interrupted by the
little guys the important thing in this
technology was not to make the very
short messages wait behind very long
messages
this automatic round robin which is now
called packet switching you chop things
into fixed lengths you give them a
little bit it's not that's not enough
give it another piece and they go
flying to the network on their own
so the idea of packetizing was important
the idea of distributed control the idea
of large shared systems in which you get
some terrific design benefits came along
and so this got published mcgraw-hill
book
nobody cared
i published early yeah this is published
my dissertation ended in december 62 i
graduated in june 63 this book was
published in 1964. and nobody cared
nobody cared in fact i went to at t the
biggest network of the time
and i explained to them you guys ought
to give us good data communications
and their answer was what are you
talking about the united states is a
copper mine it's full of telephone wires
use that
i said no no you don't understand
it takes you
35 seconds to set up a call you charge
me a minimum of three minutes and i want
to send 100 milliseconds of data
and their answer was little boy go away
so little boy went away and with others
developed this technology which ate
their lunch
but nobody cared and they said it
wouldn't work and even if it did work
they want nothing to do with it
so that was the environment we faced
it wasn't until years later when the
government decided they needed a network
that suddenly i saw a way in which i
could implement the technology i had
but getting back to what i said earlier
i set up this mathematical model
it was analytically intractable and
still is by the way
i had two choices one is give up and
find something else
or two
make an assumption which allows them to
move forward
so i introduced a mathematical
assumption
which cracked the problem wide open
from that point i could just sail
through the solution
get the get the performance behavior get
the design principles going forward
but then the question is was that
assumption any good
what was the assumption the assumption
was what i call the independence
assumption and it's absolutely a false
assumption
it says when a message travels through
the network
it changes its length independently
every time it hits a new node on the top
through the network right
mathematically that creates an
independence which allows you to proceed
with the analysis
but it's clearly not true right
so what i had to do was to simulate a
network with and without the assumption
i simulated many networks on a machine
at lincoln laboratory on the tx2
transistorized computer there
and i spent four months
writing the simulation program
without debugging a single line of it at
a 2500 line
assembly language
simulation
and i knew if i didn't get that
simulation right i would get no
dissertation
ran it tested with and without the
assumption and the results were
amazingly close
so i had my solution i could prove it
work the package wouldn't fall on the
floor
i could tell when things would work well
and when they wouldn't
got published again still nobody cared
about it as i said lincoln laboratory
sent me for my master's dissertation
they also resent me for my phd so they
supported me for years
wonderful economic financial
research environment support
and i felt an obligation to work for
them and i was prepared to take a job at
lincoln laboratory
which is a great institution
and so i went when i went to work there
the first thing they said is look len
why don't you look outside before you
can commit to work here
make sure there's nothing out there that
you really would like better
this was a gen a magnificent
step on their part
so i took a trip to the west coast
i went to some of the
aerospace companies
i was not interested in university
position at all really
but it turns out when i was going up to
san francisco to look at some of the
high-tech companies up there
a friend of mine suggested i interview
with berkeley
so i did
i interviewed i came back they lost my
case they changed the uh the chairman i
never heard from them
but on sabbatical one of the professors
that interviewed me came to mit while i
was just finishing myself my phd then
and he sees me and he'll says klein rock
how are you and he thinks that i'm
looking for a p a an academic position
he contacts one of his friends here at
ucla who then invites me out here offers
me a job and now i've got a dilemma
do i want to teach do i want to cross
the united states it's almost like on a
wagon train 3000 miles away from the
east coast where the world is
family is
for a job paying half that i could earn
back at at mit lincoln labs
and try something i'd never tried before
so i went to the box at lincoln lab and
i said look
i've got this offer it looks attractive
it's it's a new challenge
what should i do
and there was a wonderful answer they
gave they said len
try it
if you don't like it
come back wow wow it's right yeah well i
came here in august of 63
50 years ago and i'm still here
[Music]
so here is an example problem to solve
now
none of the mailbox run of the routers
none of the post office offices know
exactly where the thing is going and
they don't transport it to the final
destination all they do is they
transport it to the future to a further
down destination but what if they get it
wrong what if one this is like
michigan this is chicago this is dallas
and what if michigan thinks sending to
chicago is a good idea chicago thinks
sending to dallas is a good idea and the
dallas thinks sending to michigan is a
good idea well then michigan is going to
get it again and send it back to chicago
and so then what you end up with is this
situation where your packet your data is
in a loop
right this wouldn't be good for the post
office and it's not good for the
internet
so you have to say how do we solve this
problem when something's wrong right
it's you wish it were perfect but it's
not
and so this is the kind of research
question as to how to solve this kind of
problem and we'll talk more about this
in a bit uh when we get into a little
more technical detail but i just wanted
to sort of say that's the kind of
research in engineering that took
literally 20 years and four different
versions of it of the arpanet to get
right
[Music]
there was this whole world of
of coders and
hardware guys in the 60s and i thought
to myself i bet there's a really
interesting story here so
my editor at simon and inchester was
totally
100 behind it
uh we the working title was really bad
it was called building cyberspace so
we knew we needed a new title
and so
and matt my late husband didn't come in
on the project uh he was actually a
better writer than i am and a wonderful
just had an absolutely incredible mind
and could grasp anything
and uh he didn't come in on the project
until about maybe a year into it
when i was getting overwhelmed i had
this new baby and i was working
at newsweek
and i was
uh and i realized that there was just
more to the story than i could do myself
it would have taken me like double
double the time
so um that's when he came in on the
project and
i found indeed that there was this
incredible untold story of not so much
the internet so we have to keep it
really clear the arpanet and how that
started and
um
in fact matt's the one who wrote the
chapter the fastest million dollars
which is about how it got funded
um at ipto the information processing
techniques office
at what was then derpa and then became
urban and darpan and arpagon and uh
these people were all as i had hoped
incredibly interesting
really smart
and uh
and had this new idea for how computers
could talk to each other
and um
one of the most amazing things was uh
visiting
um larry roberts who
was
running ipto at the time that this whole
thing was drawn out we were at his house
in woodside and we went out into the
garage this is how
unresearched this topic was because you
know huda thunk right
and
we go out into his garage and there are
all these boxes
of old mildewy papers and he starts
pulling them out and they're old
letters
between him and people at mit and
then he pulls out this amazing set of
sketches
of him just it's like remember when um
trudeau doonsbury did inside reagan's
brain this was like inside larry
robert's brain he was like just
sketching out all the possible
configurations
of um
what this network could look like and
i've got these pictures in the book
which you can show
but here you know
you know these these are all his very
early diagrams
um
just sort of popping out of his head
this is when this is you know the the
early nodes on the arpanet
and i just loved finding all this
incredible primary source material
and it was a
it was uh i felt like i should have been
paying somebody to be able to do this
rather than
right because it's just in a it's in a
garage that millions of people drive by
right and it's also this important
artifact yeah of the what we're living
right now right and we were able to sort
of you know capture it and bulk baranika
newman was a big force behind the book
the book was in part their idea
and so these guys because what we tend
to forget
is that bbn
they built the first amp
and the interface message processor
in fact there's a very funny story in
the book where ted kennedy
you know senator from massachusetts
sends a letter to bbn
congratulating them on getting the
contract for the interfaith message
process
i know uh so a completely uncharted
territory and they had to build this
piece of hardware which they did and
program it which they did a whole new
thing and uh
it was uh so i spent a lot of time with
the folks at bbn got to know them well
and that group they were completely on
school in talking to you know
reporters or
a book researcher and there's this one
guy
ray tomlinson everybody said oh you
should go talk to ray because he uh came
up with the at sign i said oh really
okay
and so you know there's this wonderful
really
quiet guy ray tomlinson sitting in his
office and i
knocked on his door i said i understand
you came up with the outside he goes oh
yeah yeah and then he explains to me you
know how it is that he
did this and then you know and now it's
a huge legend that ray tomlinson did
this and uh
and
uh other and some the software guys uh
really i have this image if you sort of
just driving and driving and going and
going back and forth i mean what how
long was the research how long did you
research this was this i think yeah the
research took a couple of years
and it wasn't so much driving that the
hacker book was like driving all over
all over the place because that was
three different stories of three
different hackers
this was more in fact email between the
hacker book and this book and the and
wizards so 1988 and like when i started
this book 1990
email had come it was much more popular
so
there were a lot of we did a lot of
emailing back and forth i spent a lot of
time i did go from i was living in
austin at the time i did go from um
uh austin to boston a lot and i spent a
lot of time actually i did fly to la and
spent a lot of time with john pastel
who came up with the domain name system
and
um uh and he died
in 90
i want to say 98 99.
that was shocking uh i spent a lot of
time with him tell me about it um
tell me about john well john uh so
anyone who's ever seen a picture of john
maybe you have one you can dig up
this very long kind of santa claus like
beard and what's amazing is so i spent a
lot of time at his house he lived in a
teeny tiny little house
in uh in the la area
and uh with his girlfriend this very
nice woman named susan
and uh on the refrigerator there were
all these family photos and they all
they were all like these
uh people with long beards long white
beards and i thought one of an
interesting family
and he drove i think this kind of beat
up volvo or something like that
you know something completely
unpretentious
and lived so unpretentiously and
uh
and had all his files like right in his
study in this little house all this
history and also at isi where he worked
in marina del rey
and uh
and we spent hours and hours and hours
together first in boston um at where we
were both at a
an anniversary party of the um of the
arpanet
and we spent a lot of time together and
i thought you know this guy is key and
he was so
quiet that sort of getting him to open
up really meant spending a lot of time
with him and he was oh and we met at one
of the very first inec conferences in
1995 in hawaii and spent a lot of time
there and he just was so patiently
trying to explain to me
um
things but i'll never forget this one
thing that happened with him in hawaii
at the inec conference it's
the internet society conference one of
the very early ones and uh
and
i just was asking him some questions and
he goes uh
he looked completely disturbed and
distracted and he said no no there's
someone over across the room i have to
talk to and it was someone from a very
small country
sort of wanting to talk to john
about their domain the country's domain
name or something but to john it was far
more important that he deal with this
person's problem then you know
then cement his place in history in this
arpanet history in fact
when i was working on the book
i sent him an email i'll never forget
this i think i don't have the email
anymore and i said just out of curiosity
why
haven't you ever
like wanted to
get rich
because that's when people were just
starting to get rich so this was in 95
and he said it just
that's just not what this is about
isn't that a wonderful thing it is yeah
and that's who john was one of the
things that i've been curious about is
how this got by att
right how this made it past 18 i know
talk about no vision
right and uh
well you know paul barron had happened
he had couldn't convince at t to build
the
very uh marvelous network that he uh
designed and then
these other guys the next guys the next
crew that came in
uh
and they just they were very very you
know think about it back then it was
they had a monopoly what did they really
care
they had
um
they had the um
bell
uh
research labs
and
they it was a non-invented here kind of
syndrome
and
they
they didn't see they didn't see it i
mean talk about no vision they simply
didn't see it but i think the fact that
not invented here part of it was um
like what would we need uh what would we
possibly
need this for yeah they were in a
context
they were in their own context yeah
but thank goodness i mean thank goodness
they didn't get their hands on this
thing the same with ibm sorry you know
just
we don't we didn't want corporate
america
or deck for that matter
um the original hardware was um based on
a honeywell machine and thank goodness
honeywell doesn't exist anymore uh it
sounds terrible that i'm saying this but
it's but it was all
kind of happy
accidental
sort of
coincidences i think al gore is
oh what oh totally underestimated and
underappreciated is that what you were
going to say oh yeah
i mean why mock him every time
every time i tell people i wrote a
history of
the origins of the internet
um people say very mockingly oh did al
gore invented and i won't play into that
he played a huge role
in terms of policy
and direction
and uh
and when uh clinton was uh
running for president you know they were
out there with this very important uh
technology white paper
that uh
uh
i mean you can't do things like this
unless you have
the support that people like al gore
provided
[Music]
by the end of the 1970s there was quite
a sophisticated network like i said
they'd rewritten it four times it had
gotten to be very sophisticated there'd
been a good investment they had been
careful about understanding how to
improve it each time they rebuilt it
and so it was a really a fine working
piece of software and the people who
used it at these research universities
and
um
at the military it was kind of like a
futuristic world right you could send
email and a second later it would appear
right it was really quick and everything
was nice and you could even have instant
message like interactions where it went
right then
and
the problem was is this was a small
group of people this is maybe
looks like 60 or so
that was all the computers on the entire
internet right i mean now we have
our cell phones and we got billions of
them right but this is like 60.
um
so real question is how did this go from
60 computers of a very narrow group
to
a much larger group and the answer to
that question
is at urbana-champaign illinois
and so
at the same time
that this kind of goes back to bletchley
park right where the computers were part
of science
throughout the 50s and 60s and 70s
scientists much like the military
realizing the computers were mighty
useful to advance scientific research
and so the national science foundation
would fund universities to buy computers
and they'd say give me 10 million
dollars to buy a computer and another
universe would be like give me 10
million to buy a computer and then three
years later the first university said my
computer's obviously i needed another 10
million dollars
now the research questions were good
research questions and they were
important to society but the national
science foundation got tired of giving
10 million dollars to every everybody
i was part of this because i used to be
a high performance computer guy this is
a
convex c3800 supercomputer
uh i would be about this tall on this
super computer this is a
lovely and very expensive model that i
was given after
afterwards they were going to throw it
away because this is from like 1987.
um
and and basically i wanted one of these
terribly badly each one of these is
about two million dollars this is like
two four six eight ten million dollars
and i so badly wanted this and i thought
that i i deserved a ten million dollar
toy and i could do such great research
but unfortunately everybody else wanted
the exact same thing
and they were important too so the
national science foundation said to
themselves hey
this isn't going to work very well if i
can't find my pen
um
you know we're not going to we're going
to make a network
how about we put a few of these things
in and then make a network and connect
them together
of course it's never as simple as that
so now we're going to meet
larry smarr
at the national center for super
computing applications ncsa
at the university of illinois
urbana-champaign
and larry was the director of ncsa and
one of them one of the many people but
one of the most instrumental people
in creating the national network
that we now think of as the internet and
getting it moving it from being a
research project to being a project that
we
all both academics and regular people
that we all can can make really good use
of and so let's take a look at larry
smar
[Music]
well i am a
trained relavistic astrophysicist and i
got my phds always in physics
departments working on astrophysics
problems involving
general relativity gas dynamics and so
forth and so in the 70s when
i was developing what is now called
numerical gene relativity which is the
way to solve line sense equations for
dynamics of black holes colliding black
holes or in astrophysics
that require generality like supernova
events and so on
uh i had
uh to go and get a top secret nuclear
weapons clearance to get access to
supercomputers because in the mid 70s
the only place to get a supercomputer
was
either at livermore los alamos or uh in
one area which was weather
now astronomy has always been a driver
of supercomputing and in fact
on johnny von neumann's computer that
was built
by the institute
half of that and went to army
to aberdeen half of that was used of
course for the army for
trajectory
calculations but the other half was used
for stellar evolution so astronomy and
von neumann's interest in weather meant
that astronomy and weather
for 50 years basically have been
dominant drivers of supercomputing usage
and yet
uh to do pure astrophysics you're having
to get a top-secret nuclear weapons
clearance now nobody seemed to think
there was anything unusual about this
um and so i just went ahead as a postdoc
and i would get a few months in the
summer work 100 hours a week
and then the last of the year i'd have
to live off that go back to harvard
where i was a junior fellow try to
explain to them about you know
one could solve the laws of physics that
we had been laying down for 300 years
and incredible detail for engineering
devices like nuclear weapons that
put on earth temperatures of the center
of the sun
stresses beyond anything that we could
imagine in academic problems that we're
trying to solve in lots of disciplines
so this thing could revolutionize
academic research well nobody
got it it was like i really felt like i
was transitioning
in a flying saucer between this advanced
civilization at livermore and the stone
age culture at harvard and harvard was
as advanced as any place and thinking
about this so it was a
what i did not figure this out until it
was in the
early 80s and
by then the first cray had gone into the
continent of europe in an open
scientific institute the box plonk
institute of physics and astrophysics so
i'm over there in the summer
along with people like dave arnett who
is one of the great supernova
super computer guys in our country and
people in chemistry and it was like
paris in the 20s with all these
expatriates sitting over there and and
we're like trying to figure this out
like it's an american-built
supercomputer right why are we in munich
right i mean this is
very strange so um but you know in
america we don't question
the infrastructure somehow i mean it's
just like it's either there or it isn't
there or that's just the way it is
but i was having a moss of beer late one
night
actually think it was a second masa beer
with my german host who had also been
born like i was post-war
and he finally turns to me and he says
aren't you ashamed of yourself
you big rich occupying country you come
over here in our little country
and and we finally get enough money
scraped together after world war ii to
buy one of these super computers and you
americans come over here and use up our
time it says how did you guys ever win
the war you know what what is going on
here
and so this finally sort of
just stimulated me to say what is going
on here this is nuts and i went back and
i found out for instance
that after the sputnik program
the federal government had funded the
universities built the science buildings
started the supercomputer centers ibm
would go around and give away almost the
mainframes and and so the scientists in
the 60s took it for granted that they
had the fastest computers in the world
in academia
but about 1970 with the starting the
vietnam war and with all kinds of guns
and butters issues and everything else
that
stopped
and in fact to give an example by 78
half the number of phds and engineers in
engineering was being generated in our
country as there were in 1970.
so there was this complete
severing of the sputnik era
partnership with the federal government
and it was particularly bad in computing
to give you an example when i was at
livermore in
in the 70s there were four cdc 7600s
which were just one of the finest
supercomputers ever built
no american university ever took
delivery of a single cdc 7600
in fact the university of illinois when
i first got here had a cyber 175 which
was a retread a second
design manufacturing of of this thing
and we were one of the first
universities that had it and people all
thought that you know illinois naturally
was way ahead of everybody else so it's
like
we were just completely divorced from
the private sector that was generating
these wonderful machines because of
federal policy which was to say
these things are only are so valuable
that we can only afford to put them into
war environments
so after this german encounter i
came back and i said well gee i wonder
how many other scientists like me are
there
so at the university of illinois
i started calling cold calling my
colleagues and saying
hi you don't know me i'm a little
assistant professor but i bet you that
your research is blocked by lack of
access to super computers uh and they'd
sort of say like
who crack wreck who is this you know
grant call
and but we'd start talking in chemistry
and biology and agriculture
and
so on and sure enough it turns out that
that that was true they knew how to do
the science they just didn't have access
so i said well send me a little
prospectus of what science you could do
if you had a supercomputer
well i ended up with 65 faculty in 15
departments on one campus
and i thought this has got to be this
way all over the country
so
it was i really started
saying well gee somebody's got to raise
this issue and about that time
there had been a lacks report that had
the federal government had done to begin
to undercover some of this stuff but
they still weren't i remember peter lax
he was one of the greatest
mathematicians
uh head of one of the top people in the
kron institute a long time
advocate of
things computational
and i had this long long
battle with peter because in the draft
report of the lax report it was not it
was going to say well yeah we ought to
get one of these super computers and
make it available to the universities
but you know let's put it livermore put
it somewhere that people know how to do
this stuff and a university was not on
the list
of what the lacks report considered to
be appropriate sites for a supercomputer
so i had this long
battle over the telephone i remember
with peter lacks
sort of david and goliath because i mean
he was this giant of the field i'm
nobody
and um
i i finally convinced him not to exclude
universities as a possibility even
though he felt that it was fairly
unlikely that any of them would be able
to play with sharp instruments and not
hurt themselves
so i mean you gotta understand the world
was totally different
when the supercomputer centers program
was coming into being and people it's so
hard for people now on the web and
everything to go back to that time there
was no internet
you know there was there was these
wonderful people vince cerf and bob khan
and all these people bill joy who had
developed tcp and and and embodied it in
the arpanet this was a few computer
science
departments and military okay
nobody in a physics department or
chemistry department ever heard of the
arpanet much less had any access to it
but it was obviously the right idea
and so once we got the
congress to put through money for a
national supercomputer program then
there was a national competition and
and and so on and the five centers were
selected
the first thing then the nsf realized
well okay now we put these in place to
be providing access to academic
scientists and yet uh like they have to
fly to champaign-urbana like i had to
fly to livermore okay this isn't right
so there were a lot of discussions then
but the trouble was that the telecom
lobbyist in washington
would block any discussion of the
federal government putting in the kind
of network we have today which is what
people wanted i mean everybody knew that
they wanted to have a ubiquitous email
person-to-person network but as soon as
they'd start talking about that the
telecom lobbyist would come up and say
no way guys that's private sector don't
get the federal government involved in
that stay out of it
so what we learned early on is real
interesting it's like if we had argued
instead of the super computer program
let's get the federal government to buy
everybody a personal computer
which was ibm personal computer was two
years old in 1985 and put on people's
desk okay again this would be an
interference with the private sector
um so but we said oh we'll just take a
few of these esoteric supercomputers and
they said okay that's right there's no
market there that's okay the federal
government has a role well the same
thing with networking what we said is we
just want to put a high-speed backbone
across the country to connect the five
centers
and and the telecom people said okay
that's cool you know 56 kilobits was the
national high-speed backbone less than
isdn today
yeah that's not a market okay
and and we said we got a few of these
weird super computer types who are out
universities who want to hook into that
they say yeah that's okay that's not a
market you can do that
well
that was the nsf net backbone then the
regionals got funded and then the
campuses were afraid that if they didn't
dig up their quad and put in some fiber
then the professors who wanted to get
access to supercomputers would go to a
university that would do that
so
gradually the whole internet emerged out
of
the
the sort of policy
vice you get into washington
where you can't do the right thing
you have to do something that seems
irrelevant
but
has a logic to it that will gradually
bring the market forces into play
that will spin out ultimately a whole
industry
so i hope you got from that that it
wasn't trivial it wasn't like somebody
just walked out and said hey make a
network i mean
there were
forces powerful forces the telecom
lobbyists that did not want this to
happen
and we will we will see these telecom
lobbyists a couple times
as we progress through this lecture
so
larry smart and the folks that made the
supercomputers convince congress to
authorize the
the
giving of a grant to build the national
science foundation's network it was
going to use the tcp protocol that the
arpanet had built
it was supposed to be inclusive at least
for research
academics and it was you know research
universities would we want to get them
connected
and so our story now leads from the
university of illinois urbana-champaign
to
my university the university of michigan
now if you take a look at this
arpanet picture that was sort of right
before well 1972 but if you look at all
of the arpanet pictures there is a
glaring omission
from my perspective declaring a mission
on all of these i wonder why aren't we
there well there's a very good reason
why the university of michigan is not on
any of the arpanet pictures and that's
because we build our own network
we build a network using lease lines a
three-node network between michigan
state university university of michigan
and wayne state university we were
sharing each other's compute resources
we were using each other's computers
interactively we were playing online
multi-user games we called them
adventure they were all based on text
but they were great fun and they were
great community building we had chat
forums we had all kinds of things and we
used each other's software and it was a
is a cool little world
and the arpanet
wasn't seen by many is all that
significant it was kind of a experiment
right it was a research project and we
were a researcher we were production
merit was production and arpanet was
research so there you go right so there
was actually a lot of these sort of like
nascent networks out there early days
and so the university of michigan sort
of never really was significantly
involved in the arpanet work but
the university of michigan being a large
university did want to get a
supercomputer center and because of some
strategic blunders as doug van hollen
will soon explain to you
um
michigan didn't get a super computer
center and so the idea was is we would
do what it was going to take to get the
network because that might be more fun
so doug van hollen at the time was the
chief information officer at the
university of michigan having recently
arrived from carnegie mellon university
and he was also the
chief of the merit network the network
that connected our three schools and so
they they figured that once they didn't
get a super computer
center they better really pull out the
stops so to get so that they would get
the nsf net
and of course they did get the nsf net
and doug van hollen was the principal
investigator for the nsf net starting in
1988.
so let's let doug van gaaling talk to
tell you the story and i'll be back in a
moment
[Music]
back in the
mid 80s
the national science foundation decided
to establish super computing centers
and the university of michigan was one
of the organizations that made a
proposal for a national super computing
center the michigan proposal had as a as
its primary hardware artifact a machine
that was built in japan
and
i explained to my colleagues my new
colleagues the university of michigan
having just arrived that it was highly
unlikely that the proposal would be
funded
a short while later i was visiting the
national science foundation and i had
gotten to know not well but had gotten
to know eric block who was then director
of the national science foundation
and
eric and i had a conversation about
michigan's proposal
and um it was clear to me from my
conversation with eric that there was no
prospect that the michigan proposal
would be funded i said to eric i said
well it occurs to me that what might be
even better for the university of
michigan than
having a supercomputing center is to run
the network that connects all of the
supercomputing centers together i had an
old friend
who worked for ibm research by the name
of al weiss
who's in charge of all of ibm research's
computing facilities and
i called al and i said al
uh this is a great opportunity but
ibm is going to uh is is not going to be
successful here and um i need your help
and so i also rallied some folks from
ibm research where there actually was
work going on in tcpi
protocols we got tentatively an
agreement from ibm that they would
contribute the hardware
and the software
to create the routing
structure for the network
but we still needed the communications
facilities
and
at that time
the cfo at ibm was a gentleman i think i
remember the name correctly by his last
name was crow
and
um
so through ibm we went to him and he had
contacts with a former ibm employee
who is now the
network that
chief technical officer and essentially
the chief network operations
officer for mci his name was dick lee
paper
and
so ibm
approached dick lee paper and asked him
if mci would be interested in providing
the communications facilities for this
network well
as you may recall
at that time mci was this fledgling
organization some people had described
it really as as a as a law office
trying to create
an environment where they could actually
offer telecommunications services up
against att's lobbying efforts and they
were they had just been successful in
that they were establishing
uh
facilities across the united states and
uh and dick lebhaver saw this as an
opportunity to sort of move
mci into the big time um
to be part of this nsf net proposal and
so we wound up with an agreement
that we would file a joint proposal
with merit as the principal organization
in partnership with ibm who would build
all the routing
hardware and software and with mci who
would provide the nationwide
communications facilities
and while we were and
then we got
governor blanchard to commit a million
dollars a year from state funds in
addition
so we wound up being able to submit a
proposal to the national science
foundation i think for something like
14.7 million dollars because we knew the
ceiling was 15
but in fact by including all this
in-kind uh activity it was actually more
like a
55 million dollar
proposal it was designed to start at t1
or 1.5 megabits
uh with planned upgrades over the over
the period of the network
network's life
um
we've subsequently learned that uh the
proposal was received with considerable
skepticism by the reviewers of the
national science foundation
uh people really wondered about our
technical ability to pull this off but
uh the that review
was conducted without
reference to the actual funding pattern
and then when the raps got pulled off of
the
amount of resource that was being
committed by the partners to this
proposal it immediately went to the top
of the list
at the nsf and
and a short period later we received uh
informal word that they wanted to
negotiate with us about sort of working
this all out but we had to do a lot of
innovation uh the border gateway
protocols had to be developed to allow
multiple networks to interact with one
another
and we had to build increasingly more
capable routing and communications
facilities
when we started
the network
we had t1 circuits
but there were no
cards for computers that would go at one
and a half megabits
we used the t1 circuits we subdivided
and built a mesh network among all of
the routers that we put in place
it wasn't for about a year ibm was
actually to build prototype cards that
would go at one and a half
uh megabits
when we put those when we put those
cards in our test network
we discovered
they they worked just fine we put them
in the production network the network
started failing on us and we discovered
after
uh
after a very tough period
that
the folks who had built the t1 hardware
for mci
had planned on using certain bit
patterns to do diagnosis on the network
and it never anticipated the notion that
anybody would ever use a full and a half
megabits as a single channel they had
always thought that it would be broken
up into a set of voice uh circuits at 64
kilobits each and so they didn't have
any worry about these patterns ever
appearing on their network well it
turned out that that happened
with some frequency
uh on
the nsf net and it took the
communications line down when it did so
they had to re-engineer
their hardware
to
undertake this we actually had for a
short period of time put some
translation circuits in our routers that
actually looked for these bit patterns
took them out and replaced them with
something else uh and then reinsert them
at the other end uh to make it work over
these t1 circuits so we had a lot of
adventure
finally
in
i think it was around 1990
network was growing so fast that it was
clear that these t1 circuits were not
going to
we're not going to enable what we needed
to do
so we had to go to the next step which
was
ds3 or from one and a half megabits to
45 megabits which was a very large step
a 30-fold increase in capacity
and in order to do that um we
wound up creating another
not-for-profit organization called
advanced network and services
merit was still the principal
investigator on the grant but it
subcontracted
the development of
this new network this 45 megabit network
to advanced network and services which
was headquartered in armonk
and uh
and
ibm
mci
and uh nortel who
uh all contributed
three million dollars to the founding of
this new uh organization so it had the
uh the staff and the facilities to do
the innovation that required us to go
up to
45 megabits
that did accommodate
our capacity needs
over the life of the nsf net
the nsf net was the fastest internet
network
to the end
it finally
was decommissioned
in
when the congress decided that the
federal government should not be in the
business of supporting something that by
that time
in their view
should have been
become a commercial facility
i'll not ever forget
sitting in
a house hearing room in the capitol
and
next to mitch kapoor
and um
some internet
uh
some small internet company uh startup
ceos who were complaining
uh to the
congress
that it was inappropriate for
the nsf net to be funded by
by the national science foundation when
they could provide this service
as a commercial service
at the very same time they were making
that complaint they were using nsfnet
as
their
backup network
to carry traffic
when their much less reliable networks
failed on a national scale mci of course
turned out to be a major internet
service provider also using the same
technology
in a
in a classic um
innovators curse moment
ibm who was at that time the leader in
routing technology for
uh internet
for
internet backbones
managed to decide
that they should kill
all of the work they had done in
developing these routers because it
would threaten their proprietary network
efforts
it's probably almost single-handedly
responsible for the fact that cisco
became the dominant router
company in the united states rather than
ibm
[Music]
so
as you can see none of this is easy
it wasn't easy for larry smart
and now we basically have the lobbyist
once again the lobbyists are deciding
that there's only going to be 15 million
dollars because if it's 15 million
dollars they can only build a 56 kilobit
line
but michigan thought outside the box
some people might say we cheated
other universities wanted to get the
grant kind of thought we did cheat we
didn't play by the rules like in star
trek we rewrote the rules so we got it
and we slid underneath the nose of a t a
one and a half megabit network that
started started large and started fast
and got faster and as doug talked it was
a very very very successful network and
it it didn't it had follow-on effects
just like larry talked about it had
these follow-on effects of causing
campuses to build networking because in
would come this really fast national
network so you better fix the on-campus
networking so it was really quite
wonderful and the partners ibm mci the
other thing is is a t was being beat up
by mci at the time and maybe they
weren't noticing so we might have been
lucky it could easily have been two
years earlier or two years later it
might not have worked so
whatever it did work and and we can be
very grateful
so the university of michigan
was sort of the
center of they ran the network operating
asian center and did the network design
worked on the software with ibm and
built the network and um it
had a very exponential growth as it went
forward
this building right here is on our north
campus and it was for me personally the
very first place that i typed the first
characters that went across the internet
i walked in this door to i wasn't at the
university at that time
but i had friends here and so i came in
and i was typing on you know hello on
the internet so this building was where
the network operation center was
and um where i touched the internet for
the the nsf net for the first time so it
started out real simple
but its goal its goal was
to enable connections to other networks
the regional networks got formed larry
smart mentioned that and so then the
backbone became sort of a forcing
function to get more campuses on and
more and more states etc etc
[Music]
do
in the case of ghana
private sector led
government was not aware government was
not interested
and so the private sector took it out
but the private sector we're discussing
is me
i'm not exactly private sector i'm
academic
only i did this job through the private
sector
meaning that i realized that
you can wait for the university forever
because they depend on government and
you can wait for the government forever
they have no clue
so i actually have been known to have
said publicly
that
i cannot wait for the government to do
it for the country
so i know how to do it i would do it no
matter how small it is just to make the
point that we are able to do it in so
doing maybe i can create an avalanche
that will carry through the momentum and
that is what i try to do in the case of
them
now on the continent as a whole they
have variety
like
in the case of egypt
where
the minister there happens to be one of
our counterparts from internet society
isak
and that's tara camel
and so there was a heavy government
success
built
in other places
like south africa there was good
academic dose
so it has varied depending on on the
settlements but i think in much of west
africa the trust
had been principally from private sector
because i also went around helping togo
private sector helping gambia private
sector and so even nigeria giving them
intellectual property so they could also
begin to do it so it became privacy
helping private sector but for the
common good because we really felt that
we had to go together otherwise things
would just
disappear i allow some countries to
transit their data through me
and togo was an example
but in other places i actually sent
engineers to install
notes for them and gambia was an example
in other cases i actually trained people
like swaziland they brought
the telco people to me to be trained
in other cases we did consulting
services to help ethiopia and so on and
so forth so that was roughly the
progression in that the names had to
confess but i was meaningful and we had
to move mail and so we had to do that
and then the next bit was get the
capacities connected
and download was a madras but it was a
good community activity in the sense
that we wanted to help each other and
that has continued till now because now
i actually run the african network
operators group and the principal
function of this group
is to
sort of help operators support
themselves
and usually we support ourselves with
building our capacity in many different
areas mostly in
infrastructure related things like
routing type of issues or server
services type of issues for those who
want to build information resources
um the afnog has now become the meeting
place for most of the technical
community and we meet only once a year
and when we meet his life for a product
of two weeks within which we spend one
week to train whoever has been admitted
into the into the workshops and we run
four workshops in parallel now it didn't
start as four it started as just two and
then we've added as we went along we
even have a french track in the in the
routing side of things
um
and when we meet after the workshops for
the students then we try to sort of
induct the students into what the real
world is so we follow the workshop with
meetings and the meetings including lots
of parallel sessions
those who are following the affiliate
meetings will get to do that those who
may be discussing some tutorials maybe
in security
we'll also get to do that and then we
also have a day for like conference
presentations or 20 30 minutes from a
variety of different areas and so that
has now become a major meeting place for
the engineers and
once a year we all congregate and it's
supposed to be service to community type
of thing
in that nobody gets paid but we try to
raise money for the student participants
to come and we've been getting funding
cisco has been a regular funding source
and we've got funding from idrc internet
society
francophone and a whole number of others
but over time we're trying to change our
programs so that we become more
self-sustaining
so participants who are coming in from
let's say operators telcos and so on we
insist that they pay more of their way
so that we can raise funding for
academic and research people to
participate and so on and that was
really how how things are and it still
continues to be a major meeting point
for for many of our operators of course
once we've got the connectivity in
then there's a whole host of other
issues that began to show up
but we thought all of them can be solved
within the same environment so you have
necessity issues oh you have aftld
let afj focus that
you have a research and educational
network challenge or build a consensus
around the same meeting place so to
understand afnoc has moved from being
a workshop type of thing to a meeting
place where many new things could be
incubated and allowed to blossom and
take on their own life
[Music]
now the particular case about the
was interesting in that we it took us 10
years to get to accreditation
of course in the beginning we actually
knew what it was
we knew was very important and for
engineers we knew that that was what to
focus on
none of the other things
so we began to build consensus around it
you know a proposal was made first in 95
then 97 a formal document
and then
we moved on but we realized that we had
to build something more than just casual
meetings so we went deliberately to
tottenham to agree on specifics and the
specifics was
who becomes a member of the board
and we decided to do it geographically
okay so that we don't get too much
caught into why is that there are so
many people from the north and nobody
from the south so okay each one of the
sub regions gets to elect one person so
if the members who elect that person and
that person would save for a period of
one to three years depending on the
staggering and that is how that one was
okay but the the difficult thing with
that was
as we're learning that meant more and
more were coming
so when whenever we thought we had an
agreement on something we're about to
move forward like in operation then more
people come one case was very disturbing
and then that's uh sort of a moment
and that one john kuster was also there
this was very early and he had agreed
that me just do it you have to do it has
to happen
so
i invited them all to a meeting with the
african engineers and everything
and suddenly somebody got up and said no
no no why don't we share it up into the
countries and have this all go our
separate ways
and i mean at that point i thought that
was the end of the world
and to be honest with you i've never
felt so ashamed
because
i was a bit of an interface between the
african technical community and the
global community i knew young poster
myself personally and they've come to
sort of help me
and my people were not ready
so all john could say to me was
get your people ready
and you will have it
so i had to continue
until i was able to
build sufficient consensus and in 205
began
and at that point was also evident that
if he has taken so long there are maybe
two factors i have to consider
in 10 years i would have upset a lot of
people
and
this could be real in the sense that the
regis three registries had to give up
something for affiliate to exist
so it's inevitable that i would have
made a number of people in those three
registries uncomfortable
so for me it was obvious i
could not continue in the same capacity
of course i didn't tell my colleagues
that this was my real feeling
but it was also true that
if i were to stay there i'll get less
participation i'll have less motivation
for people to you know make an effort
and what i needed more was more people
making effort
than just one person driving things
because i knew that the space was so
large that even if i had nothing to do
with these things there was plenty for
me to do
so
the strategic thinking was
find a way to exit
without telling anybody make sure
you don't give up too much information
for people to capitalize and game on it
so everybody thought i was indeed going
to be the next official chair
not the you know startup chair but
official chair and i let them think so
but when it came to the board meeting i
decided to dissolve the board and i got
vote for it
and then i decided i would not run again
and at the same time certain people have
been
you might say
controversial in their contribution
i try to urge them not to and in some
cases i even told them that if you tried
i would martial the community to vote
you out and in some cases they tried and
they were voted out
but that created a certain flow of uh
maybe new entrants wanted to contribute
service to the community
and that has continued till now and and
i think that
that has been a very good thing and of
course we also observe in the case of
afrin that the ability to make local
policy
uh does
affect the effectiveness of you know
the task at hand
so for example we know that
uh
soon after accreditation
the
type of membership we had
begin to skew more towards the smaller
size because majority of the operators
were actually small operators and they
were trying to fit into a large markets
a large operator community environment
when we were working with right and
arranging and so on and that wasn't
working so well so by us changing the
policy to recognize the size the two
sides of our operators were able to
increase the membership
and beyond that we realized that our
location also we changed the policy so
that our location sizes were smaller
than the normal that a person a typical
operator will get so by knowing the
community and making the policies the
community making the policy to suit
itself you're able to get a better match
to the needs of the community and and
that has shown in the growth and uptake
of at least ipv4
addresses
from affirmative
[Music]
now one of the things that was quite
interesting is we in the academic field
had the right to use this network but
when it first started out it was
supposed to be academic only
and then once it was established in the
late 80s and early 90s
there were some people that started sort
of like bending those rules or bypassing
those rules or ignoring those rules and
it wasn't really clear who was supposed
to police those rules and the people
like at the university of michigan they
their heart wasn't in
reducing who would use the internet they
wanted to expand right and so there were
places um often bulletin board systems
uh would somehow get a connection to the
internet and then they would give
internet access to a bunch of
non-academics and so it became
increasingly in the late eighties
understood by everyone around the world
but this is pretty much nerds right they
can sit with a screen
with a command line interface with the
text based screen and they can get
excited about that i'm i'm like that i
can get excited about things that are
non-graphical because i just make it up
in my head
but we needed something to pop this into
the collective consciousness of all
humanity rather than just
academics first and then nerds
second
but
that was about to change so i started
our picture where we had super computers
at university illinois
we went to university of michigan we got
the nsf net funded and now we're going
to fly across the ocean to cern
cern of course is a high energy physics
laboratory
they do this 26 mile circle and smash
particles and take pictures of the
smashing particles and looking for the
higgs boson or found the higgs boson
um
it's a really cool place i recommend
that you visit the
cern is a place that physicists from all
over the world
visit
live at
and collaborate with
for experimental physics it really
revolves around those experimental
facilities and so regardless of whether
you live in russia or australia or
germany or america or japan if you're an
energy nuclear physicist you have got to
work with cern or spend time at cern and
those who spend time at cern tend to
make the best discoveries
and so these projects have such long
lead times and they take so many
different kinds of talented people you
know they're metallurgy welders
physicists engineers
designers project managers there's a ton
of people involved in it and it's a
pretty well funded operation and
everyone's pretty smart so one of the
things that they do
is they have fun they have these clubs
like the softball club the cricket club
the blues club and and it's kind of like
these people are somewhat away from home
a lot and so they just have fun with
each other
this is a picture that i will show you
of the cernettes they are famous for
being the first band photo on the web
some people wonder if they're the very
first photo on the web but they
uh are a doo-wop group and they sing
sort of 50 style doo-wop songs they are
very fun to watch
but their songs are about like
particles and
internet and modems and stuff like that
stuff that i care a lot about um they
sadly they've been they've been doing
this since the 1990s um you know 1991 92
kind of time frame um and they all grew
up and their kids grew up and their kids
were all in college and so they they did
their farewell tour in 2011 and i and
one of them's moved to australia so we
don't know if the cernettes are ever
going to get back together and sing but
for now they're on permanent hiatus but
for your viewing pleasure take a quick
look at one or more of the cernette
songs
[Music]
so like i said you should go visit cern
i have had the great fortune to visit
cern i have visited cern with an on
professional uh in a professional role i
help them record lectures with my
synchromatic software that you may have
heard me talk about um
i
i have visited sort of in helping other
technology things and i
uh teaching and learning with technology
and things like that and so they've got
a a wonderful cafe
and if you're working with people you
get to go in the back and hang out
that's pretty cool they also have a
wonderful museum that you can go see the
first web server and all kinds of other
cool stuff and uh in 2006
06 i was lucky enough to have an invited
talk at cern where i talked about sakai
and how they might use sakai to do
collaborative work and
i brought my family with me and so my
wife theresa and my daughter mandy and
my son brent and there is me
we are in the pit and this pit is like
like eight or nine stories underground
it is six stories tall
this is where the beam comes in right
here it's three stories from the bottom
of the pit the pit is six stories tall
at this point the it was only less than
one-third complete and so we could go on
a tour and so i have a family photo with
hard hats in the cern pit and uh that's
pretty cool another time i visited um i
went and sang with one of our university
michigan physicists and that would be
this guy right here his name is stephen
goldfarb and he's a physicist that works
on the atlas project um but
he also is the bandleader of an all
physicist band called the cernettes of
the canettes blues band and
he let me sing a song
i i was coming to do some video work for
him i happened to be in the area and i
just stopped by on one of my trips and
me and another michigan staffer we
grabbed a couple of cameras we made some
music videos for him and put the
cernette some of the cernette's music
videos up on the web and then they let
me sing one song called i got got my
mojo working and so i've got i'll share
with you the video i've got my mojo
working this just oh so everybody in
this band is a physicist
and pretty much everybody dancing is a
physicist too now the reason i'm showing
you all this is to give you a sense of
the energy and joy
in addition to the hard work that goes
on at cern
you guys are all going to be on youtube
soon
this guy's got more channel than that
though he tells me he doesn't just do
the gym
i'm going to get him up here if you guys
help me you make him come up here
southern michigan
bluesman's mom
you can do the mojo
let's go
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
i
oh
[Music]
i
wanna do
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
i wanna love you so much
just
[Music]
good
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
he's got that knowledge
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
so i don't know if you noticed halfway
through i i knew that song by heart but
i had still written the lyrics on my
hand and so halfway through i you can
see me look at my hand to check the
lyrics that i knew made me look like a
dork i'm not i really want to sing i'm
just not a very good singer
and thankfully steve let me sing with
the band
so back to the topic at hand
in 1999
i visited cern uh as one of my first
tasks at the university of michigan to
help them with lecture recording and uh
i said hey i got a camera you know is
are the inventors of the world wide web
here and we still had a little bit of
the television show going back then so i
went and interviewed uh robert caillou
who was still at cern he was just sort
of across the street from the cafeteria
and we uh walked into his office and
gave him a microphone and just started
talking about the beginnings of the
world wide web and robert caillou is the
co-inventor of the world wide web along
with tim berners-lee who who built it at
cern so let's take a listen to robert
caillou
[Music]
hi charles severance here i'm at cern in
geneva switzerland one of the world's
preeminent high energy physics
facilities
we were lucky enough to talk to robert
caillou one of the co-founders of the
world wide web
the big collaborations at cern and
steven uh is a member of one of them uh
had people spread all over the world and
use cern as the infrastructure to do the
experiments and so um
obviously the the whole of high energy
physics has been the sort of miniature
information society
since way back when
as soon as there were networks
essentially and so
because we have this need for
spreading documentation around
we built these things like centralized
databases there was certain dock you
know you could use it but whatever
and we had a lot well we still have a
large database of
energy physics articles uh kept by
stanford
and you could get at it before the web
by knowing exactly what computer to log
into over the network blah blah blah
blah when when the web came all that
necessity of knowing which computer to
go to
what to say to that computer and so
forth just disappeared you know you
people put up these pages with the links
and you could just follow links and get
to places where you wanted to be and
find everything
and it was also all in the same format
so that was very important too that you
know we broke this
proprietary commercial system of
vertical markets which you know
don't let you get at anything except if
you stay with this particular company or
with that particular company so that
that horizontal split that cut that we
made between the browsers on top and the
databases at the bottom was i think
essential uh
to make it useful for us but also to
make it useful for everybody else right
and so
that was that was what it was like in
the beginning and tim
and i we did this all on this
next machine here
uh
in about 1990 so the first server was up
about 1990 the first
uh end of 1990 the first uh
server in the united states came up
about a year later uh
at stanford because of that database
that i was talking about before you and
tim feel like this was the big one or it
was just
well
in a sense of course
as i always say we called it world wide
web in 1990 and and tim had in fact a
name like that just before that
so
there was in fact no way of building it
smaller than the internet already was
and the internet was everywhere so there
was no way we could build it smaller but
the thing that we probably did not
expect or did not aim for definitely in
the beginning
at least
was to have this be
useful outside the community of
academics and internet people that
existed then see the internet came
outside the academic world
only
what
after
i would say also after 94 right
roughly what i think at the beginning of
the
yeah
94 is what i call the the the year of
the web it's when we had the first
conferences where when you know mosaic
got off the ground really and and when
commerce
started to notice it and companies began
to be formed and so forth exclusively
with that in mind and that was only then
before that it was mainly universities
and academics gopher was simpler
and easier to install and easy to
populate
and that explained its
easier success for a while because both
took off at about the same time
and because the web was somewhat more
difficult it took somewhat longer but
gopher became also integrated in the web
browsers almost instantaneously and so
you know after that
after after short while you saw what you
could do with together what you could do
with gopher you went for the web but it
was easy much easier to install gopher
this is a very which is why it had a
sort of
bump where it it
went ahead of the web for a while
the same is true of mosaic mosaic was
just
no good but easier to install
right and so it went ahead of what we
were trying to do we were completely
killed in the browser environment
because what we tried to do with our
browsers was more difficult
than what mosaic was trying to do and so
you know
this proves that a better thing
sometimes
gets killed or takes much much longer to
come up because
the easier thing so like a virus
outgrows the other one i think the the
real problem was that
this
development system is so much better
than anything else that porting what we
had here to any other platform took an
order of magnitude more time
and
the
for example every time you clicked here
you had another window right every time
you clicked on a diagram you had a
diagram in another window when you
clicked on the map you got the map in
postscript scalable perfectly printable
and so on and so forth and try to port
that to another system
you go berserk and this is the reason
why in mosaic you had only one window
and every time you clicked you replaced
the content of that one window which was
not what we wanted every time you see a
page you've got the images in line so
you scroll there are gone and so this is
all not what we wanted is horribly
complicated for the user and and it's
not efficient but you know it was the
easiest way to do it on the next system
and so
you know there you go so that thing
spreads and
and if you want to make you know there
is a big difference between making an
editor and something that just puts up a
page and you can't do anything with that
so um
our system from 1990 was
also the editor i mean i started it's
only after next stop making hardware and
i had to go back from a next to a
macintosh
that i had to learn html right i mean
before we produced all the documentation
and stuff but we never saw any we never
in html we never saw any urls
right because
you linked
by saying link this to that not by
typing in the url there was a special
window you could
call up in which you could type a url if
you needed to but it wasn't the usual
thing i mean this navigation now which
says http
you know i learned all that
the hard way afterwards that you have to
use that because you've lost that system
right the interesting thing though is
that i
see i find html a glorious language no
i'm not i'm not the average user
but i like to write it i mean i enjoy
almost word processing it's like tech
it's like yeah right right it's exactly
as bad as tech that's exactly what it is
it's exactly as bad as thing and can you
imagine i mean the headings
have levels which are absolute
true
you need a plus what um i mean come on
html was we just didn't have must
realize that we were never more than
four people here tim and myself and a
student each okay so things like uh
putting in serious effort into
thinking about html was a low priority
business and on then of course by the
time it
there was time to do that it had spread
beyond repair right
that sort of like units right right but
of course we had like a virus
uh yeah uh in a sense we we um
we have xml coming now fortunately so
that'll that'll help
this machine here uh it's um
well it's more than 10 years old now
it's
got
it runs
unix
but it has unix with a
nice visual interface it had some other
interesting things which was the which
permitted us to
do the development of the web in such a
small time such a short time and that
was it had a completely uh
or it has a completely object-oriented
development system in which there is
already supplied as part of the library
and editable text object and that was
what tim used to make the first browser
and this this was all nice because it
got us there very quickly and then we
realized that you know
somehow the real world uses these
horrible machines and you know porting
it from here to make it available on
these horrible machines
in the same elegant way is
an enormous amount of work about halfway
through 93 i think
we
we made a last effort in outputting
browsers that were also geared to
becoming editors but then there was just
no hope
so i really like
that video it's real precious to me i
shot it in 1999. i don't know if you
noticed but i got a ponytail in the back
and i got a village people mustache
um
when i first came to university of
michigan i thought i was pretty uh
pretty special and so i grew the
ponytail uh
i don't have ponytail anymore
i got all my hair's a little darker now
um
it was i really liked the moment where
he started yelling at me because i liked
html and html these days with html5 is
so much better than html was he was
exactly right that html wasn't elegant
but it was
amazingly powerful at the same time and
the fact that we could see it
meant that people believed in it and it
was it wasn't magic
um the other thing that you might have
noticed is that he had some very strong
opinions about the design of what a web
browser should be and they might not
have seemed logical when you first
listened to them one thing he said was
every image had to pop up in the same
screen and mosaic had one page that
replaced the whole thing and you saw the
images in line which is not what we
wanted to do that's what robert said
that might sound illogical today with
farmville and facebook and you know all
these things but you have to understand
that in 1990 the network was very
different even than it was in 1995 it
was a very slow network and if you put
images on every page they would slow
down terribly and so what that user
interface looked like is you had a
document that was the text bold italics
these kinds of things and when you
clicked on something you got a new page
and then it would take a while for this
page to display because the networks
were really and truly slow and the
computers were slow as well
so that might sound to you as an
irrational
design choice
but in the time of 1990 it was a
completely rational design choice
and one of the things that sort of
changed over time
was that became less and less a rational
design choice as the networks became
faster the computers became faster an
image became images became more of a
natural thing that the technology was
capable of handling
so continuing our story we started at
university of illinois urbana-champaign
we went to university of michigan we got
the nsf net up in 1990 and cern creates
the world wide web the web took a great
step forward at stanford university when
the very first web server in america
came up now the fact that it's the very
first web server is not actually all
that important the what was important
was what was on that web server
um
it was 300 000 physics papers at the
slack stanford linear accelerator stored
in the database on a mainframe and uh
you met and caillou robert caillou
mentioned this in his conversation about
this
now what happened was is paul coons who
you meet just in a moment he
you know he said i'll put my database
the database was well known and people
had many ways of using it but with the
web it made it much more easily used
and so i think in a way paul coons
inadvertently created the first search
engine the first reading of something
that's mostly content that people read
up to that point tim berners-lee and
robert were really trying to build
something that allowed collective
editing of information stored on servers
all around the world so let's take a
listen to paul coons
[Music]
so
well the database that was here at slack
was used by people around the world but
with great difficulty because they had
to have an account on the mainframe
most people weren't familiar with
mainframes and second of all the
database
language that you type in was
difficult
so before there was a web i invented
a way for people to
do what's now called instant messaging
and to do a query to the database
without logging in
and that improves access to the database
but you still had this terrible
language
of the database machine
to to
type in in order to do your query
a little later on people added an email
interface so you could send your query
by email and get your response back by
email
so when i was at cern in september 1991
and tim demernos lee dragged me into his
office to show me give me a demo of the
web
when he demonst at first i wasn't very
interested but when he demonstrated
doing a query to a help
system database on a mainframe
i immediately put two and two together
and says well if you can query a help
system on a mainframe you can query a
database on the mainframe
and i started getting interested
the thing is that we couldn't change the
query commands because that was built in
the database but the web page could give
you examples and remind you what the
query would be
so did you have to write it all from
scratch i mean did you write it from the
protocol or was there software that you
reused to make your first web server
well i used the cern
server
software which was written in c
unfortunately we had a c compiler on the
mainframe at that time that wasn't very
long we had a mainframe of c compiler
but we had one
so all i had to do was to write some
extra c code
to uh
get the the query that the user had made
and turn it into the database query when
it was december 12 1991 we installed our
our web server
and we
we informed tim berners-lee
that day to give it a try
the big boost came about a month later
in january in southern france where
there was a workshop on computing topics
for high energy and nuclear physics
and at that workshop
tim burnley had a preliminary talk
so he gave his hour-long talk to about
200 physicists from
around the world
and
as part of his talk he gave a demo
and at the very end
most people i think were bored most of
the time i mean the worst thing that
software people want to think about it
is uh documentation and he was pitching
documentation
but at the end of the talk
he connected to the slack web server
and made a query
and that really dropped a lot of draw
jaws
because
everybody knew the database everybody
knew how hard it was to access
okay and here he just clicked away typed
in a few things for the query term and
bang the results came back and nicely
formatted
so i way i say the interest in the web
went from about 20 people to 200 people
in that hour
okay
now those 200 people went back home and
if each one of them told 10 people
then within a week the interest in the
web brewed 2 000 people
so uh that that was the big turning
point and i think tim recognizes that
that was really to kick off
and i think the reason that the
web took off so quickly once the
comers
appreciate it and started to realize it
it's a win-win situation
okay
it's a win for the customer obviously
because he can do price comparisons he
can browse this airline schedules on his
own and visualize what he wants to see
quickly he can cut and try different
things as much patient as he has to get
the price down
so it's much much better for the
consumer
but what about the provider the airlines
well it's much better for them
because just software is running on
machines
okay it's much lower cost
for them
and
and so they're winning too
i point out in my talk about the web
near the end sort of a punchline
that in doing big science
we're
solving we're finding solutions to
problems that the general public don't
know they have
so who would predict that out of high
geophysics research he would come
something like the web would come up i
think that would be unpredictable but in
hindsight you can see that it was a
natural place
for uh for the web to have been invented
so again i think paul really created for
us the first search engine and showed
that the web could be a mostly consume
environment and be extremely useful when
you think about it
if there was no web and there was no
content how would you know that the web
is a great way to view content so paul
coons had the advantage that he had a
lot of content and it was content that
at least the physicists found extremely
valuable and then people go oh i can see
in fact i remember when i first saw the
web i was like okay fine it's got
pictures who cares
um because other things like gopher were
just as good
and then i saw the ability to go to
federal express and track a package and
go like now that's a cool idea right the
go gopher couldn't do that as a matter
of fact in 1993
sort of three years after the web was
created the web was actually not all
that popular
1991 was the paul coons but that was
mostly physicists and a few
nerds myself included but in 1993 gopher
was a much better product and it was a
much more beloved product
and the problem again went down to came
down to the fact that the network was so
slow that simple
text-based things worked better than
highly graphical things
and there's an apocryphal story that
happened in a march of 1993 where there
was a meeting of the internet
engineering task force that does
standards for all these things
and they had a bird of a feather session
for gopher and a bird of a feather
session for the world wide web and the
gopher session was full of people and
they couldn't have enough in the room
and they were sitting on the floor and
peeking in the door and then
later
i wasn't at this meeting by the way rich
wiggins my co-host on the television
show was at this meeting
and what he tells me is at the birds of
feather meeting there was almost nobody
there and turned berners-lee was like
i've been working on this thing for
three years and it's better than gopher
but nobody wants to use it and then
people in the room at that point told
him they said it's just too complex it's
too hard to get working
and so
this is a long time ago and the web was
not
assured to be a success at that point it
just wasn't really clear
the university was getting the idea that
we had spent a lot of money on
a campus-wide network and
that maybe we should use it for
something besides connecting to the
mainframe so most of the top of the
computer center was saying maybe we
should do something with publishing
information that'd be an interesting
sort of use of the network that more
people could use than just the people
who wanted to talk to the mainframe
were you surprised at how fast gopher
took off yeah absolutely shocked uh
because we basically wrote something
that we thought would be good enough for
our campus
and hoped that a few other places would
use it because then if somebody at a
different institution used it we'd have
some credibility locally that hey we're
not just saying it's good somebody else
is saying it's good so
that it was accepted is probably more a
sign
that it just happened to be the right
thing at the right time the environment
was ripe for something like that and we
had an okay product at the right time
yeah basically we put it up for
anonymous ftp and sent out a couple
announcements on using it saying hey
here's a thing that does kind of a
campus-wide information system the
fashion back then was to say everybody
needs to have a cwis a campus-wide
information system and so gopher we
thought made a pretty good one because
you didn't have to centralize publishing
on one machine you could let individual
departments publish off their own
machines and control their own content
that model turned out to be a pretty
good one so lots of other places started
using it so we had kind of the right
idea
at the point where this particular issue
campus-wide information system was
something that all of the
all the university computer centers were
saying i've got to have one of these the
technology we
built gopher to work with were
fairly slow machines with limited
graphics and slow modems that was our
design point because that's what people
had six seven years ago
and while we added graphics and movies
and those sorts of things gopher wasn't
designed to be hyper text and really
media rich documents
it was aimed more at run fast over
limited bandwidth on slow machines
so
1993 was kind of like
it was a real there's a lot of things
that could have been very different in
and
i want to show you
a
commercial and there's a couple of these
out there from 1993 that one of the
large telecommunications vendors
put out as a national ad campaign and
this is what the telecommunications
industry was thinking about
they saw it all happening they saw this
all happening they knew it was going to
be big they knew it was going to allow
interactions in many ways they knew it
they
they weren't dumb they it was like whoa
what's going on no not at all they
absolutely knew so this
this really
wonderful series of commercials
is um
[Music]
it's just quite amazing so take a look
at the end you'll see actually what the
large telecommunications company's name
is so take a quick look
have you ever renewed your driver's
license
had a cash machine
nice picture you will and the company
that'll bring it to you a t
have you ever watched the movie you
wanted to
the minute you wanted to
learn special things that's all taken
from jazz now any questions from far
away places
so where did jazz come from good
question
or tucked your baby in
[Music]
from a phone
you booth
and the company that will bring it to
you a t and t
so
again sort of
looking back at this and looking at
things that might not have been
um
there's nobody that really makes the
connection that steve jobs might have
had some impact on the world wide web
but
in a way he was actually quite
influential steve jobs of course founded
apple and then was kicked out of apple
um at after the macintosh um and he
started a new company called next
and if you listen closely to what robert
caillou says and you listen to closely
what paul kuhn says and the computer
that was on my desk during this entire
period of the 1990s to 93 were next
computers
next was a bold unix-based highly
networked high-definition display
high-performance computer that steve
jobs built when he formed the company
next after he got fired from apple of
course he eventually came back to apple
and the next technology is
macintosh that's the macintosh operating
system and so
if you make a mistake in macintosh you
might see a error message starts ns
something that's called next step which
is the operating system on these next
computers
for the first three years of the web
it was pretty much only on the next
computer people would even the server
was you know on the next computer and
the browser was on the next computer
and and so it's the next computer really
kind of did that i i wrote an article
in uh sort of a couple months after
steve jobs died for ieee computer
magazine's
january 2012 issue that really sort of
tried to at least from a historical
perspective
point out how important steve jobs may
have been
in
helping the internet get formed
[Music]
hello and welcome to conversations with
computing
in this column i take a look at some of
the second order effects of the
technology that steve jobs produced
throughout his career and how those
technologies from apple and next often
served as an inspiration to many of the
early innovators in the internet and
world wide web
i found out that we'd lost steve jobs on
the evening of october 5th right in the
middle of a lecture on using regular
expressions in python
i was recording the lecture for a later
podcast
because you might want to go down the
nerd rabbit hole later and that's okay
there's nothing wrong with avoiding the
nerd rabbit hole but this is a nerdy
thing
it's extremely nerdy
i think it's awesome
a nerdy announcement
[Music]
the very next week in the same classroom
i was giving my lecture on the inside
story of the history of the internet and
the world wide web
sharing some of my interviews with early
pioneers
as i gave the lecture and watched my
video interviews thinking about steve
jobs i began to realize how important
apple and next technology was to those
early innovators
in some ways the very existence of those
technologies helped propel the internet
and web revolution forward
in my 1999 interview with robert caillou
the co-inventor of the world wide web we
are sitting in his office by the next
cube that ran the very first web server
as robert describes how the next stepped
development environment allowed them to
quickly build prototype versions of a
web browser in
1990 you get the sense that their next
hardware and software was very much an
equal partner in their early visions of
the web
obviously the the whole of high energy
physics has been the sort of miniature
information society
since way back when
soon as they were networks essentially
and so
because we have this need for
spreading documentation around
we built these things like centralized
databases there was certain dock you
know you could use it but whatever uh we
had a a well you still have a large
database of um
energy physics articles uh kept by
stanford
and you could get at it before the web
by knowing exactly what computer to log
into over the network blah blah blah
blah but it was all very difficult and
then so
when tim invented to web and i had a
separate proposal i dropped it because
tim's proposal ran over the internet and
that was clearly much more efficient
um
when when the web came all that
necessity of knowing which computer to
go to what to say to that computer and
so forth just disappeared you know you
people put up these pages with the links
and you could just follow links and get
to places where you wanted to be and
find everything
and it was also all in the same format
so that was very important too that you
know we broke this
proprietary commercial system of
vertical markets which you know don't
let you get at anything except if you
stay with this particular company or
with that particular company so that
that horizontal split that cut that we
made between the browsers on top and the
databases at the bottom was i think
essential uh
to make it useful for us but also to
make it useful for everybody else right
and uh so
that was that was what it was like in
the beginning and tim
and i we did this all on this
next machine here
in about 1990 so the first server was up
about 1990 the first
end of 1990. the first
server in the united states came up
about a year later
at stanford because of that database
that i was talking about before the the
real problem was that
this
development system is so much better
than anything else that porting what we
had here to any other platform took an
order of magnitude more time
and
the
for example every time you clicked here
you had another window right every time
you clicked on a diagram you had a
diagram in another window when you
clicked on the map you got the map in
postscript scalable perfectly printable
and so on and so forth it tried to port
that to another system
you go berserk you know there is a big
difference between making an editor and
something that just puts up a page and
you can't do anything with that
so
our system from 1990 was
also i mean i started it's only after
next stop making hardware and i had to
go back from a next to a macintosh
that i had to learn html right i mean
before we produced all the documentation
and stuff but we never saw any we never
though in html we never saw any urls
right because
you linked
by saying link this to that not by
typing in the url there was a special
window you could
call up in which you could type a url if
you needed to but it wasn't the usual
thing i mean this navigation bar which
says http
you know i learned all that
the hard way afterwards that you had to
use that because you've lost that system
right
steve jobs next workstations were
essential to the creation of the
earliest web software
their advanced development environment
and rich display capabilities led early
innovators to think of the internet less
as a text only and more as an engaging
multimedia experience
in my 2007 interview with paul coons who
brought up the first web server in the
united states on an ibm mainframe at the
stanford linear accelerator in december
1991 we can see that he still has a
working color next workstation in his
office
when paul was developing software for
the ibm mainframe there are around 20
web servers in the entire world
if you wanted a web browser to test your
server having a next workstation
was essential
so when i was at cern in september 1991
and tim deverance lee dragged me into
his office to show me give me a demo of
the web
when he demons at first i wasn't very
interested but when he demonstrated
doing a query to a help
system database on a mainframe
i immediately put two and two together
and says well if you can query a help
system on a mainframe you can query a
database on a mainframe the database
itself had about 300 000 entries
and was it heavily used was it was it
heavily used before you put it on the
web and then continue oh yeah it was
heavily used people
had signed up for have computer accounts
on the mainframe so they could do their
queries
and
from all around the world i think there
was some 4000 register
so did you have to write it all from
scratch i mean did you write it from the
protocol or was there software that you
were used to make your first web server
well i used the cern
server
software which was written in c
unfortunately we had a c compiler on the
mainframe at that time that wasn't very
long we had a mainframe of c compiler
but we had one
so all i had to do was to write some
extra c code
to
get the query that the user had made and
turn it into the database query
now wasn't the original web server on a
next
and that's
the the uh
all the web software was originally
developed on the next computer at cern
while the web and web technologies were
gaining traction in the academic and
research communities who often had
access to powerful unix workstations on
their desks the rest of the world was
browsing the internet using the text
oriented gopher clients and servers
in 1993 the national center for
supercomputing applications at the
university of illinois at
urbana-champaign released ncsa mosaic
mosaic was the first graphically rich
web browser that ran on unix macintosh
and windows in my 1997 interview with
larry smarr he points out that the
success of the ncsa mosaic browser
occurred in part because of earlier work
developing the ncsa image library to
take advantage of the graphics
capabilities of early apple macintosh
computers what we basically did during
that ladies period was
to make the world safe for images
what ncsa image did was basically we
said we want to build a world of
infrastructure in which
it's as easy to move an image around as
it is to move a word
that was our design
parameters back and and that's the way
we talked about it back then so that
meant we had to scale the network scale
the disk drives scale the compute power
we had to go to full color
when the mac 2 first came out 256 color
levels uh we got 50 of them apple gave
us 50 mac twos which was like stunning
uh in those days we were in fact we're
the largest funded
group in the academic group in the
country for the apple advanced
technology group
ibm at that time was telling their
customers you don't need color we've
already provided it as i said you have
four of them black white cyan and
magenta
why would you need more
so what we did was we took
things that were on 100 000
computer graphics workstations of image
processing that medical imaging people
used satellite reconnaissance people
used and we took all that put it into
software and ncsa image on the mac
and so you could just move the mouse and
do what it would take you would have
otherwise cost you a hundred thousand
dollars to do and you'd have to be an
elite specialist again taking things
that elite people knew how to do could
afford to do and making it available to
the masses
the day after i found out that steve was
no longer with us i happened to have a
morning meeting in new york city so i
went to the apple store in manhattan to
get a sense of our collective reaction
to the loss of such a brilliant
visionary who's affected us in so many
ways
hello everybody this is chuck i'm here
at the apple store in manhattan i'll
show you kind of what we're seeing
we're seeing
press we're seeing a
impromptu memorial for steve jobs
uh that's got apples it's got flowers
it's got all kinds of really really cool
stuff
and
but the the crowd seems really quiet
there's a media that's interviewing all
the people you can see uh
see the media there grabbing people off
the street and interviewing them sure
i'm sure they're capturing their
thoughts and so here we are sort of
one day
one day after
uh the passing of steve jobs throughout
his career at apple and next and then
again at apple steve jobs was never
interested in the least expensive nor
the most profitable technology
he pursued the best and most advanced
technology
in many of his designs and decisions he
provided a road map for the entire
consumer technology marketplace
it's no wonder that many of us would
wait with breathless anticipation for
each and every apple announcement
they were always an exciting glimpse
into the future of technology
over the past 30 years the products that
came from jobs companies were a joy to
use
and perhaps more importantly they
inspired many innovators to keep their
focus on the exciting and unexplored
future
[Music]
so we started our
journey at university of illinois
urbana-champaign
we got the nsf created university of
michigan we created the web we created
the first web server and now we're going
to come back to where we started
we're going to go back to the university
of illinois at urbana-champaign
these are the folks that basically
exploded the web
moved the web from the academic space to
the commercial and end user space
and there's all kinds of things the
network was growing things were getting
faster
personal computers were getting better a
very rapid pace because
the ibm pc is almost 10 years old and
many computers they were getting quite
fast in the in the 90s so the 1990s our
computing and their display capabilities
were getting better very rapidly
and
in this environment ncsa at
urbana-champaign university illinois
urbana champaign built an open source
web browser that worked on mac
windows and
unix
it was the first web browser that did
this and it it was the thing that
really made it so average people who had
pcs or macs in their home could get a
network connection and start enjoying
all of this new content that was coming
up on the world wide web
hello my name is charles severance and i
am showing you right now a desktop
application that works on my macintosh
called ncsa x mosaic this was a software
released in 1993 and it was the first
mosaic it was the x windows mosaic
and i'm running it on my macintosh and
you can download it from my github
account uh csab is my github handle and
it's the x mosaic dash 1.2
so what we're looking at here is the
original default home page at the
national center for super computing
applications at the university of
illinois and we see it as we saw at
circa
1993 we can scroll through we can see
the old good old days the visited set
links in purple and so if we scroll down
you'll see some neat pictures and
the wonderful gray background
list tags were
were real back then
you know we can
go see something about visualization at
ncsa
i've done a little tiny bit to this to
teach it a few things you can see
all that i've done on http
um
on my github site you can see everything
i've done on my github site i try to
stay as i just made a few more things
work like png images and http 1.1 so you
could visit more
more pages another another wonderful
page
to uh
another wonderful page to take a look at
is the original
first page on the world wide web the
info.cern.ch
and again we're experiencing it now
circa 1993
to see what's out there
take a look at the people involved in
the project so here's
some of those pages tim berners-lee of
course robert caillou of course
and here's some of the other people that
were working at cern
so
there you go
that is a quick experience in how we
surfed the web in 1993.
after this the ncsa staff student
programmers software developers
all formed the company netscape in order
to commercialize all this
joseph harden was the supervisor of the
software development group at ncsa
that was responsible for building and
releasing both the mosaic web browser
and the httpd web server as open source
and gave them way free
[Music]
the ncsa mosaic web browser was
developed at the university of illinois
starting in 1992
ncsa mosaic brought the web to apple pc
and unix systems
joseph hardin managed the software
development group at the national center
for super computing applications
[Music]
ncsa was kind of a special place right
one of those things that happens very
infrequently where there's lots of
energy a large amount of resources
visionary leadership and a lot of free
space for people to play
and larry smar
has to figure in any discussion of it
quickly because he's the person that
created that space
and
that gave a bunch of us people in
visualization people in
computational science people in
collaboration technologies people in
all kinds of stuff networking in the
late middle and late 80s
a space to just figure out what it was
that we thought was fun and what was
interesting you know what i thought was
interesting
was how people were using these new
technologies to work together we've been
working we started out working
with
tools that
supported
simulation and computations on the main
supercomputing systems
that's what the software development
group did and there was a group before i
joined it that did
ncsa telnet
right this is back when
we were trying to convince the physicist
that decnet wasn't such a great idea
that we wanted this crazy
open nobody owns it right ip
um model for the network and
that was kind of a bit of a struggle
because if it was an open source type
thing and nobody owns it why how's
anybody going to have responsibility for
it and why not use decnet which is this
perfectly good proprietary
well-developed you know system
yada yada so it was a long time it took
a while for us to
explain to the physicists why we wanted
an open model for um
tcpip for the interconnection of all
these networks
and i spent time for a while with a
program at ncsa called the affiliates
program
where we gave people mac ses
and
told them about tcp
and put the ncsa telnet on the machine
and said now here's how you get to the
super computers
larry recognized from the beginning and
we all loved the idea
that these small little things on the
desktop were really the gateways for
everybody to the big machines in the
background and that all of this would
turn into one cloud behind the the
screen that we needed to figure out how
to get the user involved in as much as
possible
so we were interested in building tools
for end users that worked with pcs and
that allowed them to do their work
better
in the computational science communities
that they were part of on the super
computers
and it's an easy extension from that to
think about collaborative technologies
in the large how do people work together
not only with these tools
but also with
simple communications
email
papers
data sets that they want to share
and how do they do that initially our
interest was in
synchronous tools
um
when we were thinking of collaboration
tools so we were building something
called ncsa collage
which was
a set of tools that worked
and one of the big deals was that they
worked across the three platforms
the x windows for the unix people
the windows environment and the mac and
that was one of the things that was sort
of part of the
underlying culture there was we wanted
to make them available to as large a
community as possible so
started working on collaborative tools
and there was a set of people and each
other on each of those machines that was
working
to make it possible for people to share
in real time
images of their data the spreadsheets of
their data
and
papers that they had run across
interesting references to uh with their
colleagues who were remote from them
geographically
so that's the context in which dave
thompson
who was one of the developers one of the
ex-windows developers the lead x-windows
developer i think for the
collage tool
um pulled down
one of the early
um
web browsers and it was the one from
slack and i can't remember its name
and he went through the effort of
getting it working
and brought it in and showed it to mark
andreessen and i
and both of us looked at the screen dave
described what he had in front of us
and we said
we can do better than that
that's a complicated system and the
interface looks terrible
and it dave said that it was a real pain
for it
for him to get it working for him to
download it and install it and compile
it and everything
and it only works on the next windows
box and wouldn't it be cool if it worked
across all three of the boxes and if it
was something that was just a plug and
go like the rest of our tools so mark
and
another developer there
ran with the idea dave wanted to work on
it but i said dave please finish up with
the collage stuff and this was before we
really understood what was meant by open
source
so we just and we wanted everybody to be
able to take the software and do
whatever they wanted to with it we
weren't that concerned with commercial
advantage we were more interested in it
being open and
people being able to make contributions
back to the code and taking the code and
doing what they wanted to with it so we
just put it all in the public domain
which as the folks from apache will tell
you
was kind of ambiguous it's not clear
what that means um but at least it got
the code out there
so
mark and eric we're working on that
um working on what mark and eric were
working on what the first generation of
ncsa mosaic
and this was the next windows
app
and nobody was working yet on the
windows or the mac version and we saw
the first version of that come out when
was it early 93 late 92
and
it was probably early 93 and
the response of course was fantastic
it's wonderful
to be able to just click on something
and see it right away and indeed the
combination of
um
hyperlinks in a document as far as
navigation and retrieval of documents
as a user interface is just great and a
lot of people
got it immediately especially people
that were working with
the tools at ncsa and the companies i
remember an hp exec coming in one time
and
mark and eric had written a little
filter that took
unix
um documentation
and
made it into html and made all of the
references into links
and they went to they hit an hp site
and the exec said where's this coming
from
because he was able to see all of his hp
documentation there in the room at ncsa
and navigate through it real easily and
he said well you've got three or four
folks back there that have put up
httpd servers you may not know what
those are yet he said i've never heard
of this and we said but this is the kind
of thing that um is probably going to be
really useful in the future for people
who are trying to manage documentation
in a distributed fashion
yada yada right we went on with a story
like that and this guy was bouncing up
and down in his seat and this was the
kind of response that we got with it
and
for a while we tried to integrate the
earlier work with collage
with the work with mosaic and early
versions of mosaic have a collaborate
button at the top
and that was something that would allow
you to pull in something from a
synchronous session
on the idea was that you'd be working
with your colleagues synchronously and
then asynchronously go off and use the
browser
and pull something into
the um
the collage session or vice versa be
working on something in the collage
session and be able to access it through
the browser or just use the browser as a
component and uh in the session
well
um the browser of course took off
we had tom redman who was the lead for
the
mac version
though
uh
he was the person who really built it
was alex toten
who was a
excellent developer and a lot of times
ran ahead of the other people that were
working on stuff especially on the mac
and chris wilson and john
they were working on the windows version
so all of a sudden
in 93 late 93
early 94
there's this full suite
of mosaics that work across x windows
the mac and the windows system and
that's the point at which the guy who is
the president at the time of the
internet
association said ncsa has fired a shot
heard around the world because it's
available now across all these platforms
and anybody can use it
we were convinced
deep down inside that all of the new
technologies and the digitalization of
the world and everything was going to
make a huge difference we just weren't
sure exactly how
at the same time
when
people would come to us early on in the
mosaic experience and say we want to
commercialize this and do this with it
or do that with it there was a lot of
you know we're not sure i remember
sitting in rooms with
commercial folks that came in and
pitched to us
and i bring the whole team in um
the whole
software development group and say
listen to these guys and you know tell
me what you think about this
um
and we were nobody was sure what it was
gonna do and there were people who
started off building browsers and just
kind of never got off the ground it
wasn't until
the netscape
effort started up
that there was sufficient
energy and sufficient resources
i think to really
get on and ride and push um
and and
you know crank up
a
group of
x hundred developers
uh in a matter of months
and then they were you know
quickly overshadowed by the effort
that um microsoft put into it i remember
one of the netscape guys
saying um i came back from a meeting
with some folks up in seattle and they
said that microsoft now had
this is when netscape is writing at the
top of its form right top of the game
this guy says
microsoft just told me that there's
somebody from microsoft just said that
they've got like
2 000 developers working on this said at
that point i realized that we were you
know going to have some difficulties
um and we of course always felt
that
there should be more than one browser
um and so we wanted this because we were
interested in standards and openness
right at the time if one there's only
one browser then that company gets to
determine what the standards are there
were all kinds of hassles early on
about
putting in different features and the
browsers driving the standards rather
than the standards driving the browsers
and all this kind of stuff so we wanted
some diversity
there was a feeling very early on
that this was
going to be
a real gas this was going to be hot that
this was something that was the response
was just so immediate
if you go back and you ask people
who were
sitting in front of machines in 1993
94 or 95
right and you say do you remember the
first time that you used mosaic
right you remember the first time you
used a browser it wasn't mosaic and
vast majority of them that i that i've
run into say yeah
i can remember
and i remember one of the nsf program
officers
calling me up one day just out of the
blue and saying
i just wanted to tell you you know you
guys probably this is like after we've
been playing with this for months right
not not years just months
he said you know
sometimes we just sit around and click
on things because it's still such a
surprise to have a picture or a whole
other page of information pop up
right and we don't know where it's
coming from and we don't know who's
putting it up but we still haven't
gotten over the g wiz aspect of this yet
[Music]
so at the end joseph is really talking
about how microsoft had to react to
netscape and how all of a sudden the
market begin to sort of crash together
and tons of investment a lot of
intensity
triggered mostly by the release of the
windows and the mac version of mosaic
1994 was distinctly different than 1993.
the staff at ncsa went and founded
netscape in april 1994.
the first world wide web conference was
held in switzerland shortly thereafter
the other first world wide web
conference was held in chicago there's
some interesting stuff about that in
these books
the uh books robert caius and tim
berners-lee's book talks a little bit
about that
in october 1994 tim left cern and went
to form the world wide web consortium
and and by the end of the year windows
95 beta 2 with an internet browser
was there with tcpip built in and so
if you really think about i mean it's
not even a whole year it's almost six
months where the world changed forever
and so
at this point now money is coming into
it up to that point it was mostly ideas
and research but now money is coming out
and we start seeing a transition
so netscape
was on the forefront of doing this
and
netscape basically
took the open source product
they started
kind of competing just to build a
browser but they quickly decided that
they would go
turn the browser and their web server
more proprietary and try to create
distributed computing applications using
proprietary things that netscape would
build unique to themselves
and they would attack microsoft
the moment it became clear that netscape
was going to produce a way to to to
develop software on mac windows and
linux
portably then microsoft got worried
because then the operating system
wouldn't matter and window microsoft put
so much into the windows operating
system that if the operating system
didn't matter it would really
tremendously threaten microsoft's
business hence windows 95 with tcp in a
free web browser
so
netscape sort of scared
well as
microsoft tried to buy netscape netscape
refused to sell wanting more money and
then microsoft vowed to destroy it
and as microsoft was coming after
netscape
first netscape tried to compete
by building better and better software
like the javascript language which will
meet brandon ike in a moment
and then after that they tried to sort
of
switch from being the proprietary bad
guys and go become more the open source
good guys and that kind of blew up in
their face and they built this open
source mozilla which eventually became
the mozilla foundation which eventually
began firefox
so now what i want to do is i want to
you to meet two people both of whom now
are the senior leadership at the mozilla
foundation brendan ike who's the cto of
the mozilla foundation but he'll really
tell us about
the
1995 where he invented javascript in 10
days as part of netscape and then we'll
meet mitchell baker who was the founder
of one of the founders of mozilla and
she will talk about how netscape
kind of fortunes declined got purchased
by aol and fortunes declined even worse
and how they basically pulled the
netscape code base out to form the
mozilla code base which then became
firefox codebase and the firefox of
course had this great idea that mitchell
will tell you about of having a search
box
and they made
tons and tons of money as mitchell will
tell you about so
up next brendan ike of the mozilla
foundation and mitchell baker of the
misilla foundation
[Music]
do
i was hired at netscape in april 1995.
netscape had already launched it's 1-0
mosaic killer if you remember mosaic was
the big ncc mosaic was the big browser
until netscape took over so when i came
to netscape
they'd been going for about a year i
actually had an option to go in at the
beginning i passed that up but i went in
in time to do what i was tempted to do
which is a programming language for
html for web designers and programmers
to use embedded directly in the web page
not something
uh
that was like coming along at the time
called java which was a more of a
professional's language where you would
write
real code with type declarations and
you'd have to write
that code in a way that compiled i was
writing something
javascript that could be used by people
who didn't know what a compiler was they
were just going to load it it was like
basic and that was really the pitch that
we would make
two languages not one
analogous to microsoft's visual basic
for c plus plus so javascript for java
bill joy of sun actually liked that idea
and agreed with it and he was the guy
that signed the trademark license by
which what i had created became
javascript the name is total lie it's
not really related to java so much as to
a common ancestor c in syntax
and and to the extent that we made it
easy to use and
something you could copy paste program
or start small from scripts and grow to
programs javascript has succeeded
massively it was also an incredible rush
job so there were mistakes in it
and uh something that i think is
important about it is that it i knew
there would be mistakes and there would
be gaps so i made it very malleable as a
language and that has enabled web
developers to make it be what they want
it to be to project their own style of
not just api but almost language pattern
on it
and
create their own innovation networks to
use eric von hippel's phrase or
innovation toolkits on top of it so it's
not a language that tries to restrict
you to one paradigm it's a
multi-paradigm language i mean there's
all these things where a language comes
out and immediately trips and falls and
you have to sort of it's okay at the
same time
but there wasn't really a trip and fall
in javascript why
so you could say that it hasn't been a
version too and that's true because i've
tried to work on what might be a big
version too that was called the fourth
edition and that failed uh there has
been evolution the web is all about
evolution people don't quite see this
while you're in the midst of it because
it's microevolution but web pages from
the 90s don't all render properly these
days they don't all work right and a lot
of them are lost and only available
through webarchive.org
javascript
had enough at the beginning enough good
parts to use crockford's phrase or
enough genetic material from other
languages
you know first class functions
prototypal inheritance from self
the inheritance of first class functions
from scheme is really kind of a fraud
because scheme is different in many ways
and i couldn't make those
uh differences manifest i couldn't do
the scheme thing in javascript i was
under these marching orders to make it
look like java i had 10 days to
prototype it so scheme was more of a
spiritual than an actual influence but
first class functions are very powerful
and they
fit with an event handling sort of
programming model i was inspired by
atkinson's hypercard so that's why you
see on click in javascript and hypercar
had this pattern for event handlers
called on you know on page
down or whatever
so
javascript had enough good at the
beginning to survive now if you think
back though to the mid 90s javascript
was cursed because it was mainly used
for annoyances like little scrolling
messages in the status bar at the bottom
of your browser or flashing images or
things that popped up windows massively
we could have put in controls for those
we should eventually browsers firefox
kind of championed this led this
automatic suppression of annoyances that
made it all much better and with moore's
law compounding and with javascript
getting some evolutionary improvements
in the standards process it became
really quite fast enough and good enough
in 2004 and five to get the web 2.0
revolution that was i think
tied in with firefox's
retaking market share from ie and
developers realizing there was a client
side to the programming stack that could
be expressive and powerful and could be
fast enough thanks to faster computers
mainly you must have had some training
some kind of oh i've done a lot of set
experiences that kind of got to the
point where you could pull from scheme
and
i had implemented uh i was sort of a
language buff when i first started
computer science i was a math physics
major
originally and ended up math computer
science when i finally got my
undergraduate degree so i i was
programming uh
formal language theory uh applied to
recognizing languages like lexical
analysis parsers
automatically constructed parsers from
grammars i love that stuff because it
was all very pretty and clean
theoretically and it it still is it
hasn't changed a lot there's been only
one or two innovations since my time in
university in the early 80s so
what um
what that gave me was the ability to
quickly knock out uh you know a sort of
a
a language interpreter i could do the
the
parser and the scanner i could generate
bytecode because netscape wanted to do a
server-side embedding in javascript even
though it could have been a tree walker
something that interpreted parse trees i
made a byte code
for it and it was an internal bytecode
not the java by code that's become a
handicap for java i think
and i knocked all that out really
quickly because i'd done it before i've
done it at silicon graphics to build
sort of network monitoring tools to
capture packets based on expressions
over fields at the various protocol
headers i'd done it for fun just to make
my own languages and finally i got to do
it really quickly
the the speed was an issue for me it was
partly we were all feeling like
microsoft was going to come after
netscape because they had tried to buy
netscape in late 94 for too long the
money i heard about this before my time
at netscape but we also were in a weird
game theory with respect to java because
even at netscape some people thought
well if we have java do we really need a
second language they didn't see the
benefit of the visual basic companion
language for a much larger cohort of
programmers or amateurs designers
beginners
to write java as to write c for the
microsoft platform that they took a lot
of education and greater pay it was a
higher price proposition to get
people gluing components together and
designing pages and filling gaps using
javascript as they did with basic and
visual basic in microsoft's windows was
cheaper and wider spread it also
enabled this uh user innovation toolkit
approach uh to use vulnerable phrase
again because javascript was malleable
because
there were so many web designers you
would see different schools of thought
on how to use it emerge and this has
become quite clear over the last 10
years with the various javascript
libraries and i think that's actually an
advantage as i said earlier to
javascript that we're not telling you
here's the one way to write it here's
the one true object-oriented paradigm
here's the only way you should ever make
a reusable abstraction it's not unmixed
right it's hard for beginners people
reinvent certain wheels and make
mistakes doing it or don't like having
to acquire a library but you see jquery
of great power library because it gives
people this very sweet
query and do paradigm and again it's not
mandatory with javascript but a lot of
people learn that they think that is
javascript i think jquery is a language
or they think
you know jquery is the tale of like the
dog jquery is great and john rezzy used
to work with us in mozilla and but there
are so many good libraries out there now
and they're actually shrinking and
becoming more compositional which is a
good trend so javascript by being
malleable and
sort of fostering user innovation i
think has
uh played a unique role if i had done
something more rigid i think
the odds are greater would have failed
i i just can't imagine how you would
have escaped from
the object-oriented pattern of c-plus
plus partly i had to because if i'd
done classes in javascript back in those
10 days in may in 1995 i think i would
have been told this is too much like
java you're competing with java you know
somebody at sun would have yelled at
bill joy more than they did and it might
have killed the deal so
i was definitely not only under time
constraint but under marketing orders
make it look like java but don't make it
too big for its bridges it's just
this sort of silly little brother
language right the sidekick to java but
then you you put in primitives i snapped
himself in here you put some primitives
you know like closures and all those
other things that that it's like you can
build what you want yes and and that
kind of went under the radar for a lot
of people and it wasn't all even there
in a good working order in the first
release but over the next few years it
became
not only well um known uh i would say
more standardized and well known over
the next 10 years it became evangelized
like crop words are the exponent of the
closure pattern and good uses you can
make of closures so people find the
malleability and the expressiveness and
the power
compelling enough that some people
actually resist any version two they say
i i don't want you to
add cliches or common special forms for
patterns that i'm more happy writing
myself or
acquiring as a library myself
you you've created an abstraction that
implementers can do crazy things with
right and people can rethink what the
interpreter is really supposed to do
they can and they can just say okay here
comes v8
that's right differently right
optimizations that haven't been tried i
knew about these optimizations because i
had studied small talk himself
but nobody had gotten the time and the
money google was maybe first there were
other efforts going on in parallel and
apple and mozilla have kept up as best
they can but va deserves a lot of credit
for pushing this forward it wasn't
quite as as first on the scene as as
they like to claim because it was all
coming together in 2008 but it has been
very helpful it has shown people what
can be done what's interesting to me is
that you then go and put different more
intensive workloads on the language and
you see the there's a new va that should
come out of somewhere it may not come
out of google because they may have
tired of optimizing javascript in fact i
believe dart is a response to that by
the principals who did v8 they want to
do a language where they don't have to
worry about all this crazy compatibility
may not succeed and it also doesn't give
javascript the next level of performance
but i believe that level is there and
it's still improving in performance
much more dramatically than a language
like java where the the gains are
percent or a fraction of a percent on
the standard benchmarks but a lot of
html5 development now quote-unquote
html5 javascript css web apis beyond
what's in html5 is taking off you're
seeing like zynga doing html5 only games
it's really coming faster than some
thought and i talked to the venture
capitalist fred wilson of union square
in new york said yeah it's here he
thought it would take years it's we've
turned that corner and so you call it
html5 what it really means is it's the
web stack it's the same stack you use to
write web pages and hosted web apps you
can write
apps that run in your device apps that
are maybe hosted maybe offline maybe the
line is blurred so that you can
associate them with a url but you can
also take them on the plane without any
fear that you're going to lose anything
by disconnecting from the internet
[Music]
landscape is of course known
for its netscape navigator product first
commercial browser on the web so
first tool
the first generation really used to get
on the web
and that was successful for a while
and then
competition became quite stiff from
microsoft the different way to compete
would be by building a shared asset
instead of netscape versus microsoft
that netscape would gather contributions
of volunteers and other commercial
commercial partners you know and build a
product that would be shared and that
group of people knew that
to be open source you had to be real you
couldn't just say oh we're open source
love us
you really had to manage it differently
so at the time there were six or seven
or eight of us who were employed by
netscape as mozilla.org staff and
another 100 or 150 employed by netscape
as netscape engineers building the
netscape product
and contributing their work to the
mozilla open source project so we are
all in the same buildings we all went to
many of the same meetings but we had
slightly different goals because
although we call it the netscape product
netscape had been purchased by aol
already
and so the client itself was diminishing
in importance and the importance of the
netscape client was to push traffic
to the aol websites but we of course at
mozilla.org were an anomaly
because our charter was to build a
successful open source project and so
that worked for quite a while you know
there were tensions
you know these were the dark years for
mozilla
we
came to understand we needed to rebuild
our core technology
that took a long time
while we were doing that market share
continued to slide
and there was a set of tensions over
what does it mean to run a real open
source project
and as it turned out there were two
competing views
and one view was that
open source is phenomenal we're very
happy that the code is out there anyone
is very welcome to take that code and
use it we absolutely want to build a
large and engaged contributor community
but all decisions and all authority will
be held by the managed equipment group
and we'll make those decisions as we
think best which is of course
to benefit
the client we're trying to build which
was the nesgate browser
we at mozilla.org were convinced it
wouldn't be successful
that
building a product to benefit aol only
wouldn't generate the kind of interest
either from individual volunteers or
from commercial partners that we needed
to be successful
and that we found the difference in
perspective from the volunteers
made the quality of the project much
higher they were under immense pressure
to ship this product because the company
needed it
and not only was it difficult
technically and in an engineering sense
but we at mozilla.org were saying and
there's these other things
right you may think it's good enough but
we're telling you it's not because this
is the feedback that we're getting
and you need to change some of the
development processes and management
practices
and so they
thought well i'm not sure what they
thought but we experienced it as no we
really need to keep going on the way
that we're going to get this product
shipped
but unfortunately
you know the mozilla community was
correct because when that product
shipped it was a failure
that was netscape 6
universally acknowledged as a bad
product and pretty universally
acknowledged as the end of the netscape
product line you know that all those
people that had held on and hoped
through the netscape four days and
waited and waited and waited for the
update once they got it pretty much gave
up
so that's what we experienced
so that certainly didn't help us that
was unfortunate
it did reinforce our view that
you know our view of the world wasn't
crazy
and
so we continued on
and it was still long and slow to get
technology and products that we liked
and the tensions continued the
management tensions continued you know
the failure of netscape 6 didn't make
anything easier and certainly for the
the aol folks it really didn't make
things easier either
and we fought a lot about the ui
i think ui is a constant source of
tension but in our case it was worse
because some of these fights would be
it makes sense to aol to put something
in the product and the interface of the
product either a button to an aol site
or something that has an ad in it or
some feature that a partner is paid for
so it generates revenue we think
it might send people to our site you
know some of our users might really like
it so it all made sense from their point
of view but if you're not building the
aol client to benefit aol and you're
trying to build an open source product
that
is used for many people then of course
those those features are a big negative
and so those are very fierce fights
because because the
management of the client group had very
clear
opportunities in hand that they wanted
to
build into their product and we were
this small group saying no
diametrically
we're pretty opposed in that case and we
would say no you can't put it into the
core product you're welcome to have a
build system on your own and add it in
later and that's how we ended up doing
these things so so we did develop a
system for but of course it's awkward
and you're always rubbing against what
should go where and it turned out even
in the very early days that the open
source mozilla versions of the product
got a lot more testing than the netscape
versions and we also tried to build in
some
quality mechanisms that again seem
normal today
so you can't
you get hired as an employee
you don't automatically get the right to
check your
code into the tree right someone has to
you know look at your qualifications and
say
and mozilla and the way we work we
understand
your coding level we understand you know
how we work we understand if something
goes wrong with your code you know where
you need to be all of these things and
that's a very difficult setting for a
hiring manager to say well i've just
hired you
and you can't be as efficient as you
think you can because there's yet
another vetting process by this other
group so i understand you know why it
was difficult but on the other hand as
an open source project if you can't
control the quality of the code and you
don't have any say in it you're not very
real
aol
client fortunes declined and the
netscape browser declined and declined
precipitously after this netscape six
and so aol was interested in laying off
people
uh
and in one of the big layoffs i was
included
and that was seen that was in 2001
and that was seen as
a power struggle as well
because by that time
the fights back and forth about
what we were building and who was making
decisions we're pretty well known within
the engineering organization it's it's
hard for them not to be
i mean it's true anywhere right but but
in some cases the fights and the bugs
are all very public as well but
uh and and so
so i was laid off or fired depending on
your you know how you want to describe
it
and as it turned out it wasn't really
possible to take my place and i
continued as a volunteer
and the netscape engineering
organization was very clear whose
leadership they were most interested in
following
and so
we had to work out a way in which
the
management at
netscape aol that remained and i worked
out a you know sort of a way to work
together enough
so that they could ship the product they
wanted to ship but that i continued to
lead the project
and i think that was a surprise um
not not so much to me
i think
and so i worked as a volunteer on the
mozilla project you know for a number of
years including the years in which we
shipped our first product which we
called mozilla
and which we were very proud of
technically
and for its day many people were
surprised at how good it was
but it didn't have a good user
experience but eventually i ended up
working on another open source project
with mitch kapoor for a while
and that was
lucky
he had started this open project and
reached out to talk to brendan and i
about it to learn something
and the day that he was scheduled to
come down and talk with us was the day
that i was laid off
and so it was
an odd time
yeah that was chandler i was preaching
on there but oh sad
so i i worked on that for a while and
and mitch was always a supporter of
mozilla even before firefox when he
didn't like the product
but he recognized that we were an
important part of the ecosystem and that
went on until 2003
when aol decided to stop investing in
the client
almost completely
and fortunately they knew that just
killing it wasn't good
they knew enough about mozilla and the
name and the brand to think it would be
good to do something with it
and
so eventually
i ended up
working with them and and they
some of the people there knew mitch as
well and i was working with mitch and
they knew him and so we all you know
spent a chunk of time trying to figure
out what was possible
and my partner brendan was still at
netscape
very eager to make a move
and many of the key people we wanted
were also desperate to keep working on
mozilla
and so we ended up getting a two million
dollar
seed money from aol
and mitch was helpful with that and a
few other things trademark name mozilla
and the four giant servers which were so
important to us at the time and which
had taken us almost 18 months to get
through the purchase cycle at aol
and so uh i think we still have those
boxes sitting around because they were
so important to us at the time
and so in 2003
the mozilla foundation was formed
and mitch was the first chairman
because he had done so much and had so
much to offer
and
brian balendorf and
and uh
guy chris blizzard who worked on mozilla
forever and and brendan and i were on
the board
and aol
understood that there were three or four
people that would be leaving
when they they did uh some kind of reorg
when they closed down the client group
and that those people would be coming to
join us
and of all the people that we thought
would be most helpful at mozilla they
all came
that was about nine or ten so we were
and mitch continued to support me and uh
one other person in mozilla part-time so
we were maybe 10 or 11 people
and i
and brendan and i had always felt that
we needed employees it was exciting it's
a little scary
because we knew that two million dollars
wouldn't go that far and that we had a
lot of work to do to make ourselves real
we were still 18 months away from
shipping 15 months away from shipping
firefox
so that part was scary but it was
immensely exciting one of the friends of
mozilla showed up and they had a big
lease
and a little bit of space they could
sublease to us so we found a funky
little room way in the back not even a
sink
very odd but but we were really happy
with it
and we worked away on building our
product
at that time we made what was a pretty
fundamental change that that was
critical and we decided unambiguously to
be a consumer product
that seems obvious but when you're a
bunch of developers it's not that easy
and it means that you have to strip out
a lot of the
things that are clunky for a general
consumer you really have to be
determined
that you're building for a general
consumer not yourself and i think many
open source projects probably don't want
to do that and shouldn't try if you
don't want to because you have to keep
at it so we started doing that out of
the blue some visual designers appeared
from
prince edward island in canada and so we
started to get nice looking logos which
we'd never had before and visual
elements
and then we tried to figure out what to
do with the start page
because we knew that
mozilla development tools weren't the
right answer
and we just
took us forever
and we looked at all sorts of things and
finally decided
the one thing we knew that everybody did
was search
you know we'd have people who say well
it's obvious you should have the bbc at
least in english language versions it's
obvious and then you know our
engineering guy would look up and say
well it's not obvious to my 17 year old
daughter that that's what she wants it's
not obvious to my son either so
but everybody used search
so we thought we have the search box
maybe we should put that on the start
page too
make it easier maybe it be more obvious
to people
search
so
we went to talk with the search
providers
we had a very fruitful discussion with
google
i think they also saw the value of
having a mozilla browser in the world
they're very explicit about that and i
believe them
and so
they're also open to doing a a business
arrangement
and so often people ask how mozilla gets
paid and would like most businesses on
the web
search search and ads
you do a search you know you'll see ads
if you follow those ads
revenue is generated you know it goes
through the system and we get a little
piece of it as do other browser makers
so it's very similar to the business
model on the web
and
we did something that i believe had
never been done before
which was to make sure that google and
yahoo were
right there next to each other like you
don't see them next to each other you
have to click on the arrow but they're
there
and today people laugh at me when when i
say that because you only see one but
but i negotiated that and that was an
absolute utter i will walk away from the
deal
term to everyone
because i don't think i'd ever seen it
before
and i wasn't
you know if you get on a plane and you
want a diet coke but the plane only has
diet pepsi because that's their deal
you're angry and if you want to diet
pepsi and you want to coke and i
i used that example i said i'm not going
to have firefox users angry at us
because they wanted one or the other you
know you have to agree you're both going
to be in the product but it also is your
values right it is
yes your values front and center yes
because
the choice is there we can do it
and to not do it would be to take away a
choice that somebody really wants and it
matters to someone so
so
uh we we have that
choice in in the search box but we still
didn't really know what to expect so we
shipped firefox
and our sense that we were onto
something turned out to be far more too
even than we knew we'd seen a
rise in interest from 0.8 and 0.9 that
was pretty noticeable but once we hit
the release version it just exploded
and part of that was it was the perfect
product this time we had a product at
the right time in the market the
internet capabilities had grown enough
people could actually download a browser
easily
and more people had bandwidth and
ability to do so and a comfort level to
try it so that was good we had a
beautiful product
and
it was an important product
and the alternative was horrendous and
dangerous and awful and so all of that
combined to create this giant excitement
and so firefox market share climbed by
you know a percentage point immediately
and started moving in these huge numbers
so it was a completely viral storm with
nothing driving it other than you know
the product and the need itself
and so that took everyone by surprise
you know we were hoping to
be able to generate a few million
dollars to support ourselves for the
next year you know we had 10 or 11
employees you start to add that up so we
were hoping to make enough money to do
that
and it turned out you know we generated
that amount of money before the end of
the year
the six weeks or eight weeks or whatever
it was before the end of the year and so
things actually things got even more
stressful and more hectic at that point
because now you've kind of got the
proverbial tiger by the tail we're still
12 people right so that immediate need
to grow and the sense of pressure and
stress combined with elation and success
is probably you know
i don't know maybe it's like having a
child right but it's it's that it's that
combination doesn't immediately get
easily to be anonymous
purpose yes yes that's for sure we
certainly see that
and so by the end of
firefox shipped in 2004 just actually we
just passed the eight year anniversary
and you know by the end of 2004 it was
pretty clear that we are a different
organization we were we were
i would say still struggling with a
different set of problems
but we had changed the nature of the
problems really quite fundamentally and
you know we've done so in a way that
that our users loved
by
2005 we were in a really different world
where
we began to be able to actually
influence others and that's always been
the goal i mean market share is nice
and it's nice when people love your
product market share is a validation
that you produce the right thing so
that's awesome on its own but the more
important i'm maybe not more important
equally important goal is to be able to
influence
not only ourselves but others in the
industry so that we start to see more of
the things that we care about
[Music]
so that was a series of action-packed
videos uh brendan and mitchell have done
a great deal and if you look at the
current
html5
javascript
really some of the work that brendan and
mitchell have done have created this new
world that we live in right now with
these highly interactive applications
javascript ajax it can really all trace
its
moments back to
its creational moments back to these
folks who a created the clever
technology and b fought to keep it from
becoming too proprietary and so a lot of
people
gave up on say their own personal
benefit to to believe in a cause that
was the greater good of society through
open source
now the thing to also think about just
kind of in the back your mind is
if it wasn't for microsoft would
netscape have been successful in its
original strategy to make the web and
both servers and the clients make them
proprietary
they were going to sell web browsers
they were selling web browser from 70 to
100 you used to be able to go to a store
and buy a web browser your your computer
didn't come with a browser
as a matter of fact the first time that
microsoft put the browser in with their
operating system they got sued for it
but by microsoft trying to catch up they
had to give their browser away free
which made it impossible for netscape to
charge for the browser and so in some
ways not that microsoft was trying to
make the world safe
but they basically blunted the
blunted put hundreds of millions of
dollars into blunting netscape strategy
and making sure that well they didn't
make it but it the net result was the
creation of firefox in mozilla and a
much more and world wide web consortium
and a much more fair marketplace
so the world wide web consortium
it was created in uh
october of 1994
cern
made a conscious decision even though it
knew that the web had been created there
that the sort of future curation
of the web and what the web meant was
not something that a physics lab should
take on
and so tim berners-lee
went to mit
mit welcomed him with open arms they
funded him they helped him create the
world wide web consortium and have done
a wonderful job in leading the charge in
defining the standards that that me make
that that that define the standards that
define
what html is what css is etcetera
now in october 1994 there was no way to
know if this was going to be successful
again
it was somewhat of a reaction to
netscape who had this sort of like you
know
bunker mentality the netscape was going
to take it all over and own it and push
every all these open people away
tim and mitchell and joseph and all
these people did not want that to happen
they felt it should be free for
everybody and open and many browsers and
many servers and everything should
interoperate and standards were the key
to that and the worldwide web consortium
was going to be the vehicle through
which that happened
but they didn't have any power compared
to netscape and netscape had all the
money but
ibm and microsoft were not particularly
fans of netscape either and so they
early on changed joined the world wide
web consortium and gave it enough
credibility to eventually sort of take
over uh in terms of being very respected
and the standards produced by the world
web consortium are high quality and very
respected and
and they're they're guiding their
shining light to keeping the web safe
for the rest of us and let proprietary
companies do their proprietary thing but
the world wide web consortium is is a
real important part of today's web
and so we finally come to the point
where you can assume the web where the
web is just there there was a bunch of
browsers there was a bunch of servers
there were some open source stuff and
non-open source stuff
and um and and i want to briefly
introduce you to tim berners-lee this
footage was taken by richard wiggins not
me
um caught him at a conference and he's
only we only got about a minute of his
video
last month i was off in
boston for the fourth annual world wide
web conference and i had the opportunity
to talk to the inventor of the world
wide web tim berners-lee and i asked him
a little bit about where we going with
this web stuff and we have just a little
bit of footage from tim telling us where
that's going to be
you didn't see nothing yet but you wait
until people
assume the web when the web becomes
something you can assume
when the web or the infrastructure is
all
laid down or you have an information
space then it will be time for the next
revolution and who knows what that will
be it's hard to imagine a greater
revolution than what we've seen i mean i
go to the smallest places and
everybody's putting up a web page right
the web could only take place the
revolution the web revolution could only
take place because the internet which
had been a quieter smaller revolution
but that had been an internet itself
quietly
being deployed throughout the world had
happened because the internet was
something people would assume
the web revolution could take place when
the web is something you can assume then
maybe a cultural revolution a nicer
cultural revolution any cultural
revolution perhaps or maybe we'll find
ways of doing things better than we
hadn't imagined
pretty neat rich one of the things that
i i liked about it was he he just said
we're gonna his idea was the next step
is something completely different a
cultural revolution is compared to just
a little more technology i think you can
see that tim berners-lee is a real
bright guy with a real strong vision of
the future and a real deep commitment
to the the web and the internet being a
agent of change
in the world
and uh and i think that it's going to
continue to be that unless
um
proprietary companies can get an upper
hand and so it's a it's really incumbent
on all of us to protect
the freedom of the internet and there's
there's believe me there are
organizations that think they should run
the internet and the web they just are
they never have stopped
so we're at the point where the web is
all here it's quite amazing and before
we move on i want to i want to
characterize just a little bit about the
people you've met so far and talk about
some of the common common things that
that they
they have between them and in a way this
i got the book the wisdom of crowds here
one of my favorite books
each one of these people when you listen
to them talk they would quite often talk
about all the other people doing all the
other work and and and they rarely
consider themselves in any way heroes
they rarely consider themselves as the
great innovators they always see
themselves as part of a collective
curiosity and there were many things
that i haven't told you about that were
curious explorations that helped inform
it and
and this was really research and you
know until sort of the late 90s it was
just a question of how to do it
and at some point
after the late 90s it switched to
what to do with it and at that point
we have a whole different group of
people that start
really entering the world um and and one
that's one of the earlier ones and and
has benefited greatly from it is jeff
bezos and he's the founder of amazon.com
and
if you listen to jeff you will hear that
he talks very differently he comes at it
from a business perspective
he's not necessarily trying to make the
world a worse place he's trying to make
the world a better place the fact that
you can get you know all these books
like the next morning that's kind of
cool um so what amazon does is really
wonderful it's it's more efficient for
society it's economically beneficial
but he has a profit in mind he is saying
this web exists browsers exist protocols
exist how can i take best advantage of
it
uh richard wiggins caught up with jeff
in 1997
so just look at how smart this guy was
in 1997.
everyone else figured this out much
later but jeff bezos is a really really
bright person so here's jeff bezos
hi there who are you i'm jeff bezos and
what is your claim to fame
i'm the founder of amazon.com
where did you get an idea for amazon.com
well three years ago i was in new york
city working for a quantitative hedge
fund when it came across the startling
statistic that web usage was growing at
2300 a year so i decided i would try and
find a business plan that made sense in
the context of that growth and i picked
books as the first best product to sell
online for making a list of like 20
different products that you might be
able to sell and books were great as the
first best because books are incredibly
unusual in one respect and that is that
there are more items in the book
category and there are items in any
other category by far music is number
two they're about 200 000 active music
cds at any given time but in the book
space they're more than three million
different books worldwide active and
imprint at any given time across all
languages what more than one and a half
million in english alone
so when you have that many items you can
literally build a store online that
couldn't exist any other way and that's
important right now because the web is
still an infant technology basically
right now if you can do things using a
more traditional method you probably
should do them using the more
traditional method
what kind of inventory do you keep
we inventory uh the best selling books
at any given time we're inventorying in
our own warehouse only a couple of
thousand titles and then we have we do
almost in time inventory for another
four hundred thousand titles or so we
get those from a network of electronic
we
order electronically from a network of
wholesalers and distributors we order
those today they're on our loading dock
the next morning
then for another
1.1 million titles we get those directly
from 20 000 different publishers and
those can take a couple of weeks to get
and then
the uh there are a million out of print
books in our catalog we have a calendar
two and a half million books all
together those million out of print
books some of them we can get and some
of them we can't
but we find them uh if we can and then
we ship them to our customers we do kind
of a search on those
what's almost in time inventory almost
in time inventory is the phrase we use
to describe a whole selection of books
that we offer it's basically the things
that are you know below the 2000
best-selling book up to the 400 000
bestseller book those are titles that we
can get from a network of more than a
dozen different wholesalers so if a
customer orders a book from us today we
order that book from our wholesalers
today and that book shows up on our
loading dock the next morning
and then we can ship it to the customer
they say one of the toughest things to
do on the internet is to capture mind
share what was your secret how did you
do that yeah
even more generally i agree with you
that you know capturing mind share on
the internet is extremely difficult even
more generally it's the late 20th
century not just the internet you know
capturing attention attention is the
scarce commodity of the late 20th
century and
one of the ways that you can do that and
it's the way that we did it was by doing
something new and innovative for the
first time that actually has
real value for the customer that's a
hard thing to do but if you do do that
then newspapers will write about you
what you're doing customers will tell
other customers and you'll get a huge
word of mouth fan out and and that can
really drive and accelerate businesses
and that's what happened with us in the
first year of opening amazon.com to the
public we didn't do any paid advertising
and all of our growth was fueled by word
of mouth and media exposure
i saw a little ants at the bottom of the
column of the new york times that was
our very first advertising um we don't
do that anymore but at the very very
beginning we did little tiny ads at the
bottom of the front page of the new york
times
i thought that was very clever it's sort
of using a url as a macro because i read
and it expands we're a bookstore click
here right that's a great way to think
of it and it worked very well
apparently i don't know you know the
problem with that kind of advertising is
it's extremely difficult to track
um
put a different url for every uh
that's the problem is you want people to
start to learn your url so you don't
want to actually use a different one and
it's very
easy one of the great things about
online ads we do advertising today in
maybe 40 different uh on
different websites we do banner ads and
that advertising is very easy to track
in terms of knowing how effective it is
so we know for each piece of creative in
each venue not only how many
click-throughs we get but how many
sell-throughs we get how many dollars of
revenue it generates per ad dollar spent
on that creative in that venue and that
is a sort of a marketer's uh you know
nirvana in a certain sense
well it's an exciting place to be on the
web right now oh it absolutely is i mean
it's just incredible this is what's
really incredible about this is that
this is day one this is the very
beginning this is the kitty hawk stage
of electronic commerce we're moving
forward in so many different areas and
lots of different companies are as well
in the late 20th century it's just a
great time to be
alive you know we're going to find out
that
i think a millennia from now people are
going to look back and say wow the late
20th century was really a great time to
be alive on this planet
so
if you're a stockholder of amazon i
think you're in good shape because he's
a bright fella and he's always looking
for how to really do the right thing and
you know give us products that we really
like now
in this we sort of evolve the modern
internet and and much like jeff jeff
said that investment was growing at 3
000 a year or something like that
there was this mania in 96 97 98 where
people just bought and bought and bought
and the notion that communications was
going to be so valuable led to
in the sense an overbuilding of the
fiber optic plan we have
a massive amount of fiber optic in the
ground right now and our ability to send
more data through the existing fibers by
just upgrading the equipment at the two
ends that's growing very rapidly as well
and so we're in this really weird world
now
where a fiber optic between ann arbor
and chicago 180 miles
is not that much more expensive
than a piece of copper wire
that goes 30 miles
in 1960
and so
distance is less and less important in
the internet it's why long distance
phone calls don't cost any money anymore
because long distance and local are not
that different because there's so much
fiber in the ground but just one thing i
want you to think about and wonder about
is
will we run out
the we're living off of the overbuilding
that happened in the late 90s and they
put so much in and they've been able to
upgrade it so effectively
but we might run out and where will the
money come from to dig the next set of
trenches to put the next round of fiber
in uh we'll have to see
so
if we take a quick look at this is a
graph of the growth of the of the
servers on the world wide web
and if you take a look we start in 1990
with one web server december 1990 uh
with tim berners-lee having one web
server
and then it sort of doesn't grow and
then you sort of see kind of like this
take off in the last two years last late
two years the 1990s where you go up to
about uh you know 20 to 30 million uh
you know from what i don't know
1996 is 200 less than a quarter of a
million dollars and unless the quarter
of a million hosts
you see the uh kind of the crash
the boom
and the crash where it wasn't growing
and then you sort of see another new
graph which is really this is when
everybody had to be on the internet
every little store started being on the
internet every web one had to be a web
server this was kind of the big ones
coming on and this was sort of like the
flame out of the exuberant growth of the
late 90s and this exuberant growth gets
so exuberant that it really changes the
stock market in the united states and
the rest of the world to the point where
you know from the early 90s to 2000 was
the longest period of expansion
and
there's a lot of factors for this but
one of the factors is
as we began to use communication and
computation to make
commerce more efficient
that triggered a great deal of growth it
also triggered over speculation right
and so the kind of um
the uh this part here the the crash the
dot-com crash was a bit of the over
speculation working its way out probably
if you know if they hadn't
overspeculated it would go like this
instead but it can't be like that you go
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy oops
and then we sort of had a crappy economy
for a while after that but again the web
the internet and all the technology that
i just talked about
really put a stamp on the entire world's
economy in the 1990s
so i could go on and on and on and on
about this stuff open source is a big
part of this um i will put links up for
uh these videos that i've got these are
three open source luminaries that i've
interviewed uh richard stallman is the
free software foundation
the gnu which is much of unix utilities
are written this way the compilers are
written this way
he is a a tremendous advocate for open
source software
also we meet brian bellandor from the
apache foundation and the apache
foundation was formed
based on the web server that was created
at ncsa became the first web server that
was the apache web server so that
lineage goes all the way back to joseph
harden and the team at ncsa and then
rasmus lierdorf is the inventor of php
in one of the many very popular web
programming languages for building
websites and so i'll put the links up
for these and you can take a look at
them
[Music]
we got our start in the early days of
the web as a group of disaffected
webmasters who were using a piece of
freely available web software but i i
had difficulty with it we were fixing
bugs we were sharing these bug fixes
with each other like a baseball trading
cards if you will these these patches as
it's called and uh one day we discovered
the group that put out the web server
that we were using uh basically folded
when all their developers left to go
join a brand new company called netscape
so a bunch of us decided that hey we're
dependent upon this software we don't
want to become full-time web server
developers but we want to be able to to
to use this thing that we've had for
free and be able to prove it and all
that kind of stuff
we looked at the license of the code and
the license said here's the software do
whatever you want with it uh don't blame
us when it breaks right uh and uh we
said hey that's a pretty good bargain
why don't we pass the same bargain on to
the next group of people right uh so we
formed a a mailing list right uh and
this was mostly again webmasters and
people working at some early internet
service providers or or website design
companies or places like amazon or the
internet movie database
and we combined our patches together and
decided to call it a apache server for
that reason
and uh it went forward and really the
model of how we worked was based upon
kind of us as a group as peers proposing
ideas you know vetting each other's
ideas and patches and fixing bugs you
know as a group as a team
none of us had met in person well some
of us had met but as a as a group we
didn't meet in person until 1998 really
three years after we got our start and
long after by the way we'd become the
most predominant web server product
on the planet um and yet at this time
still no money no dime not direct to us
from this piece of open source software
but plenty of us you know
made our living off of building things
on top of this piece and that's really
the story i think of of kind of
successful open source projects writ
large which is
people working together on on common
technologies to solve common problems so
they can go off and make money on other
places or so they can have fun they can
try new ideas they can you know uh be
experimental right um and that's that's
really the same story of apache and of
linux and all these other open source
projects it turns out to be not that
hard to to be able to work together when
people have the same common goal which
is
let's build a product that that does all
this great stuff um
one thing that we did do that made it
easy to make some of these decisions was
to have a very uh modular api which made
it easy for us to be able to say hey if
you want that special cool feature do it
as a separate thing and and make it
successful and we'll decide whether to
bring this into the product once it's
become successful or not right another
key thing that plays into this that is
true of all open source projects is that
an open source license like we had on
ours uh that linux has etc carries with
it something called the right to fork
which means that if i were to go all you
know colonel kurtz on on the project and
started saying we're going to go here
you know and no one else wanted to
follow well all of those other people
could decide to pick up the code and go
start a different project somewhere else
you know if they couldn't kick me out
which is probably what they would have
tried to do first right
this right to fork you know means that
you don't have to have any tolerance for
dictators you don't have to deal with
people who make bad technical decisions
uh uh you know you can take that future
into your hands and and if you find a
group of other people who agree with you
you can go on and create a new project
around it
so i think that
rule that right to fork limits the kind
of excesses that we see whenever we
start to talk about how do groups make
decisions and and conflict arises how do
you deal with that conflict and it means
that you
your style of leadership isn't so much
one of control and plotting you know
moves ahead of time but instead one of
um
being able to to get people on your side
convince them that that you're the
you're going to value their efforts
value their the the contributions that
they make
[Music]
and up next we're going to start digging
into how this all works rather than what
it is uh how it came to be so we're
going to talk about what it is rather
than how it came to be and
and so
thank you for your time so far and i
look forward to seeing you at the next
lecture
[Music]
oh oh hi sorry i was uh
i was in the forums
i guess it's uh time for this week's
video
so uh
this week we're moving from history to
technology and and in a sense we're
gonna tell the same story again
uh you know we'll sort of start at the
beginning but we're going to start from
the bottom and work upwards so since
we're kind of talking about the same
things
um but just from a more technical
perspective don't worry you'll be fine
um we're not going to over there's no
math i promise there's no programming
don't worry about that so of course i
appreciate ieee computer magazine who i
write for to let me use the articles
that are associated with some of the
videos
as well as the folks from
open michigan who have helped me so i'm
gonna say
no hang on got a phone call i'll be
right back
okay well that's been sent sorry for
that interruption um again i thank
everybody for the use of the copyright
materials um part of my hidden agenda in
this class is that you will be able to
look at this xkcd comic and you'll
understand the humor so i'm going to
stop for a moment and let you look at it
and see if you get the humor
okay so maybe you did maybe didn't but
hopefully by the time we're done you'll
have a better chance of getting the
humor
so if you recall
the most academics throughout the 60s
70s and 80s the best they had access to
was this store and forward networking
where you would send a message and it
would go into a computer and it might
sit for some time then it would find its
way across on a network it would sit for
a little while longer find it and and
hop and there's these multiple hops we
call these hops and each of these would
be a couple hundred miles per house and
to go from say uh michigan to stanford
there might be 15 or 20 hops cops are as
much defined by geography where we're
all trying to
optimize the cost of these long distance
connections
so the thing that really characterized
store and forward networking was that
there wasn't a lot of sharing one
message was being sent across one of
these links at a time and all the other
messages just kind of waited in time in
line
now that the the innovation that
happened
in the research networks
in the 60s through the 80s
ultimately embodied in the arpanet was
the fact that they were going to be
packet networks
first how do we share one link
so that a long message doesn't clog it
up and how do we deal with outages more
dynamically
with the idea that
eventually you could send a packet
across the country and back into a
computer and back out maybe a half of a
second and that was seen as something to
do rather than
somewhere between 10 minutes and a day
or two
so how to do this efficiently it was a
research project and it was a research
project that lasted almost 20 years well
20 years and
20 or more years and and it the one of
the neatest things about this is they
were able to throw it away and rewrite
it a bunch of times so that they could
put something in production see its
flaws see what was good about it then
they had the money from darpa to throw
it away and rewrite it now by the late
1970s it had you know 100-ish computers
on it here's a picture and these are not
the schools these are the computers
these are you know listing all of the
computers that are there
and so
the engine the the innovation that they
spent 20 years perfecting was the notion
of packet swishing so how can we simply
move data simultaneously across the
connection
and the essential brilliant idea is
break the message into packets
and again to sort of review here i have
a message and i have postcards that only
can handle 10 characters and i'm going
to send
this hello there have a nice day message
to daphne in california
and so i have three 10 character
postcards i basically put a from address
and a two address on each postcard
and a sequence number on each postcard
one two and three and i put ten
characters on each and then i stick them
in my mailbox i just put them in
put the sign up and then i wait
now
let's just say
um you know that the the post office
person comes and picks this uh this
first one up and uh it goes to chicago
from a minnesota mini from michigan and
then it goes to omaha goes to denver and
then the second one kind of falls on the
floor and it ends up going to charlotte
north carolina and then they're like why
is this here and then they sent it to
atlanta to get checked and then they
make sure and and this one goes and
number three ends up going to st louis
and then tulsa and then colorado
and this one gets routed back to
charlotte because they weren't sure why
they sent it to them in the first place
and then they sent it to memphis
tennessee and then this one makes it to
california and then this this other one
sort of goes to phoenix and this one
finally gets to dallas texas and this
other one goes finally and then this
third one goes to tucson arizona and
then las vegas nevada and finally makes
it right so these poor little postcards
that i put in they have each a different
journey right it's a little adventure
for each of the postcards that they go
through and so
we don't i don't see how this works on
my end i put in three postcards i
numbered them one two three but on the
far end in california daphne opens her
mailbox and has scribbling all over her
mailbox oh the shame no actually get rid
of the scribbling so daphne opens up her
mailbox and she doesn't know how these
packets got there ivy postcards how they
got their outcomes the first one she
goes oh looks like i got a message from
chuck but i've only got part of it then
out comes the second one shortly
thereafter and then after a long period
of time
finally the third one comes out but it's
actually the second one and now she
understands that she's got the entire
message and she reassembles it and away
we go and so this is the basic notion of
how
all those postcards can share the
infrastructure all they can all be
invited at the same time they can take
different paths you don't have to
connect them all together like trains
basically
and and this led to a shared network
infrastructure and so the computers that
were in a store and forward network went
from sort of big powerful computers with
disk drives to really tiny computers
with a single purpose of forwarding
packets
rather than long storm storage of
message and so so the the store and
forward had
long-term storage of messages in the
routers so the
but i mean not in the wrappers in the
store and forward the old one long-term
storage was somewhere in the network but
this was only short-term right
short-term storage short-term storage
and so when a packet comes out it simply
has to find its way through a series of
cops it still hops and it's still
connections but basically it has to find
its way across the internet and then we
would take whole campuses
like university of michigan say or
stanford for example
and then we'd have sort of various kinds
of local networks on those campuses and
computers on the campuses and servers
and various things and they would route
all their packets all their data out to
the internet and then the packets would
find their way across the internet and
then we might have a home connection as
well that might connect and so the
shared shared
network infrastructure focuses
only on packets not reliability or
anything else
so this notion of hops didn't go away as
a matter of fact i don't know how many
hops it took to get from ann arbor to
palo alto in
using bit net
i'm going to guess it might have been
16 or 20 and these days it takes 16 or
20 hops the difference is is in the
internet the 16 or 20 hops happens in a
hundredth of a second or a tenth of a
second
so the notion of hops and the notion of
intermediate computers is still present
in the internet
and the tcp networks that we use today
and so your your message sort of
leaves you the host that you're in
hops to the first router and then hops
to however many routers dot dot this is
more of a dot dot dot thing and then
finally hops its way out to the far host
and so this is sort of either your
computer maybe stanford's web server and
then there's this series of routers in
the middle that it hops through
okay
and so
the problem of
what data goes between here and here
is you've got to solve a lot of problems
right how to
all kinds of problems and so in order to
simplify the solution or break the
solution into
simpler more manageable parts
they came up with a layered network
model now
this is a cartoon
and
computer people love drawing cartoons
and saying this is our architecture this
is our framework this is our approach
sometimes they're helpful sometimes
they're not helpful sometimes the
cartoon is just kind of a cartoon
but what's usually being communicated in
these kinds of pictures is they're
taking a big problem and breaking it
down into some
subset some set of smaller problems so
the whole problem that they've got to
solve of getting data reliability
reliably across the whole country is
that big
and if we can break it into four pieces
and work separately
and come up with ways to let these
pieces interact
work separately with each one then maybe
we'll have a better solution
okay so
take a problem that's so large and so
complex that we might not be able to
solve it and break it into four smaller
problems
gives us a better chance of solving the
four problems now there's a certain art
to picking how you break the problem up
and there's more than one network model
the one that we use in the internet is
the tcp or internet protocol suite model
and we'll meet some of the people who
designed that uh there was also a model
called the seven layer osi model open
system interconnection model so there's
a model out there that has
one two three four five six
seven layers and they all have names and
they all have purposes now definitions
uh this was not quite as power this was
not very popular and i doubt that it's
many places
because the tcpi model is the one that
kind of won
and so that's the one that we're going
to study but that doesn't mean that that
has to be the only one but it is the one
that has become popular on the internet
so once you break the problem down from
a big problem into four small problems
you have to develop documents about how
these layers work together how various
computers work together how routers work
all these things
and so early in the process of the
development of the arpanet they created
an open process to build these
specifications
where they would invite invite engineers
from all kinds of companies and
universities and who knows what any
expertise to show up at a meeting
several times a year i mentioned the
ietf meeting when i was talking about
the history of the
internet and the tim burner's leave off
that only 15 people showed up to
that's this meeting it's the internet
engineering task force which is just a
bunch of engineers that get in a room
get in many rooms and solve a bunch of
problems and so the standards that come
out of this and you can go read them
they're all open documents
they're very throwback documents they've
got this text thing and it's got all
this like
beautiful uppercase that reminds me of
when back when printers didn't have
lowercase
and these are documents that describe
how most of the components of the
internet work together
so
the layered architecture that i just
described
where you have a computer and then it
sends data out the back of it and then
hop hop hop hop pop through routers then
the data rises destination computer
and then the destination sends it back
it's hop hop hop hop hop coming back and
it comes to you we're going to expand on
this a little bit so each of these hosts
on the two ends is going to expand to
this much right here
so that's one host that's another host
and each of these routers is going to
expand into this
so this bottom picture is just an
expanded version of this upper picture
so that we can see how the internet
layers work together
so when you send a message
in on your computer
it's this is all software application
transport internet
link so this is all software and then it
comes out the little plug on the back
your computer right
so maybe your computer has a little plug
like this on the back of it right that's
an ethernet plug and here's an ethernet
wire
and unplug my local area network in
right and so
this right here
is that right there that's kind of the
plug it might be wi-fi which means it's
kind of like air but if you have a wire
like this then it's a little more
tangible
and there's something on the other end
of that wire
this is a very short wire but there
would be a router on the other end of
that wire
the router takes the data off the wire
and then forwards it just like a post
office intermediate post office would do
on to the next link
on to the next link and this would be
multiple hops in here they're only
showing two hops and then finally it's
on the last link going to that computer
at stanford and then it goes up through
these four layers of software and then
goes and does whatever it's going to do
now when they send you the response back
it kind of goes the other way
and back up and back to you so if this
was you in a web browser
you know and then here's me
and here's a slide i've got right this
web browser and you move in your cursor
in the web browser sending stuff back
and forth to the coursera servers kind
of here and that's what's happening
right so
if as we look at this picture over here
this left column is the host you're
coming from the right column is the host
you're going to and the routers are
these things in the middle okay
okay
so let's start looking at all four
layers we're going to start
at the bottom at the link layer and then
we're going to move up
so if you recall when i talked about the
the the basic reason
why we even have a layered architecture
at all
is to simplify the problem
to simplify the problem
so the idea of the link layer is the
link layer is a
it all only worries about getting the
data across one hop right only worries
about getting the data from across one
piece of wire what like voltage goes on
these little wires and
how we send the stuff and if more than
one computer is using the same wire how
do we share
it's a complex enough problem
but we don't worry about the whole world
we worry about this one link layer and
so the link layer is sort of like the
connection
out of one computer and into another
computer and and this might be fiber
optic might be you know 40 miles or it
might be 40 feet for all we know but
it's one link okay and then a router
pulls it off that link and then forwards
it onto another link if you go to the
post office
you could think of
the
the person who picks your mail up from
your house with the thing on their
shoulder that's one link then they put
it in a truck
which takes it to a place that puts it
in a semi truck and then it puts it to
another place it puts it on a train
and the semi truck and the train and the
postman or post woman are these little
link layers each
person or semi truck is not taking it
all the way they're just getting a
little farther so that's the link layer
so the link layer doesn't worry about
the rest of this stuff it really
the stuff that is defined on this wire
really doesn't even care if there's a
world wide web or anything
its job is to get data across one foot
that's what its job is is it up is it
down how do we share it doesn't care
it's got a very narrow view so
what it means is we can zoom in on this
problem right we can zoom in
and focus and ignore everything else
so the link layer
basically asks questions like
you know i've got some data inside the
computer and i want to send it out
how do i encapsulate it what if this is
shared how do i deal with that and
common link technologies that we see are
like ethernet or wi-fi or cable modem
dsl satellite or optical right these are
all
links layers of one form or another so
if you're going back to this ethernet
link layer which is one of our favorites
because it's kind of ubiquitous
other than wireless it's probably
ethernet is the most ubiquitous link
layer
so
when the manufacturer builds an ethernet
or a wireless adapter
they actually build into it which is
probably right here i don't know it
could be right here
um they build into it a serial number so
they they mark this as having a serial
number
and you can actually whether on windows
or mac you can work your way down to
find the serial number for your actual
manufacturer piece of equipment so
there's one on the mac that's an example
one on the mac and that's an example one
on the pc
they tend to be
six
two digit
numbers concatenated together often with
colons in this case in windows it shows
dashes
and so this is a raspberry pi and all
the raspberry pi's are going to actually
have similar prefixes
and then
serial numbers within that prefix
and so the raspberry pi's get
manufactured they come out of the
manufacturing line with this sequence
number just kind of going
up up up up up and um then they get
shipped to all corners of the world
and so these
numbers are not the numbers for this to
get across the world all the number all
these serial numbers at the link layer
are good for
is
to get across one connection in case
that connection is shared and if you
were to plug this into a hub and you're
plugging other computers into that same
hub well then you're sharing that
connection
and this computer might see the traffic
for that other computer and so we use
the physical addresses so that
this computer knows which of the packets
belong
to it on the piece of wire so wired
ethernet or wi-fi certainly if you're
sitting in a room with a bunch of wi-fi
computers you're sharing the air so you
have to come up with rules
how to share this how to share nicely
and how to behave
so the way it works
is
you could and this ethernet could easily
have a bunch of other computers hooked
to it right because it's really shared
and so they're all sitting here they're
all talking simultaneously
you know but we have a we have a pair of
computers that want to talk so it's not
just one it's got a bunch of folks
sitting here
just draw a bunch of them bunches of
folks
they're all talking or all potentially
talking and we got to figure out how in
the shared medium like this is think of
this as a hub and they're all connected
into this hub
including the two we want to talk
they're all connected in the hub
including the two that we want to talk
and how can these two make sure that the
data goes is this data that's sent with
the intention of going to this computer
this router
how can it make sure that it gets there
well
if it knows the address of the sending
and receiving unit it just encodes that
in the packet
and that way it sort of goes by all
these folks
let me change colors here
the packet we send goes by all these
folks
and even if they all heard every one of
the packets
they all know that it doesn't belong to
them because they all have a different
number and this is the only one that
responds to it so that allows them to
share the wireless or the wire and
share the wireless or the wire and have
it all work out for them
so so that's the idea of the link layer
now again remember this might only be
50 feet or 50 yards or 50 meters will
make it meters it's only 50 meters but
you still have to share the network in
that 50 meters
and then the router takes it off of that
and forwards it on a different link and
that's how we get across the country
but that's the next layer up and let's
not worry about that for now so the idea
is
think about one link whether it's fiber
optic or cable or wireless or wi-fi
and so what are the kind of problems
that you have to solve on this link
layer
well
so one of the things that's cool about
many link layers is like wireless and
ethernet is they can be shared and it
makes it really easy just plug new
computers in so you just sort of like
here's a hub and you just plug another
computer and it's on the network
but they have to come up with a way to
avoid the chaos when they're sharing
and so
the the way ethernet
does this
is with a technique called carrier sense
media access with collision detection
and as you'll see a lot of the things
that we do on the internet have a lot to
do with courtesy
meaning that
we're just nice and if everybody's nice
it all works out it's kind of like
driving in a car
just everyone can't run through the stop
sign at the same time somebody's got to
stop got a green light your turn my turn
whatever this probably wouldn't work so
well with cars
because sometimes you do have a
collision of packets you just have to
wait
packet collisions don't crush your car
they just slow your data down
so here we go
this is basically carrier sense media
access with collision detection the
first thing you do if you want to send
some data
say we got some data inside a little
computer we're going to send it out
knowing that there might be other data
going by
the first thing we do is we listen
we listen to what's on there
if it's not silent we just wait until it
goes silent and then we start sending
so if someone's already using it why
crash into their data and crush their
data because there's it's shared there's
only one you can't
both be sending at the same time
so first you listen
once it's silent you begin transmitting
data
and then what you do is you also
listen to your own data
and if your own data is coming back
then it's sounding pretty good
and
and then if if
you if there is a collision because
there's a chance that two computers will
want to send at the same time and
they'll collide then what they have to
do is back off and they have a
sophisticated random number calculation
so that they back off not always the
same amount each computer backs off a
different amount
and they make it so that it's fair so
one computer is not always backing the
most off so it's very fair so it's
when you detect a collision
you re-transmit
after a random back off first you avoid
collisions but in the in the rare case
that you have a collision then you do
this and so
um
i want to introduce you to
the person who invented ethernet
ethernet
this is robert metcalf
and he was
working at xerox palo alto research
center park everyone calls it park
and they had they were building what is
most considered the first computer the
alto computers they were connecting line
printers are
fast printers to these
xerox was building the first
laser printers
and they needed something faster and so
they just started building it and they
built this thing called ethernet now
it's a little different than the
ethernet that we see the first ethernet
that they built is a little different
you can see a picture of it down here if
you ever go to xerox park and get in
you'll go see this little museum they
have
it used a single piece of cable
that ran along they just ran it down the
hallway and they would connect a tap in
and then they would use that to send the
data so it would go down the hallway and
the tap would come out in each office
and they were truly sharing the media
this is not shared except when you plug
it into a hub that's what makes this
shared
and it was inspired by
an earlier wireless network where they
were doing
not collision detection but
re-transmission called aloha and a lot
of early network packet network
inspiration uh comes from the alola net
in uh you come from university of hawaii
and because
they didn't have anything except
wireless but they did have wireless they
did a lot of really cool early research
on wireless and so uh let's go ahead and
meet bob metcalf
the inventor one of the inventors of
ethernet
[Music]
so
i was extraordinarily lucky
and happened to be at the xerox research
xerox palo alto research center
when a problem evolved that had never
before occurred the problem had never
occurred and that was the problem of
having a building full of personal
computers
and i was a networking guy so they
turned to me and said
network these puppies and we had just
finished
starting the internet it was then called
the arpanet
which was packet switching
and it was pretty clear we wanted this
network to connect to the
it wasn't yet called internet thing so
it would be packet switched we're pretty
sure
at the same time we were building uh
arguably i don't want to get into that
argument the first laser printer
which in our case the first one
whose name was ears that's a whole other
story
it was a page per second 500 dots per
inch and if you do the math that's about
20 megabits per second so the existing
methods of interconnection
had a a lot of problems one is they were
all home run so all these wires one from
every desk would all come to this one
place in the building and put a big
rat's nest we called it a rat's nest by
the way
two is they generally ran at 300 bits
per second or
if you really rev them up they go to 14
4 kilobits per second
and that wasn't even close to 20
megabits per second so and we wanted to
be able to keep the printer busy by
sending documents from all these
pcs which hadn't been built yet accepted
part
well they hadn't been built even in park
at that point so we were building the
printer and we were building the
pcs all at the same time
so i um
started work on this and there was a
pre-see an effort before mine
called cygnet at park and it was being
done by charles simony my friend
and uh but he wasn't a networking guy so
they sent me in to pick up cignet from
charles
and he was going to go off and do
something else and by the way the thing
the other thing he did is he wrote a
text editor
a word processor called bravo
which then became
microsoft office wow
so charles
is a billionaire and he's been to the
space station
twice the international speed
so maybe i shouldn't have kicked him off
cignet maybe i should have done bravo i
don't know anyway so i uh immediately
decided that cygnet by the way cygnet
stands for
simoni's infinitely glorious network
was in fact infinitely glorious and much
had too many moving parts to
be a lan
by the way the word lan
wasn't invented until 1990 and this is
still 1973. so the word land was way in
the future so that's an anachronism
anyway the
the cygnet had too many moving parts for
a land
and it was in the course of
investigating how to organize this land
that i ran into a packer by quite by
accident by a packet radio network at
the university of hawaii it was called
the aloha net
and what was beautiful about the aloha
network is it had it solved a
distributed problem
that is how would we share a radio
channel back to the mainframe in hawaii
at the university
if we were just a bunch of terminals
scattered among the hawaiian islands
and they couldn't really easily talk to
each other
to get coordinated how would they
coordinate their sharing of this inbound
radio channel
and norm abramson there at the
university of y devised this very simple
randomized re-transmission procedure
where
a person would type
by the way what they would type was a
card image
it was 80 columns wide
back from the days of card
batch processing
so you would type in your card image and
hit send
and then your terminal would
send it in toward the mainframe
and then would wait
a short time to see if there was an
acknowledgement returned on the outbound
channel
and if there was everything was
hunky-dory but if there wasn't that
probably meant the two terminals had
decided to send at the same time
so then as many terminals as
participated in that collision of
transmissions
would then
randomize and and then re-transmit at a
random time in the future thereby if
they overlapped here they very likely
would not overlap again in the future
because they would choose different
random numbers to count down
so that's
randomized retransmission multiple
access
so i since i was trying to avoid this
big rat's nest of wires and only wanted
to have one wire just one wire not 16 or
32 or whatever the
alternatives were just one
i wanted a distributed solution to how
to share this cable and the aloha
network produced that using randomized
retransmissions so then i um
actually you know
there's sort of two stories here one is
a hardware story we've learned about the
hardware there's a hardware story and
there's a software story and the
hardware story is uh
not that interesting but it's there
so one of the first things i did was to
buy a kilometer of cable or maybe a mile
i don't know if i'd gone metric yet but
i saw a spool of
coax cable about this big with the two
ends
sticking up
so i got a
pulse generator and i hooked it up to
one end and
hooked it around back into the
oscilloscope and started launching
square waves down the cable and watching
what came out i thought that would be
good preparation for building a network
and what came out the other side wasn't
a square wave it was sort of
sort of lazy rise times and lazy fall
times
but if you put a
a digital gate
you could recover the square wave that
is you just said
use the digital threshold and so out of
this gate came a square way so you could
recover
at the end of a mile of cable this
square wave so i kind of knew
i kind of had some confidence then that
we that various stations connected to
this cable could inject their square
waves
and the other guys could recover them
so
that hardware
wasn't that hard but it um
it was a
straightforward so the first hardware
was kind of relatively straightforward
very straightforward and the and the
square wave by the way was called
manchester u what we do is we take the
bit we'd make a packet of bits
and then we'd send them one at a time
down this cable and we would encode them
and the encoding was also simple it was
manchester coding meaning
for each bit the first half of the bit
would be
the complement of the bit and the second
half of the bit would be the bit so you
would have a transition in the middle of
each bit cell
which is a very simple modulation scheme
so as you're sending the packet the
cable's wiggling and you can recover the
signal at the other end and clock those
bits into a shift register then click to
clock the shift register into the memory
and collect the packet that way
and that all took just some soldering to
make that all happen basically well i
don't wanna
it got a little bit complicated when you
wanted to put 255 of them on a mile of
cable you had to be a little bit careful
about the impedance of the taps
because a square wave coming by a tap
might generate reflections that would
then interfere
but the beauty of manchester encoding
was that while you were sending a packet
there were constant transitions so if
you listened
you could tell whether a packet was
going by and you didn't have to listen
for long you only had to listen for
about a bit time and then you which
which turned out to be 340 nanoseconds
so you could wait that long and tell
whether there was a packet going by
so one of the first differences between
the ethernet and the aloha now there are
a lot of differences but one of the
first ones was
carrier sense
in the aloha network
you couldn't tell if somebody else was
transmitting at the same time as you but
on the ethernet you could and the
advantage of that was you might as well
if you're sending and somebody else is
sending at the same time you might as
well give up because you've destroyed
each other's packets so punt then that
recovers that bandwidth that would
otherwise be lost to just
continuing to transmit a damage packet
and the
the other thing was this this manchester
code meant that the cable was on half
the time and off half the time that is
the the driver sort of an open what we
used to call an open collector driver
would either yank the cable up to
three or four or five volts i even
forget the voltage now
but it was under five i'm sure that i
had a rule i never won above five volts
uh
you would yank the cable up and then
during the other half the bit when you
weren't yanking you let go so
so for example in each bit cell you got
to look
to see if anyone else was transmitting
when you had stopped and if there was
somebody else then you had a collision
so that was the second feature so it was
really a digital signal it was really a
digital signal it wasn't modulated
signal in any way right no well it was
uh best you could send a digital signal
over coax on off with the manchester
encoding so the ink
manchester encoding is akin to a
modulation scheme but it's the simplest
one you can think of it's very baseband
yeah and it is very baseband but it's a
sort of modulation scheme that a
computer scientist would come up with as
opposed to one of those fancy
radio people right so and and by the way
i took a lot of gas from all those radio
people why did you use such a simple
scheme you wasted
you would have wasted all that ban you
wasted all that bandwidth that capable
that cable was capable of carrying
hundreds of megabits per second and you
only carried 2.94 what a waste of the
cable
well
there was plenty of cable to waste so
we've talked about carrier since
inclusion detection
and the scheme would be that each packet
would carry
two addresses the address of the
destination and the
the address of the source
and each of these would be eight bits
and so on the back plane of these little
personal computers with wire app
you would wire wrap in a code between 0
and 255 and that would be the serial
number of the machine and that and then
you would read that off the back plane
and put it in the packet
so each packet had two addresses this is
different from the loan incidentally
which had one address because the
channel was only going
through two channels
so two addresses and we added uh
a cyclic redundancy checksum on the end
of the packet which we implemented in
hardware so that you in addition
so you could tell if the packet had been
damaged so if there was a collision
and the
terminal the contending stations backed
off there would be a hunk of garbage on
the cable zipping around but when it was
received the checksum wouldn't add up
and you just throw that chunk of garbage
away the day that i was launching pulses
down this spool of cable
i was doing some soldering
and i was doing some
knife work to get the insulation off the
copper and
and across the room was a young grad
student who was doing something else and
he noticed me
not being good at this
and turns out he was very good at it
because he had worked in a television
studio and he had worked in cable
television so he knew all about skinning
wires and coaxes so he came over to help
me and i was his name was david boggs
and then we started working together
and
invented ethernet together
so he was and he was
he was
slightly more hardware and i was
slightly more software but there was
then a third guy
who was even more hardware than david
who was the picofarad guy the guy who
would put those last few passive
components on the end just to be sure
that that connection to the coaxial
cable
would be clean for transmissions you
wouldn't every time you tapped into it
you didn't put a big lump of impedance
on the tapping seems like a
counter-intuitive thing
to me i mean think that i mean everyone
would think that a star is the right
thing but you were going to tap into
that just
well
one of the problems we decided to solve
was the rat's nest problem we did not
want a rat's nest and every time we
installed a new pc we didn't have to
home run a cable back to the rat's nest
so we wanted to put one cable down the
middle of the corridor and then every
time you want to put a pc you just run
up and tap into it
and we didn't want the network to go out
and go down while you were tapping into
it because we wanted 24x7 access to the
network so there had to be a way to tap
into the network without bringing it
down
so that led to a a device we found in
the cable tv industry
okay it was called a geralt tap and it
was basically
a vampire tap you'd you'd drill a little
hole in the outer
casing of the coax and then you would
screw in this tap that would puncture
the insulation and go right to the
copper and tap in and you notice in that
operation you're not breaking the copper
so the network continues sending you tap
in and you're now part of the network so
that came from the cable industry it did
oh so a guy named david liddell who had
done cable tv installations
when he was in grad school in toledo
uh suggested that we use the gerald tap
since it was already being made in
volume and worked just fine as far as he
was concerned and it allowed us to solve
the rat's nest what we perceived to be
an important problem the rats nest
problem
the aloha network ran in the kilobit per
second range like 4 800 or
i don't remember the numbers but
kilobits per second ethernet then
started at 2.94 megabit and in those
days by the way t1
was
1.544 megabits per second so in 1973
he said it was already twice as fast as
t1
of course t1 still around
oddly
but then we went from
29 2.94
we briefly went to 20 megabits per
second inside of xerox
and then when we bumped into deck and
intel for the standardization process in
802 we decided on 10 we came down from
20 to 10 so the chips would work
and then we went from 10 and later
i helped found a company called grand
junction networks that introduced the
100 meg ethernet and i remember being at
my coffee table
in palo alto i think it was
i forget the year no maybe it was in
woodside
but we were trying to think of how we
would make a faster ethernet
and uh there's some math that shows that
if you as you go faster the efficiency
depends on the diameter of the network
and as you go faster and faster the
efficiency goes down
the diameter network in bits
and we're trying to go up a factor of 10
and
and then i don't know who it was
one of us observed that wait a minute
we've been assuming that ethernet is a
kilometer in diameter
but we're going we're all going to hubs
now so that
we only need 100 meters not a thousand
meters and that was the factor of 10
right there so by changing the
collision interval
you maintain the same efficiencies uh
theoretical efficiencies
by just
assuming going 100 meters instead of a
kilometer so that got us to 100 megabits
per second and now gigabit
10 gigabit which i guess is the
mainstream now and then 100 gigabit is
now from beginning to run 100 gigabits
per second you can't
you can't be a computer scientist and
build that kind of digital now you have
to actually be an engine a hardware
engineer to run at 100
i think at that point you're pretty much
a radio person
yes but then after 100 gigabits comes
terabit so i've already begun giving
talks on terabit ethernet
[Music]
welcome back so i hope you uh enjoyed
that now i want to make it real clear
that
when i give you a 15 minute video of an
amazing
inventor and computer scientist
you don't have to remember every word
that that person says okay
it's more important to get the gist of
it i try to cover the things i really
want you to know in my slides
and you might want to listen to it more
than once or
listen my slides and then go back but
you're not i don't want you to memorize
it i i wanted to give you
smart people i want you to hear from the
smart people who did all this cool work
in their own words
but when we hear from their own words
they're
sometimes pretty technical so
just relax and enjoy listening to these
people and understand that you're not
going to get everything but hopefully
you'll come back and you'll get more and
more later so
the idea was that he really started with
this idea of wireless which which was
we're going to share one medium and the
wireless and the wire the ethernet wire
that he built the coaxial cable that he
built was like a giant
radio except it ran in the ceiling
and so the design ended up really simple
and that's that's been good for ethernet
over the years and later wi-fi is a
variation of ethernet um and so it turns
out to be
uh sometimes it's best to build
something simple but that just make it
go really fast and make it really cheap
he also formed the company 3com which
was one of the first manufacturers of pc
cards and so back in the day you would
go buy a pc and you would go buy a 3com
card and plug it in the back your
computer and so
there was a time when san francisco
stadium candlestick park was named
3com stadium and
our friend bob metcalf was involved in
all of that so he's done many things
throughout his life and we're honored to
have met him
so
we started with this four-layer
architecture that says we're going to
break down a big problem of cooperating
applications across various kinds of
networks
we're going to break it down and we just
got done talking about the link layer
it's literally 20 000 maybe 50 000
engineers have spent the last 20 years
figuring out how to make this work
because the layered architecture lets
them think
although it was informed
they have twenty thousand fifty thousand
i don't know
twenty thousand engineers that think
about that problem and they ignore the
rest of the problems okay they ignore
the rest of the problems
that's great because they've gotten
really good at this one problem
now we're going to go like you know i
don't know how many engineers let's just
make it up 5k engineers think about this
next problem
the next problem is called oh my color's
got to change
the inter network layer
it is the notion of forwarding
each of the postcards with a from in the
two address
forwarding enough times to get them all
the way across the network that's the
next problem we're going to solve
we're going to stop thinking about the
link layer we're just going to assume it
works it's just magic that's what a
layered architecture gives you you don't
worry about the stuff above you you
don't worry about the stuff below you
you focus like crazy
on the stuff that you're focusing on so
the link layer
only works on
one link right it worries about one link
and there might be 15 or so of these
links
but the internet layer worries about all
the links and
the proper sequence of links to follow
to get from
um to stanford
that's a kind of complex problem
we're not going to worry about
reliability we're just going to worry
about if i had a pack if i had a
postcard with a from a2 address a packet
can i get it there
how will i forward it
i assume the link layer is perfect so
the internet layer is the first end to
end because if you recall
this vertical box set of boxes is the
host starting computer and this vertical
set of boxes is the destination computer
so
in this little raspberry pi
all four of these things application
transport ip
and the link is all part of this one
gadget okay
so i p is best effort and it's okay to
drop data if things go bad and that's
one of its charming most charming
features
but what it had to introduce in addition
to the ethernet addresses or the media
access layer mac addresses
is
an address of the destination
now if you remember the mac addresses
the addresses for the link layer come
from the manufacturer the moment this
equipment is manufactured is burned in a
serial number but these move all around
the world
if this runs here at the university of
michigan it needs one address to connect
to the network
one ip address if it runs in stanford it
needs a different ip address so we have
to be able to change these they're
assigned differently
so it's the worldwide number
that is your like postcard address it's
like a phone number right so wherever
i'm at you call my phone and this gadget
rings
so it's address
well that's actually kind of a
bad example because i use the same phone
number okay ignore that
phones use magic they use crazy magic
so in computers they're not as cool as
phones you have to change the address
everywhere you go we'll talk about how
you change the address everywhere you go
the ip addresses are based on where the
station is connected
they do get reorganized once in a great
while but not very often and you can
even go to various websites on the
internet
and say i p address lookup is the most
common search
and it will tell you something about
where you're coming from
right and it'll kind of be sometimes
really weird because you might be at a
starbucks and it might send it all to st
louis and it might say oh you're coming
from st louis even if you're not so you
can look it up and you can look up other
address as well you can say oh here's an
ip address i'm going to look this one up
first it starts by looking yours up but
you can put in different addresses like
in this particular one if i put a
different address in here it will
actually go look that address up
so the ip address format it's four
numbers that are separated by dots each
of the number
can be between one and two thousand and
255 and it's just a representation of a
32-bit number
back in the day they kept the numbers
small because didn't want to use all the
computer memory
and so this is an example of an ip
address
four numbers between 0 and 255
separated by dots
okay now
the concept the address is broken into
two parts there is the network number
part
which is the prefix and then there is
the computer number within network
okay and it's kind of like phone numbers
were before cell phones where the area
code
was
where the phone was and then this was
within that area code where to find it
and even the older days these were
actually geographic too right so these
numbers would be neighborhoods or
whatever
these days it's all electronic so that
the the precise mapping of a phone
number to a geography is uh is less
precise and that's why you get a cell
phone number and you move to a whole new
state you keep your old cell phone
number because it's become electronic
but in the early days when it was actual
relays and switches making the phone
numbers work
they actually had to do with where
it's actually kind of fascinating how
phones work gotta how to teach a class
on like how phone switches worked in the
1800s actually quite fascinating
because they were surprisingly simple
that's the interesting part how simple
turn of the century well turn of last
century phone numbers were
so
let's get back to ip addresses
there's four numbers
some part of those four numbers is a
prefix we call that the network number
and
when the packet is in the middle of the
network it doesn't really look at these
numbers it only looks at the prefix so
it kind of thinks of
all the packets going to
a piece of university of michigan as 141
211 star star and then we we design
these numbers within michigan and then
this number is assigned to us by the
internet authority that assigns numbers
so we say hey we need some more and they
give us a prefix then within that prefix
we get to set up all the other things
so
this network number which is the prefix
of the ip address is the way that a
packet is routed through the internet as
it progresses through the internet
and so it's sort of like if i start with
if i start with
my computer here at um and that's my
number that's my actual number and
here's the stanford computer and that's
its number
right and i send a packet and i say okay
this i'm gonna i'm gonna send it from
141 to 11 144 188 269 67 149 yada yada
as soon as the packet enters the network
it doesn't throw the data away but it
stops thinking about it only looks at
the prefix
and so it simplified greatly simplifies
what the routers have to do as it goes
across the hops in the internet it's
greatly simplified because it only looks
at the first part it doesn't have to
look at the whole thing
and then it starts making decisions as
to how to get there says okay i'll hop
it over here
then it's like in kansas city and says
ah what am i going to do here and
i'll pick one of those two links and
i'll go over here
and then as it exits the network it
dumps it somehow onto stanford's campus
and then it finds its way oh didn't find
it to this one it found its way to that
one there you go unpredictable computers
now it so within the stanford campus
these numbers mean something and the
stanford campus uses those numbers to
get the thing to the actual real
computer
and so it's sort of use this prefix you
know it has a real number but then it
uses the prefix in the middle and then
the real number reappears at the end so
that's called a network number and it
greatly simplifies
it's complex enough
to be in the middle
and have to worry about all these things
coming from
kansas city and
beijing and like where these things go
to have to look at each one and know
where every computer is is crazy
so that's why they call it the inter
network protocol because it says there's
one network there's another network and
the only thing i care about is the
network number and i am the internetwork
protocol i p
internet work protocol i'm just getting
these things from one network to another
network and then it's up to that network
to figure out how to get the darn thing
to the right computer within it and it's
up to stanford to figure out how to get
it to the right computer at stanford so
these things are called the network
number it's the prefix of the ip address
now the key thing that it's really a
beautiful beautiful design because it
because
the center of the network is both
exceedingly complex
in one way that it's so big and so fast
but exceedingly simple in the other it
just has to move the data from point a
to point b
and if you think about it's even simpler
if we look at it from the perspective
of this router the router here i've got
circled
right it just received a packet it looks
at the network number and it actually
doesn't even care to some degree where
it really belongs
it only has one of two choices it's
going to go this way it's going to go
that way
right
which one's better
and it turns out if you look at it
either one would work
turns out this one is better but if i
went this way it would just take an
extra
tenth of a second or something right so
it turns out the decisions that are made
don't even have to be perfect
you can make the wrong decision and the
network automatically corrects that's
part of the goal of the network and so
it really simplifies and limits
the
the the need for each router to
understand the entire network which
makes these routers i draw them small on
these diagrams on purpose because we
think of them as small and fast and only
solving a really tiny problem but doing
it really super awesome
so routers maintain
what we call router tables
and they maintain a list of network
numbers and the best outbound route
for each of the network numbers
now the other thing that they do
is they pass
routes back and forth and this is how
they adapt to errors right they get
updated dynamically they ask each other
for the best place if they see a network
number they haven't seen before they ask
their neighbors and their neighbors
neighbors and they go oh god okay i got
a good way to get to 67 149 and so
there's all kinds of communication but
it's relatively slow and it doesn't have
to be perfect
and so it's router tables are what
routers have but they're indexed by the
network number of the packets not the
host of the destination so that's an
amazing
amazing improvement in the performance
and efficiency of the
internet core the ip core
so it's really quite simple
right you basically
have a local area network on your campus
this might actually be your house too
house is kind of like a campus
and you can do all the crazy things you
want hundreds of computers thousands of
hundreds of servers and thousands of
laptops and you get one address that is
the address
of your campus
it's the network number of your campus
to the rest of the world
and then all over the world people can
send to you
and by simply looking at the prefix
data makes it to you
keeps this really simple
and really fast
okay
so it's beautiful
that's what the network number one area
code one network number it's the only
thing has to be kept track of a whole
um campus can be characterized within
the core of the network as basically a
single network number now the reality is
it's usually
a few of these because they get given to
you in smaller chunks so you end up with
you know 20 or 30 of these things for
your campus if you're a medium to large
campus
okay
so now i want to talk a little bit about
the problem of
computers that move around
so you have a laptop
and you use it at your local coffee shop
and then you close the lid and you go
home and open it
and it works at home
and then you close the lid and you go to
school and you open it and talk to
wireless at school and it works
it's like
hey dr chuck you just told me that i
have to have this address and i can't
talk on the internet if i don't have the
right address and the packets are routed
based on the prefix of this address why
is it that i can be three places coffee
shop home
and school and it seems like everything
works well
that's because
while your computer has an ethernet
address that's baked in at the factory
most computers are configured when they
first open up and connect to a wi-fi to
ask
instead of having an ip address
configured in your computer they send a
request out to say
hey
i'm new here
is there anyone who will give me an ip
address that i might use for this
particular location
and
if there is an access point say at your
starbucks
it says
sure
use this one you're at starbucks that's
a good number for starbucks now it turns
out that the prefix of this is exactly
the prefix that the the world sees all
this traffic to starbucks so there's
actually kind of a real address
okay
and it gives you an address
okay so you ask when your thing comes up
it asks what can i get and then it's
told what address to use so using one
address while you're at starbucks a
different address at home and a
different address yet again at school
so that's called the dynamic host
configuration
protocol now it turns out
with schools and
homes and
there's just too many computers
to give every computer
a real address and so we have these
special addresses
they're called the non-routable
addresses
so you'll probably notice if you go to
one person's house
you will have a ip address of
192.168.something
something go to different person's house
it'll also be
192.168.something.something
they go to your house it's
and you're like how can that work
i seem to have the same address well
that's because of a technology called
network address translation
where
each of the home routers actually has a
unique and distinct address but you're
not seeing it
it's giving you a temporary address an
address that really can't run at all on
the internet it only lives within the
house but then as your packets leave the
house or leave the starbucks
the real address is put in and then when
it comes back the real address is taken
out and your local address is put in so
they're called non-routable addresses
because if they ever escaped into the
real internet they'd be like oh those
are for your house they're only for
they're not supposed to go very far and
i don't even know where they go they go
nowhere
in the core of the internet but they go
properly inside your house so the way
this ends up working
is if you are at
your coffee shop
the coffee shop has an address
you associate with their base access
point
it gives you a non-routable address to
use locally
and then as your traffic gets sent
this address is changed to the address
that address you never see this
happening it's done as the packet goes
through the base station
and then when the packet comes back it
comes back with this address but then as
it goes to the base station it switches
back to this address
so even though this address is not the
real address the network sees they see
you having this address here
so if you would do an ip lookup from a
coffee shop
the coffee shop will be identified you
will see the ip address here and if you
looked at your laptop your laptop would
not have that same address because it's
being translated
in
the
access point
so then you go
home
and at home
your access point has a different
address
but your computer asks your ass address
asks your access point
for an address
and it gets a local address that's
generated locally and again there's a
mapping it's called nat
n-a-t i'll change the color n-a-t
network address translation so as the
packet goes through
it takes out the one address and puts in
the second date comes back it takes the
address out and puts the local one in
and the same thing happens at school
right so you're at school finally and
you get a different address they're not
the same but you look and the prefixes
are the same it's like they should be
the same place but they're completely
different because your school has a
different address and there's a
translation that goes back and forth as
the data goes around and round so just
for the distance of the local wi-fi or
whatever use these 192.168 numbers and
then they're translated to the real
numbers by your network access points
so these are illegal
inside this network so if it ever saw a
192.168
it would just throw that packet away
they're only
for very local connections
so with that
i'm wondering if by now
you know why
this is funny
i'll give you a minute
okay so the reason this is funny
is she traced the killer's ip address
and it had a prefix of 192.168
which means the killer had to be within
a relatively short radius
using likely the same wi-fi access point
which means it was close
very scary
i hope you think it's funny
it of course xkcd is never exactly funny
but it hopefully makes you smile a
little bit
so up till now
i've been talking about
so up to now i've been talking about
this cloud network that's magic and the
packets take different routes and we
don't know but they show up remember the
mailbox like they just show up or don't
show up right
so
it turns out
that sometimes we as engineers want to
take a look at what's going on inside
the internet
and it turned out that there was a
feature they added early on to help
diagnose problems in the internet that
we still use today and it's so
convenient that it's built right into
your operating system if you have a
macintosh or linux traceroute is built
in and if you have windows you've got to
install traceroute so just say windows
install tracer out and you'll find
something
but
there was a problem so if you recall i
said that
each router sees the world very narrowly
and simply sees a packet and makes a
decision
on one place
so let's say that
here comes a packet on the way to
stanford
and these routers are sort of strangely
configured
this router thinks it should go there
and this router thinks it should go
there
well it comes in and goes like oh well i
know where that one goes there
so if you end up with this misconfigured
router situation
you end up with your data going round
and round in circles
it would actually like crush the network
because it's like a whirlpool
you can't even notice that it's
happening because there might actually
be
you know
you know there might be a bunch of them
and then it comes back and you send it
around again
so you're filling up all your bandwidth
it's never going to get there
unless something changes and such
something crashes
it's not going to change because these
routers think that's the best thing to
do they're mistaken but they are they
can be mistaken because they're they're
operating with imperfect information
so how would you solve this problem
it's like
routers are imperfect
so they solve the problem with a thing
called the time to live field
so much like the network interest
translation tweaks the addresses on the
way in and on the way out the time to
live is a field that routers change
every time a packet goes through a
router it subtracts one from this field
and it starts with a number between 25
it can be as high as 255 but it's
usually like 25. and um
what happens is every time the packet
goes through a router the number goes
down by one so if it was it would be
come in here as 255
then it would go through here 254
and 253
it would come back it'd be 252
and what would happen is eventually
it would get
to one of these guys and it hit zero and
they would decide
okay
you've been running around too long we
will throw you away
so the number goes down and it always
goes down
but then when it hits zero
they throw the packet away they say we
you have been through 255 hops chances
are good you're never going to get to
your destination
so
the traceroute command
sort of cheats
normal packets are sent with a ttl or
time to live of like 30
30 hops or 40 hops
but what trace route does it sends
broken packets
it turns out
that when a router throws away your
packet most of the time it is courteous
and it sends you back a notification
says hi
i got your packet i decremented it
subtracted one
and it got to zero
and i threw it away sorry about that
here's here's who i am i mean i really
feel bad about throwing your packet away
maybe you want to figure something else
out i don't know something must be
messed up can't be my fault but i threw
it away
so what traceroute does is it first
sends a packet with a time to live of
one so the first router goes like whoa
this has been around a long time set to
zero throws it away then sends a note
back
then traceroute sends a packet of two
across
it goes hop hop and it gets thrown away
a little note comes back
so you can kind of build a map by
sending enough packets and getting kind
of a return
rejection from one of the routers
it would have got there
so if for example i do a trace route
from the university of michigan to
stanford
you'd if i did it now it'd be a
different set of things
i get this output
and if i take a look at this
this is the hop so there's the first one
two three four through fourteen
fourteen hops so it takes 14 hops now
interestingly again i don't remember
what the hop count was in the store and
forward days but it's quite a few
and that's because it's optimizing
geography
and so you can see the first top is on
my campus
then i the second and third hop are
bouncing around my campus some more
now we don't quite know where this one
is but now it's on an on a national
network called internet2 internet2
internet2 this is probably going across
the country
and then it ends up on scenic
which i think is sort of california's
network it bounces through california a
couple times
let's see uh
hpr lax so that's los angeles
this is
i don't know where that is los angeles
now looks like it's making to oakland
i don't know there's probably some
meaning to these things so it's making
it through oakland
and then it's going to stanford from
something oakland i don't know
but now it's on stanford campus and now
it has three more hops to get across the
stanford campus to the stanford campuses
web server now what's also going on here
is keeping track of how long it's taking
it sends each one a couple of times
and so these are milliseconds so
milliseconds or thousandths of a second
so
534 milliseconds is a half a second 490
is a half a second so these are like
half a second half a second oh wait no
no sorry not a half second that'd be
four thousand well
one thousand milliseconds would be one
second so i got that all wrong
so
point four nine milliseconds is like
half of a thousandth of a second so
that's fast
fast six milliseconds is six one
thousandths of a second
76 milliseconds which is nine hops away
that's seventy six thousands or seven
one hundredths
so it takes about seven one hundredths
yeah
so like
77 over a thousand
so no seven one hundredths sorry seven
one hundredths of a second
it's less than a tenth of a second to
get through
fourteen routers from michigan to
stanford
less than a tenth of a second
pretty impressive
now if i do a trace route from ann arbor
michigan to east lansing michigan
michigan state university we have a very
close connection i mentioned the merit
network where we've had a close
connection for a long time
so not only
is it fewer hops it's only eight hops to
get to michigan state
um if you look at the if you look at the
hops here
um i'm bouncing around the campus for
three i'm bouncing through the state for
two
and bouncing on the michigan state
campus
for three so it's a total of eight
two hops to get two three offs to get
across my campus two hops to get across
the state of michigan and three hops to
get on campus and it's really fast
it's nine one thousandths of a second
which is
less than a hundredth of a second
so really fast you can kind of see it
now if you ran this trace route more
than once
this might change it doesn't change too
fast but
legally it could change i mean it
there's no guarantee it's going to be
the same it's highly likely it's going
to be the same because the most
efficient way is not going to change
within a few seconds but if you start in
the middle of the day and you do it the
next day it might change quite a bit so
be something to play with
run it
print it out
run it again at midnight run it's noon
see if your trace route is different
right be interesting
so here's an example of a trace route
from university of michigan to peking
university in china
and um
and so it's again you know it's
it bounces through the state of my
campus for a couple of hops
right my campus for a couple of hops it
bounces around
the united states for a couple of hops
and then it starts crossing the pacific
ocean
it goes this there's traffic actually
went through seoul korea
and then it ended up in beijing
now the interesting thing is you can see
that it looks like it's taking about
sixty one thousands or six one
hundredths
just over uh
just almost well a half a tenth of a
second
to get across the country
and then it starts taking longer and
then by the time it's going all the way
to china and back it's doing 256
milliseconds which is about a quarter of
a second
now the big difference here
is likely not traffic it is likely the
speed of light
it is how fast it takes light to get
across the pacific ocean
so it takes a while
the reason i think it's most likely
these numbers understand
it's low traffic because these are very
consistent
pretty much all the time so that
suggests that we're not waiting for any
traffic we're getting through as fast as
we physically can
which is some combination of the speed
of the length and the speed of light
so
we just got done talking about how we
add to every packet this global number
the ip address
it has the prefix of the network number
in the internet part the internetwork
where it's really moving data from one
network to another network and leaving
it up to those destination networks how
to how to move it
um
we end up really simplifying the
postcard and the postcard ends up being
a really apt example
but the key thing
especially when thinking about the
four-layer architecture that the reason
that i think tcpip succeeded was in this
real complex problem of moving data
between billions of computers
it kept the part in the middle real
simple
it doesn't try to be perfect it doesn't
try to re-transmit data don't try to
store it it doesn't try to keep it in
the right order it doesn't try to say
that if this packet went here i'm gonna
make sure the next one goes there
the two packets one if one gets ahead we
don't really care
um it means it really fast and really
scalable
and um by keeping it simple and really
fast um
it solves really an amazing problem but
we yet have other problems to solve
so i want to close
this lecture
by introducing you to another person
so vint cerf
was a graduate student as the whole
notion of packet switching was being
sort of examined both in the federal
government at the defense advanced
research project agency darpa
and
in higher education
both in the united states and europe
uk and elsewhere
and so vint cerf was kind of at the
right place at the right time and we
could be very thankful for that he's
credited as being one of the fathers of
the arpanet
which of course begat
the internet
and so
vint is going to talk to us
in a sense going back even free arpanet
and bring us up
packets and what packets mean
and then how that all flowed into the
arpanet and how the arpanet evolved
to become the internet
enjoy
[Music]
packet switching was an idea which
was specifically studied
by len kleinrock at mit who was actually
looking at message switching and he did
a
brilliant dissertation on the use of
queuing theory to analyze what networks
of cues would look like
using this
message switching approach
and his analysis although we'd never use
the word packet
is as equally
applicable to packet switching as it is
to message switching so that's one
important milestone in round 1961.
in 62 or thereabouts paul barron
is doing work for the rand corporation
and is deeply concerned about the
ability to preserve command and control
in a post-nuclear environment we were
seriously worried that the russians
would actually launch and that we would
suffer a nuclear attack and then we had
to be able to respond and we needed
command and control for that
so paul in 1962 before the existence of
integrated circuits or anything else
is
saying we really should be
digitizing and packetizing voice
and then using sort of the pole mounted
radios that are able to transmit in all
directions to create a highly connected
environment so that if holes were
knocked out of it by nuclear explosions
you would still if it's a fabric that's
in any way connected information could
get from one end to the other
so he envisioned the notion of a message
block
and it was dynamically routed he used
hot potato routing if you got something
he got rid of it as fast as he could he
chopped up the speech into little 20
millisecond pieces
he didn't talk so much about data as i
remember it and this was supposed to be
a highly resilient voice network for
command and control i may have just done
him a disservice because later
he was very much
conscious of the importance of data
communication too
so that's around 1962 it gets documented
in an 11 volume series called
undistributed communications and he
can't sell it to anybody
the traditional telcos att in particular
and the people at what was then the
defense communication system or defense
communications agency laughed him out of
the room said this was a silly idea
couldn't possibly work
and so you know he should just go away
so he never got anywhere with that in
spite of all the documentation in 66
larry roberts along with one other guy
whose name i'm now not remembering does
a point-to-point experiment to test
packet switching it was between the
ansfq
seven machine at s
system development corporation in santa
monica
and uh
the uh tx2 machine at mit lincoln
laboratories was where larry was they
demonstrated on a 2400 you know bit line
bit per second line that you can move
packets back and forth then in the
64-65 time frame
a man named donald w davies at the
national physical laboratory in london
also gets the bug tries to get money
from the science research commission at
uh
in england and gets only enough to build
one node you know he the one node
network so he builds this packet net he
invents the term packet to describe what
these objects are and it works he's got
a bunch of you know terminals and other
things hanging off of this one node so
in a funny way he built a local area
network
if you like
but it was you know based on physical
wires
so those three guys introduced packet
switching larry and uh whoever it was
that he worked with um demonstrate that
it's possible to get two very distinct
kinds of computers to talk to each other
using the standard way
jcr lick glider is a
psychologist actually at mit
but he's convinced in the early 60s that
computing is important to
non-numeric processing that it will
allow people to
work together and collaborate in ways
that they never could before
he comes and starts the information
processing techniques office at arpa
with this being his bonnet and who does
he encounter
he encounters douglas engelbart
at sri international and the two bond
basically because engelbart was all
about non-numeric computing and the
ability of people to build up
the superstructure of communications and
documents and interact with each other
hyperlinking the mouse the portrait mode
display back on my black and white
presentations i mean the guy had a world
wide web in a box at sri
and
lick lighter understands that
lick lighter is sending out notes to his
little community of people talking about
the intergalactic network you know maybe
tony and cheek
so
he really gets credit for having put
this meme in place at arpa
then taylor comes along to pick up the
the responsibility for running the ipto
from lick lighter and is all hacked off
because he's got three terminals in his
office at the pentagon connected to
three different machines and he can't
through he says why can't there be one
terminal talking to all three we need a
network
and so
as he's pursuing this idea uh with
charlie hertzfeld who's the head of arpa
at the time charlie hands him a million
bucks over a 20-minute conversation and
now taylor's got the problem who's going
to actually do this because taylor is
not a technologist either he's
another you know kind of psychologist
type
so he decides to get larry roberts from
lincoln laboratories who did that packet
thing and larry doesn't want to come
so he goes and complains about this to
charlie hertzfeld charlie calls up the
guy that runs lincoln laboratories and
says you know we pay for a significant
fraction of your research budget every
year you should
you should tell larry he should show up
and in fact
i thought that maybe larry had been
forced to do this you know by charlie i
think it was probably a little less
awful than that but
larry was persuaded to come down
eventually of course inherited the
operation of the office from bob taylor
but in the meantime is the guy
responsible for doing the initiating the
internet or the arpanet project
so they write an rfc or an rfq request
for quotation
a bunch of responses come back probably
on the order of a couple dozen i don't
know personally for sure how many i know
that i wrote one of them with my
colleague
steve crocker while we were still at
ucla as graduate students but we were
consulting with a company called jacobi
systems in santa monica jacobi systems
wrote one of the responses bull bear
neck and newman wrote another response
primarily written by bob khan who come
to bbn from mit
so
the responses come back and they get
evaluated and four of them end up
and the jacobi systems one isn't one of
them or if it was it didn't get selected
bnn got selected
so steve crocker and i kind of hiked
back to ucla as graduate students
and the next thing we know glenn
kleinrock who's at ucla and who'd
written you know this original
dissertation work on packet switching
has come to ucla to teach and explore um
a queuing theory
is uh a closed uh compatriot of larry
roberts because they were both at
lincoln labs together
so he gets the network measurement
center piece of the arpanet project
and steve crocker and i and john postel
all of us from the same high school in
santa monica and the san fernando valley
end up in lane kleinrock's
operation
running the network measurement center
so i was the principal programmer for
that steve crocker took the
responsibility for managing and leading
the network working group has led to the
protocols host to host protocols
and john postel eventually becomes the
keeper of the documentation he's the rfc
editor which steve crocker started
request for comments he's the guy that
becomes the numbers are which is keeping
track of address spaces and allocations
and eventually becomes the domain name
manager or the internet assigned numbers
authority when the internet happens that
hasn't happened yet the this period of
time of the arpanet
program
it brings us up to 1972. and this is an
important moment in this whole history
because the first demonstration of the
arpanet happens
in the washington hilton hotel basement
in october of 72 a whole bunch of people
from the networking
interested networking community packet
switching community attend not only in
the us but from france and from england
and italy and germany and elsewhere
that group of about 25 or 30 people
convenes sees the arpanet in operation
sees applications that were being done
including doug engelbart's stuff
and then forms this international
network working group modeled after the
working group that steve crocker managed
to build the arpanet system
and at this point i become the chairman
of that group because steve is busy at
arpa doing artificial intelligence
the next
at the end of that year bob khan leaves
bulk baron nick and newman and goes to
arpa
i leave ucla where i've been working
with kleinrock and and crocker and
pastel and i go to stanford so bob is at
arpa i met at stanford and in the spring
of 73 bob comes out
from
arpa and he says i have a problem he
says what's your problem he says well we
got this arpanet and he said yep
but we also are working on
other networking capability to make
command and control work for the
military if you're going to be serious
about putting computers in command and
control they have to be mobile they have
to be in you know armored personnel
vehicles and tanks and all these other
things they have to be seabourn so we
can ship the ship and ship to shore
communications which means satellite
and we so we need mobile radio we need
satellite in addition to
the fixed wire systems that are
represented by the arpanet we have fixed
installations that are not moving around
so we have all these different
technologies and bob's brilliant idea
is not to build one network with all
those technologies embedded in it
instead he breaks them apart and says
let's build a packet satellite network
which optimizes the use of satellite
takes into account that it's got a half
a second round trip time let's build a
packet radio network which optimizes a
system whose connectivity is changing
with time as things move around and you
get variable delay and also variable
interference
so these were three different packet
networks then the problem is how do you
hook them together you wouldn't have
this problem if you put all the
technologies into one net but if you put
them all into one net it makes it really
hard to do control over all these highly
variable parameters so instead he says
break them into different networks and
connect those together so we design and
build a gateway which today we call a
router
and that concept
also introduced a whole bunch of other
things like how do you refer to another
network each network thinks it's the
only network in the universe this is
true of the proprietary networks like
sna and decnet and so on
and
you didn't have a vocabulary to say take
this packet and move it to another
computer on another network somewhere
else that you might not even be
connected to so we have to invent an
internet address space in order to solve
that problem
we have to find a way to allow packet
losses in this path to be recovered
which is where tcp now becomes a manager
of reliability on an end-to-end basis
instead of relying on each net to be
reliable the arpanet was built on the
assumption you could build a reliable
underlying man the internet was based on
the assumption that no network was
necessarily reliable and you had to do
end-to-end re-transmissions to recover
so
during this
1973 period
bob and i get the papers first paper
written and published in ieee
transactions on communications may of
1974.
and i think mostly nobody paid too much
attention to it
meanwhile arpa is funding us to go make
this actually work at stanford i am
working with my graduate students some
who are in xerox part summer
at stanford
on this detailed specifications of tcp
we published that in december of 1974
and it's the first time the word
internet shows up in print anywhere
because the first papers we talked about
internetworking
so internet shows up in a complete spec
in december 74 and it's also got bugs
but we don't know that yet
until we start implementing it in 1975
with two other organizations so bob khan
says can't have just one implementation
baltimore naked newman becomes one of
the implementers
university college london and peter
kerstein's group in england is the
second or third implementation so we
have three implementations of tcpip in
fact by this time it's only tcp we
haven't broken off the ip part
um three implementations are going we
instantly find problems with the design
and we start evolving
so over a period from 1973 to 1978 we go
through four iterations of the design
and implementation and test until we
have a fairly stable thing
and then we standardize and so 78 we fix
everything it's now by this time the
internet protocol has been split off
because people like david reed and danny
cohen are saying
we need to have
real-time communications that is not
necessarily reliable but which has low
latency so voice communications radar
tracks and all that you don't care where
the missile was two seconds ago you want
to know where is it now
so and in the case of voice if you lose
a packet you just say say that again i
missed something
so we split tcp into tcp and
ip and we create something called user
datagram protocol which is parallel to
tcp and it is the real time low latency
version of the reliable tcp
all of those little components iptcp and
udp now go into the internet
architecture starting in 1978 and we
start implementing for the next five
years we start we
do everything we can to get tcpip
implemented on every operating system we
can find it goes on to the ibm machines
it goes under the digital machines hp
goes into unix
we have a unix version built by bolt
bareneck and newman we send it out to
berkeley to the berkeley bsd release
guys and bill joyce's i don't like that
code he writes his own puts it into bsd
4.2 and that's the version of
unix that carries a lot of tcp to the
academic world because at the same sort
of time frame some microsystems comes
along and builds these fantastic
workstations and they want to use open
source or at least open protocols
and open operating systems so they adopt
unix and the tcp comes with it
and they use ethernet as a way of
connecting workstations together so they
are the engine that's driving the
academic community which are all game
busters for workstations and high-speed
local networking
so all of this of course places huge
demands on the arpanet
backbone which is only running at 50
kilobits a second and eventually leads
to the need for higher speed nsf jumps
into the fray seeing how valuable all
this is for the academic community and
concludes that it should build a network
that runs even faster and it does so
it's called nsf net
[Music]
the domain name system
it really doesn't have a great place to
fit in this architecture it is the thing
that converts user friendly names like
www.umish.edu to to uh like a
network-friendly address these network
numbers and ip addresses are important
because they are the they encode the
geography of the connections of the
internet but we humans really don't care
about the geography of the
interconnections of the internet
www.edu or
www.facebook.com is what we want to
remember
so i like to kind of think of the
the uh the domain name system is kind of
like sort of somewhere either between
the internet and the transport or
between the internet and the link or
somewhere like in this area you know
somewhere here and it's certainly not in
the application layer it's not the link
layer it uses the link layer
but basically
it's kind of a little add-on to the side
so the domain name system
is for user-friendly names okay so let's
talk a little bit about just how it
works because domain names are what we
use all the time and i p addresses are
what computers use all the time
and routers use routers really have no
knowledge of the domain names they
simply move data based on the ip
addresses numeric addresses are tough
for people to remember i remember in the
old days we would have little post-it
notes on our computers and that's how i
would keep track oh there's a new
minnesota just put up a server let's put
that number on my little post-it note so
the fact that they were numbers didn't
bother us at all because there was only
40 of them but quickly there was more
than 40.
and each campus even in the early days
only would have one network number but
now campuses have 20 or even 40 network
numbers
multiple groups of addresses they're
groups of addresses but they're many of
them
they get reorganized you move a server
from one place on campus to another like
the the michigan web server it was on
our north campus it would have one
address it was on our main campus would
have another address and so you don't
want people to know what these ip
addresses are
so they invented this notion of a domain
name system the name the the visible
name that we could switch the mapping
from the name to the ip address
transparently
and so the domain name system
is like the internet's address book
and it's a big distributed database
that's fast it uses caching so that it's
locally fast even if the network is
partially down
i p addresses reflect the technical
geography and they read right to left at
least to the point where the network
number is kind of the physical
attachment point for the campus or
business and then this part is the
attachment point within that campus or
business and so the most specific the
least specific to most specific goes
from left to right domain names on the
other hand are like organizational
structure the least specific is on the
far right and then it goes more specific
as we go left
so edu means educational institutions
umich.edu means the particular
educational institution university of
michigan
si.umich.edu means
a school of information at the
university of michigan not all schools
is just a particular one and then dub
dub dub is a particular server at that
school and it reads like a postal
address so if you think of
where i teach 2455 north quad it's kind
of on earth
and it's on the country usa and it's in
a zip code it's in the state of michigan
it's in ann arbor and then this is the
building and then this is the room
number in the building so we go from
very general
to very specific
so domain names read in a sense right to
left
phone numbers and ip addresses read left
to right
the other thing that's interesting about
domain names is that they're owned
they're owned from right to left and so
there are sort of there's a hierarchy
and basically an organization owns edu
the organization's name is educause
it has conferences and other things but
one of the things that it does is it
owns
in the public trust the name edu
so
university of michigan could go to edu
and say hey could i have umich.edu and
they would say
let me think about that and then maybe
they would give it
and they did because university of
michigan nobody else had it and it
seemed like a good name and university
of michigan was like accredited
institution of higher education so they
would give it to them if i wanted to say
like hey i'm dr chuck and i want to
create dr chuck
university i could have dr chuck.edu and
they would go like
no
you can't
you're not a university you're not
you're not an educational institution so
they might say yes they might say no
things
like.comand.org
they're kind of a catches catch can and
so the first one who gets there uh tends
to win there's
there's some situations where if
if i got coca-cola.com
and had no particular use for it and
coca-cola owned the trademark coca-cola
they could take it away from me unless i
had a legitimate purpose for it
it's harder for me to imagine a
legitimate purchase coca-cola but
target.com might be a club for target
shooting and it would be difficult for
target
to say sorry i gotta take your your your
target shooting club away
because that's even though it's not as
big as target's company it uh it's a
legitimate use
so
at each level once the university of
michigan is awarded the university of
michigan it creates a mechanism to award
sub domains within that
and so there is actually a committee at
the university of michigan and if we
want like our learning management system
is called ctools.umich.edu
if we want that we have to go to the
committee and convince them to give it
to us a top-level domain within the
university of michigan we got one the
school of information where i'm a
faculty member is si.umis.edu and they
gave us that one
i could go to that committee and i could
say hey i'm going to be
doctorchuck.umich.edu and they would say
no
you can't
so then the school of information where
i teach has si.umich.edu and they have a
committee and they can give out sub
domains within that so you get the
picture right so i could go there and
say hey
can i have doctorchuck.umich.edu
si.umich.edu doctortruck.site.iumish.edu
and they would say
no
but you can have csev.people.si.umis.edu
so once you own one of these things you
can give out subdomains i do own
doctorchuck.comchuck.com
[Music]
and if there was a high desire for
something underneath doctorchuck.com
then i could have my own little business
selling domains under doctorchuck.com
nobody seems to want any of those things
but you know some people have mail.com
and other things and so each one of
these is a new potential for expansion
and so that's kind of how the domain
name works right it is this mapping
between these names there is sort of
this
right to left ownership of these names
and uh and you have to ask people to get
those names and so that's a real quick
overview of the domain name system
[Music]
hello and welcome to the transport layer
we're working our way up from the bottom
of our four layer architecture up to the
top so we're kind of at the halfway
point we've covered the link layer like
ethernet and then we covered the
internet work layer which is kind of
like
the postcard layer so let's let's review
the magic of ip
right the magic ip is this postcard
layer that bounces these packets with
from addresses and two addresses
through
you know 15 or so hops
getting them there getting packets to
their destination network from one
network to another network as well as it
can and when it gets to the destination
network it finds the final computer on
that network
the magic of this is there is no
interim long-term storage inside the
network all the long-term storage is
outside and now we're going to talk
about that so one of the things that
makes ip so fast is that it is not
demanded to be perfect it is not
demanded to deliver data in order and
it's not demanded to it is there's no
requirement that it doesn't lose data
it's fast and barely ever loses data but
when it does there's a layer to recover
and that's we're going to talk about
next
so the internet protocol
is this
multi-hop
packets can take multiple paths they can
make use of all kinds of crazy links
but now we're going to move up one
right we're going to move up to the tcp
layer
so the tcp layer is both simple and
complex
the purpose of the tcp layer is to
compensate for
the possible errors in the ip layer as
well as make best use of available
resources
so if the network if the overall network
from
the overall network from here to here is
extremely fast we want to send data
really fast right if on the other hand
the overall network from here to here is
really slow
we want to send data slowly and be
efficient because remember part of the
goal of the tcp networking is to share
effectively and so we need to be aware
of whether our network is fast or slow
and those are the kind of problems we
solve the tcp layer how fast is the
underlying network how reliable is it
and if something goes wrong what do we
do to deal with that
so the key idea in tcp is that when we
send
some data we break it into packets and
then we send each one
and then we keep them
until
they get an acknowledgement from the
other side and then and only then do we
throw them away
and at some point if a packet gets lost
it can be sent again and again and again
until it finally is acknowledged in the
destination system and so that's
basically what tcp does is it figures
out which packets have or have not made
it across the internet layer
so here's an example scenario so we got
a message it's broken up into five
packets we've got sort of the first
hundred characters the the
you know first characters the second and
third packet now
what tcp does
is it speculatively sends a few packets
says okay let's let's get ahead because
if you sent one and waited then you
might not make best use the network so
you kind of guess and dump a few packets
out there
and so you said let's say we send three
packets cue them up for sending and as
fast as we can send them out the back of
our network we start spooling them out
the back of their network and somehow
two of them make it across the internet
to the destination but somehow
that poor second package just like every
time i'm doing a lecture the poor second
packet never gets it you don't want to
be the second packet in one of my
lectures because you're gonna get it but
somehow the second packet
has gotten vaporized
now time passes
and
the receiver gets this
this sensation that maybe maybe maybe
something's missing
and so it sends an acknowledgement back
and it says i'm going to send a note
back that says look
i'm ready for 200. i do have 100 and i'm
ready for for 200. matter of fact i
might even throw away 300 because it's
been so long
so i want you to start me over at 200.
but sender all of a sudden knows that
100 has been sent and so it knows that
it can throw this one away now right
it's been acknowledged so there's an
acknowledgement stream that goes back
and forth so now the sender
says 200 and 300 and then they make it
across
the receiver says i've got 200. this is
the 300 and then they send 400
speculatively
300 makes it 400 makes it and the
receiver says
i got 400 which means now it can cross
off 300 and 400 right check those off
and throw them away and then send 500
across and then at some point check
those off it's got 500 and now the
sender can sort of like empty check
everything off everything's been sent
and it's been acknowledged and we know
and so that's kind of an oversimplified
view of the kind of bookkeeping that's
going on on both sides of a tcp
connection
and so
this
right here is in a sense the genius of
the internet
the
storage requirements in the middle
the routers
this is the ip basically the the network
of networks
they we didn't design these to require a
lot of storage we wanted them to be fast
we wanted them to be agile we want to be
dynamic we wanted to be clever
but we also gave them right to fail so
we didn't demand storage we didn't say
hey to hold on to packets you know all
over the place just store up piles of
packets piles of packets would pile up
in these we don't ask that
no router has to keep the pack as a
matter of fact
routers are supposed to throw packets
away to communicate back and forth
between the system that maybe things
aren't working so well and don't use me
to get to california
this on the other hand with hundreds uh
maybe you know hundreds of thousands or
millions of routers but billions of
computers on the outside
so we need a way to make this reliable
so we need to have memory to store the
packets while they're in flight so we
can retransmit but we store the packets
in the computers that are outside and
there are billions of these computers
there are billions of them every
computer that you carry around every
laptop
yeah come here
every time we add another computer to
the network
we add storage for packets that are
being sent
so when your computer or our phone is
sending across the network
it is responsible
for retaining its own copies it does not
expect the inner part of the network to
do so
and that is
absolutely brilliant so the
it's what really makes this work
and so that's kind of a
a great oversimplification of what's
going on
and it turns out that there
is still a lot of engineering to make
that happen
so i'd like to introduce you to to
another
of the innovators in the that we meet in
this class uh his name is van jacobson
and i met up with him at xerox park uh
he did the work we're going to talk
about while he was at berkeley
and
in the late 1980s uh there was this
prediction that the internet was going
to die
and uh it seems obvious that it was a
it's a good idea now but back then there
was a bunch of folks that felt like
academics weren't smart enough to make a
network
and uh
and they were like ibm and digital
equipment that thought they the vendors
should make the network and we should
just pay them to use their network
and um as the nsf net was coming up
and more and more computers were being
connected and the background was
backbone was so slow it started to fail
and it looked like the predictions of
all of the computer vendors that said
academics couldn't build a robust
scalable network we're going to be true
and
so van jacons tells the story very
differently but the way i saw the story
happening and unfolding in 1987 is van
jacobson saved us
the network was crashing
and we all installed van jacobs and
patches and the network got better and
it in my recollection this was the last
time it appeared
that the entire internet was going to
crash
so we named it the van jacobson protocol
and he doesn't like to call it the van
jacobson protocol because he's a
shy and unassuming guy but i i
think he saved us
and so this interview is him describing
sort of that moment back in the late 80s
where
he invented the slow start algorithm
that really is part and parcel of every
tcp implementation that you have on
every computer that you use as a matter
of fact it's being used to to flow
control on this lecture right this
second as we speak so here's van
jacobson
[Music]
do
there were lots of campus ethernets
because they were really easy to deploy
and you could put them
in a department and
then you could run a wire between two
departments and you had a bigger network
and
so
we'd grown up networks sort of by
agglomeration
in lots of different university
campuses and
nsf came up with some money
said oh
we've got a little bit in our budget
where we could get some 56 kbit lines
and tie those campuses together
and
they did that made the nsf met phase one
but now you're tying together
10 megabit campus infrastructure with 56
kilobit wires
and
it was
wildly popular because people that
couldn't talk could suddenly talk and
they're
sending emails and moving huge files and
uh just everybody's really excited about
this technology but um
any one of those campuses could over
subscribe the net by
a factor of a thousand so
we had a lot of packets piling up and
getting dropped
at the time i was a researcher at
lawrence berkeley lab
which is in the hills up above the
berkeley campus
and i was also teaching
on the berkeley campus
even
back in those days which was mid 80s
we had a
for every class there was a
messages group you know like a little
news group that was set up all the
assignments would be put online
and i was trying to get course materials
from my office in lbl
down to a machine in uh evans hall at
berkeley and
uh
there was like zero throughput in the
net it was uh
one packet every ten minutes or so
and it seemed unbelievable would be
unbelievably bad and i
went down and talked to
mike carrolls who was heading the
bsd group the
people that develop berkeley unix and
he's getting reports of these problems
from
all over the country from
in those days the easiest way to start
running tcp was to bring up berkeley
unix because there was a
arka-funded very nice
implementation in it
and everybody was seeing
poor performance so
we talked for
a long time that day and on succeeding
days about well what's going wrong but
is
there some mistake in the protocol
implementation is there some mistake in
the protocol is
this thing was working on smaller scale
tests and then it suddenly fell apart
i think we struggled for
three or four months
just
going through
the code
writing tools to capture packet traces
and looking at the packet traces and
trying to
to sort out
what was breaking
and i remember
the two of us were sitting in mike's
office
after we've been pounding our head
against the wall for for literally
months
and one of us i can't remember which one
said you know
the reason i can't figure out why it's
breaking is i don't understand how it
ever worked
uh you know we're sending these bits out
at 10 megabits
they're zipping across campus they're
running into this
56 kilobit wire
we expect them to go through that wire
pop out on the other side go through
how could that function
that turned out to be the
the crucial starting point that
at that point
we started saying well
what is there about this protocol that
that makes it work how does it deal with
all of those bandwidth changes how does
it deal with the multiple hops
so
this picture that direction is time this
direction is bandwidth so that's a fat
pipe and that's a skinny pipe
and uh
the scale at the time is you know this
is a 10 megabit pipe and this is a 56
kilobit type so
here the difference is about three to
one it was really closer to 100 to one
and
so time
seconds times bits per second equals
bits
so
each of these little boxes in there
is
a packet it's the number of bits in a
packet
and
if you
scrunch it down in bandwidth it's got to
spread out in time because the number of
bits doesn't change
and so
uh
see the
burst of packets of windows worth of
packets gets launched it's going to fly
through the net until it hits this fast
to slow transition
and then because the packets have to
stretch out in time
they'll have to sit there and wait as
they're fed into the slower wire
and you
they pop out
the other side
they get spread out by this bottleneck
by the slower wire
once they're spread out they stay spread
out right there's nothing to push them
back together again
they hit a receiver it turns every
data packet into an ack
so you've got a bunch of acts that are
going back towards the sender and they
remember
what's the right spacing for that
bottleneck
uh so the axe get back
to
the sender and every act gets turned
into a data packet so we can see the
data packets flowing back
and
this is
after one round trip time
now the packets are coming out perfectly
spaced so they go by
uh
a new one goes into the net in exactly
the time it takes a packet to exit from
the bottleneck
so these acts are sort of acting as a
clock that
tells you
tells a sender when it's safe to inject
every new packet
and they're always going to be spaced by
whatever is the slowest point in the net
and the key thing is is how do you how
quick how can you get the steady state
sort of most quickly without wasting i
yeah and
the issue the failure we
saw was this works perfectly
after you've exchanged a round-trip time
worth of packets
but when you're starting up
when you're here
there's no clock
and so the hard part on tcp
is not getting it running it's getting
it started
because once you've got it running
you've got a clock tells you exactly
what to do
so if you
turn them on suddenly you get in this
repetitive failure mode
where you saturate the the buffering
that was available at some gateway and
then when you retransmit you do the same
thing again so you're always losing
packets
but if you
turned it on more gradually then you
wouldn't overload the buffering and
you'd get enough of a clock going so
that you
control the amount of
backlog to fit the available buffer but
you'd still be growing the number of
packets in flight so that you'd
eventually get a
you start with a kind of sporadic clock
but you'd eventually fill in the details
and get it for pack o'clock
how did you get it to the point where it
was in all the tcp implementations on
the planet because they kind of have to
cooperate in a way so remember it was a
much simpler time when you're talking
about
all the tcp implementations on the
planet
at that time there were like four
so there was the berkeley unix one
there's the mit pctcp there was a bbn
one that was used in butterflies and
imps
and there was a multix one i
took the
couple of tcp kernel modules that we've
been working on packaged them up in a
tar
i had this horrible driver hack that
would let us nerf packets from
the kernel and i mean it was really a
horrible driver hack it was
the way you said what you wanted to
snarf was by adb in the kernel you you
wrote
in binary some new values
these are the ports that i want to look
at and the driver would capture those
into a circular buffer and you'd read
kernel memory to pull that buffer out
craig larris and chris tork who were
working in
my group at
lbl and
we're both long-time colonel hackers
we're just
embarrassed at this and
they put together a really nice clean
driver
thing called bpf the berkeley packet
filter that
would let you pull packets out of the
kernel by a
a very efficient i o control interface
and
so we bundled all of that up and um
on
the tcpip mailing list which in those
days was
you know tcp was very experimental it
was very leading edge and
pretty much everybody who was playing
with it was on that mailing list to
announce that this stuff was available
a bunch of people ftp'd it
uh
tried it it blew up
sent kernel core dumps and bug reports
and
fixed the bug reports and put new
versions out and
somebody would immediately come back and
say panicked here do you want the
k core and i go oh no
embarrassed
put out a new version go out somebody
else would come back and say panicked
here
and
fixed that and just cycled like that and
after about a day we got a version that
didn't immediately panic and then
started working on the uh
the actual algorithms and
a little bit of tuning to make sure that
it
actually did
good all the time and didn't do any harm
just completely a community effort and
you know sort of when the
community was saying
this uh
mostly does good and never seems to do
harm
that's pretty what much what mike needed
to put it into the kernel so he took
that the community developed modules and
rolled them into the bsd release
[Music]
so basically the transport control
protocol has a responsibility of
compensating for the imperfections of
the ip layer data can arrive not out of
order it can arrive not at all and so
the tcp layer marks the data in a way
and stores the data in the source
computers until it is acknowledged by
the destination computers and so tcp
buffers this information and the buffers
are kept on the edge and this allows the
internet to grow in wonderful ways
so
this results in a layer
that really provides us what seems to be
an end-to-end connection
so we can send data in one end a stream
of data
just send it in just
roll it in
and
out comes a stream of data
it comes out in the same order it comes
out reliably
and we can stop thinking about it again
the whole goal of this layered
architecture
is so that
we can pretend that the complexity
inside this box
is simple
so it's not simple inside
but we the applications we're going to
make use of this transport layer can
pretend it's simple
okay and so we just i put in h
and an h comes out and i put in an e and
an e comes out and i put in an ll
and ll comes out an o comes out
and it's
hundreds of thousands of engineers and
billions of dollars of research that
makes it work
but
it just is simple it's been
oversimplified
so now we've talked about the link layer
the ip layer and the transport layer and
up next
we're going to talk about
what we do once we have reliable pipes
connecting one application to another
[Music]
so now we're going to talk about the
application layer
and up to now we've been talking about
these bottom layers and we've been sort
of working our way up we talked about
the link layer the ip layer and the tcp
layer and and and each of these layers
works with the other the
the ip
depends on the link layer the tcp layer
depends on and adds value to the ip
layer and now we're going to talk about
the application layer that is going to
make use of the services of the tcp
layer
and the services of the tcp layer are
basically to give us a reliable
sequenced end-to-end stream that can
start in one application in one computer
and end in an application in a different
computer and have a two-way
communication so i can send the word
hello
from one application
and then all kinds of
billions of dollars of hardware hundreds
of thousands of engineers 40 years of
engineering design and out comes hello
on the other end
and what's beautiful and this is the
beauty of the layer of the four layer
architecture is we just pretend this is
magic
this is magic
we send something and out it comes
with that magic available with that
billions of dollars and 40 years of
research magic available now what would
we do
right now what would we do with that
magic if we had it available to us
so tcp is giving us this reliable pipe
we're going to think about now we're
going to ignore all the rest of it right
we're going to ignore
all this part we're going to all we're
going to say is we have an application
on this into our computer now remember
this is your computer and say this is
the server right so this is you
and this is the server
and all the software runs in it in in
every all the software's running in your
computer and all the software is running
in the server
so the question is what are we going to
do between these two things okay what
how we what how are we going to ask for
data and this application is the client
application and this application is the
server application client and server are
not necessarily the same very much the
same
client server are likely very different
applications the client is like give me
information and the server is
responsible for giving
giving the information to the client so
client is often making a request and
then the server is making a response
back
and so
this client server mechanism this
application to application communication
we can build a mail system with it
worldwide web or we can stream videos
much like we'd be streaming this lecture
back and forth but we're going to focus
on the world wide web because it's
really simple and really elegant and
it's probably the easiest one to
understand and it's the most popular
but there are many other protocols going
on file transfer and others but the
world wide web protocol httpd
is the protocol that is the most popular
so
the there are two basic questions that
the application layer has to
uh solve one is
which application gets the data
and this is done using a mechanism
called ports
and ports allow a ip address or a single
computer or a single server to serve up
multiple services and then for a client
to be able to dial up much like a
telephone extension
and pick the service that they're
interested in once you've connected to
the service that you're interested in
like the world wide web service then you
have to know the protocol to talk to
that
ports in tcp are like a telephone
extension number again like i said they
you can connect to an ip address but
then you can connect to a port within it
and so if you think about a telephone
number and an extension it's sort of a
further refinement an ip address gives
us a particular server a piece of
hardware connected to the internet and
then a port within that tells us what
application we're going to talk to
so let's talk about ports and
connections
so if i have a server and this is kind
of a
arbitrary server here's here is a single
server www.mish.edu
and it has one ip address connected into
the cloud we can have many clients
talking to it
and we have many services running on
this server like
sending email or logging into that
server or retrieving web pages or
retrieving my mail from that server and
there are ports so incoming email is
done generally in port 25 remote login
is 22 or 23.
web servers depending on whether secure
or not or 80 or 443
and
the personal mailbox is on ports 109 or
110 and so these computers don't just
connect to an ip address but they
connect to a port within an ip address
so some common tcp ports that we have
are the ones i just mentioned and you
can take a look at these on the internet
the various ports okay
now
once we have a connection to the web
server or to the mail server or to the
post office server we have to know how
to talk to it and that's what's called
an application protocol and that is the
rules for conversation the rules for
conversing
so tcp gives us this reliable connection
we now can connect to the server that we
desire to connect to by using ports and
the question is what are we going to say
across that connection and what we say
across that connection who talks first
what do you send what comes back depends
on the kind of server that you're
talking to we're going to play mostly
with the world what the world wide web
click the wrong button there the world
wide web server because it's the
simplest and it's the most obvious as to
what's going on
so the world wide web clients and the
worldwide which are otherwise known as
browsers the world wide web clients and
the world wide web servers communicate
using a protocol called http as a matter
of fact if you look at the top of your
url it's http colon slash something
right and
and so basically
there is a specification for how this is
done so when they wrote down i'm going
to write the first web browser the first
web survey they also wrote a document
about how that piece of software would
talk to this other piece of software and
it's a very simple concept http has a
protocol where you make a connection to
the from the client to the server the
client requests the document the server
feeds out the document and then the
connection is dropped okay so it's very
simple we'll actually simulate this
this is called the http request response
cycle
okay and so the way it works is you're
in a browser
and you click on a link the browser is
an application it's the client running
on your computer so so this is kind of
your computer down here
okay
you click on a link
then the browser makes a connection to
the web server
and sends a request
to for the document the web server looks
up does whatever and sends the document
back and then the document is displayed
on your screen
okay
so let me show you sort of how this
works
with a web browser
so here is a canonical web page so
here's a browser here's the url that i
went and got you can get this url as
well you can even look at the source
so if you look at this source there is
my html but one of the things that's in
this source is a link
and if i hover over top of this link
it's going to look like that to hover
over top of the link you can see at the
bottom of my screen you can see it's
going to tell you that we're about to go
retrieve page 2.htm
now
this browser
is running on my laptop it is a web
client it is an http
client and i'm about to click
on this piece of software running on my
computer and then it is going to make a
connection out the back of it retrieve a
document and then show me the other
document so it's gonna happen real fast
i'll click on second page
it requested and got a document back and
showed me the document so that's the
contents of the second document okay
and so that is the request response
cycle
that is triggered
that is triggered by me making a click
somewhere in my browser
the the browser sees the click it opens
a connection this is sort of the
internet over here it makes a connection
request a document the document comes
back and then the new document is
displayed the request response cycle
click request response display click
request response display
so let's take a look in some more detail
as to what's really going on here
so the command that is being sent
up to the server
across this connection remember this
part here is the internet right there
the command is a get command and the
document is based on the url i clicked
on that the browser knows about and says
get
page2.html and then it comes back
is html
and that is a markup language that
describes how this doc this page is
supposed to be shown
so let's say that we wanted some more
detail on how this really worked
right let's say we want to write a web
browser and we want to be a good citizen
and we want to talk properly to
the uh
the web well we would go back to the
ietf the internet engineering task force
and we would go grab the document that
says hey if you want to write a browser
this is what you do
this is what you do if you want to write
a browser go grab rfc 1945
which is the hypertext transport
protocol version 1.0 now i'm sure
there's more complex superseded versions
of it
but if we read it and read it and read
it we spent a lot of time we get down to
section 5.1.2 and it would say if you
are making a request for a document this
is the request line
it has the letters g-e-t followed by a
space
followed by the url you're looking for
followed by a space followed by the
version
okay
so that is the rule that is what you're
supposed to send down this connection
i'm going to give us some more examples
on page 24 and so we could read all this
and we could write a web browser
but what we're going to do is we're
going to fake being a web browser we're
going to cheat we're going to hack it
we're going to pretend to be a web
browser we're going to send the commands
to the web browser
now i'm going to do this on a macintosh
you could also do it on windows if you
installed a telnet client
okay so the key is you install a telnet
client now most people would say telnet
is insecure and it is it's a very old
protocol because all it does is it opens
a tcp connection
to a host on a port that i specify and
whatever i type goes across that tcp
connection so it's a great way to hack
especially older less secure protocols
so because http is generally a public
protocol it's not really highly
protected so it's much simpler to hack
it hacking secure protocols is requires
writing software rather than typing
commands so if you're on windows you
have to install telnet t-e-l-n-e-t
so what i'm going to show you in a
second is i'm going to show you hacking
and i'm going to telnet to
www.doctortruck.com port 80. what i'm
saying is connect me to this server on
the internet
and connect me to port 80 because i want
to do http connections
and then i will send one command i'm
going to send that command and then the
web server will give me back the page
okay
it's probably easier for me to just
do it
so let's take a look
i am going to simulate
what the web browser does when it's
requesting
well actually we'll go to the second
page and when it's requesting the first
page it's doing a get
for page one okay
so that's what we're going to do except
now we're going to do it
in
a terminal so my type telnet
oops i always type this wrong
t-e-l-n-e-t
www.doctordashchuck.com
port 80.
okay
so now
i am connected to the web server on
doctorchuck.com
i could for example type
yo
what
is up
dude
now that would suggest i have not read
the protocol specification for the http
protocol so i do not know that i'm
supposed to type the word get here i'm
going to type yo what is up dude
and it goes
you are not from my country you are not
from my planet i do not know what you
said of course that the way web servers
are saying this is they're saying
bad request
your browser sent a request that this
server could not understand it is the
request header is missing a colon
separator you do not comply
go away
but we did talk
it just told us that
whatever we were saying is gibberish to
it and that's okay because we have read
the document and so we can
do it
so let's do it
so now i'm going to do a telnet to
doctorchuck.com on port 80. go to dr
chuck
hook onto port 80 so we can talk to the
web server
and now i am going to behave i've read
the specification i'm going to type
gt get space one space http colon slash
slash www.doctorchuck.com one dot htm
http space one
dot i think there's a slash there oops
oh no no no get it right did you write
slash one dot zero i think i got that
right
so that is what i'm supposed to type if
i am a real browser now i have to
actually type another new line
so i'll type another new line
and now
whoa
oh i gave it the wrong page look look
look look look i wanted to do i told it
to get page.htm so let's do it again do
it again
i'm not very good at this my browser is
much better at it so i type get http
colon slash www.drdashchuck.com
page1.htm
space http
slash 1.0
i believe that's it
let's hope i got it right this time and
then another enter and another enter
yay
i got it
so this time
i type you know i type this then i type
this
now it gave me some header information
it's saying things like
200 okay means i like you
uh what the time is when this file was
last modified it's an html file and it
actually shows me the html text
and so we have just
hacked
a web server
you can do this to like facebook.com and
do a get
if you get the right thing it'll give
you stuff you could go to various sites
you can fake browsers
now you're only going to get so far
because at some point these servers know
that you're not a browser because the
browser actually sends a little more
stuff than what we just sent
but you get the picture okay it's a
protocol where we have rules and if we
type the right thing
if we type the right thing we know what
the specification tells us to type we
are rewarded
with the information on that server if
we comply with the server's request
we can talk to it
if we know how to talk to we know a port
to talk to and we know what protocol to
talk to that port we can write a client
that meets the needs of that server and
extract the data
so this is i like i like command lines i
like sort of old school user interfaces
and this is a scene
from one of the matrix movies
that you may recall
i can't put it in here because of
copyright requirements i might have the
url or maybe students will come up with
the url you can probably search for the
trinity hacking scene people put it up
and then it gets taken down and someone
else puts it up
so let me tell you a little story about
this scene
this scene was actually written by a
former student of mine who worked on all
three matrix movies doing i t work on
the movies and they were in australia
shooting the the three the second
set of three movies and he saw this
scene and the scene was supposed to use
a minority report style way for her to
hack into the the power grid and shut it
down he said
that's not the way that you hack into
computers
all good hackers use a
text based interp interface some old
thing and that's a throwback interface
so the wachowski brothers told him
rewrite it
so we actually downloaded
the exact hacking software it's called
nmap which stands for network map it is
mapping the ports it's probes the ports
and sees what's on the ports see what
version of the software is on each of
the ports figures out what the what the
weaknesses of those things are and even
automatically exploits the weaknesses
so he wrote a script that downloaded
this thing that automatically breaks
into computers by the way the good guys
use this and the bad guys use this same
thing the good guys use it to test all
the computers on their campus and make
sure that they're okay
and the bad guys use to break into the
ones that the good guys aren't smart
enough to fix
and so
this was kind of cool and and the people
who wrote nmap were really quite amazed
when they saw the movie they even
figured out what version it was and
things like that and so it actually
triggered a series of uh follow-on
scenes that used actual real hacking
software uh nmap hacking software so
i don't know if we've got a url for this
or not whatever our url i come up with
um even the one the nmap people come up
with whatever it is it goes away because
of copyright but you can find it because
someone always puts it back up so okay
so
you can go and maybe the unmapped people
will know it or maybe you just have to
search for the trinity hacking scene so
you can use telnet and you can hack
legitimately hack a web server
so
basically the application layer is a
rich place and there's lots of things
that happen in the application layer we
have this pipe abstraction it's kind of
like a a string with two tin cans and we
can shout into one end and stuff comes
out the other end uh later we'll talk
about adding security to that
and we use these port numbers to allow
to multiple different servers or
services on a computer that we can
connect to
so we've kind of now reached the top of
the architecture of the internet we've
talked about ethernet the link layer and
the fiber and all the diverse wireless
all the wonderful things that happen
there the internet work layer which is
this kind of geographical hopping thing
that's unreliable the tcp layer that
retransmits automatically if necessary
and then the application layer which is
what we do with all this networks
it's really impressive that this came
out of research work from the 1970s and
that
most of the architectures that were
really present most the ideas the
architecture from the 70s are really
still present with us today
as the nsf net came out these
architectures evolved a little bit the
last few tweaks and there have been
tweaks going on ever since but the
really the last few critical tweaks
happened in the late 1980s
the uh
the number of web hosts
um or the number of hosts on the
internet goes from
six in 1969 to
sort of a billion in 2011 and and it's
pretty impressive that roughly the same
architecture that was designed with six
computers is still mostly functioning in
in mostly the same patterns
all these years later with the built
billions of computers
and so if you start looking at the
network now it almost looks like a live
creature with veins and
nerves and
and it sort of almost pulses
and you see things like you can search
on the internet for
how the internet reacted to hurricane
sandy when like new york city was just
like shut off for three days the
internet just kind of like
routed around it
yeah a lot of stuff went across the
atlantic ocean from new york city and
yeah i found different paths and you
know yeah new york was down but the rest
of it wasn't um
in many ways pretty amazing and
we certainly see other situations where
governments try to shut the internet
down by going into the server rooms and
shutting off you know what they think is
the only connections but then more
connections pop up and so it's it's very
much a uh almost a living thing
it's billions of computers and hundreds
of thousands of routers and and it's
hundreds of millions of simultaneous
connections going on all the time
including the one we're doing right now
probably
and
it's trillions of bytes of data moving
across
and it's
it's it's not perfect it but it kind of
works
you can think of it as like the largest
energy collective engineering thing that
we've done together is humanity we built
this
it's all one thing and yet it's so many
different pieces and we just kind of
keep
gluing them together and gluing more
things on more things and it was it
really was created almost like life
itself it's very organic it's designed
to heal itself
rather than be perfect because things
that try to be perfect are fragile and
they break too easily but things that
are designed to heal
can heal and you're never perfectly
correct you're never all the way up and
you're never all the way down and so
that's what's interesting
about the internet
oops went the wrong way
and so we kind of come to the end of
this where we started out with like
machines and pulleys and gears and
spraying oil at bletchley park and
typing a few characters on a keyboard to
this thing where we sort of just take
for granted that we can watch basketball
anywhere on the planet just with a
couple of swipes of the of the key and
and in a sense it's just that same human
urge to communicate at a distance
and so the last thing that i'll close
with is another video from van jacobson
now this is about a technique he calls
content-centric networking
and not everybody agrees with van
jacobson on this you can ask people and
they'll say it's a good idea
that i don't present this as the future
i present this more to get you thinking
that there is a future that might be
different than the present that what i
just told you
that seems
seems like oh it's perfect and the and
when and vince surf in 1969 he figured
this out and yeah it was the perfect
thing right and
the answer is it might not be and we as
engineers and we as the people of the
internet we must understand that in 20
years it might be all different because
20 years ago it was all different and 30
years before that it was different yet
again and so nothing's perfect and so we
should never be complacent and assume
that what we have is trivial or perfect
or even the right answer so we should
continue to question and so it's really
interesting to hear again from van
jacobson who sort of did this great
innovation in 1987 saved us and yet he
thinks
that these are issues and they're issues
that need to be saved again
and i think in many ways he's right the
question is not so much whether he's
right or wrong the question is what will
the ultimate solution that we pick uh be
produced so
so take a look at van jacobson and what
he can what he is thinking about as
terms of the issues in the future that
we're going to need to solve
when he talks about content-centered
networking
[Music]
hello and welcome to our security
lecture i'm charles severance
and i encourage you to
grab the power points and remix them and
use them in your own courses use the
videos use everything in your own
courses i i you don't have to teach this
whole course it's quite a bit
so um
so let's start out by meeting some nice
people these uh people
are alice and bob
and they simply want to communicate some
information you know
left to their own devices and they don't
want the rest of the world to know about
what they're communicating and so they
want to encrypt it some way now uh in
the cryptograph cryptography world
um they all all call these two people
the good people uh alice and bob and
they simply are a and b
kind of a very computer-esque variable
names a and b and alice and bob and then
there's some bad guys
right there's the bad guys
and uh and often they are called c
like carol or carlos or charlie or or
something like that they're even chuck
even chuck is a bad guy or dave or eve
eve for the eavesdropper and the idea is
somewhere in the middle here
somewhere in the middle you have some
person with bad intent here we have
trinity from the matrix and she looks as
she looks as bad as you can look right
um so alice and bob seem to be real
happy people they're just trying to get
you know get things done and
send some information without being
bothered and then and the trinity's
there eavesdropping and but there's
other things you can eavesdrop you can
sort of redirect the message and change
it there's all kinds of things that the
bad guy in the middle is going to do
and so alice and bob
are far away from each other and they
have to communicate securely and they
it's a it's a it's a literal gauntlet of
problems that they have to face and
various people with bad intent with bad
purposes sometimes
just wanting to see what's going on
versus wanting to change what's going on
versus completely redirect communication
so alice bob and then a whole series of
bad guys with various
bad guys and gals with various evil
intent
[Music]
you know i think computer security is
the most exciting part of computing
right now because it has something that
nothing else has it has an adversary
relationship when you do graphics or
operating systems or anything there's no
one trying to thwart you at every turn
unless you have in security that's what
makes it exciting and interesting and
that's what makes it something that's
forever changing and involves psychology
and economics and computing and
law and policy and so many things so i
think it's a great uh area to be in to
work in i think it's not going away
right as long as we have adversaries as
long as we have human beings and and
their due wells and evil doers we're
gonna need security
so
it's always going to be like that
you know preparing is interesting in a
lot of ways
security is a mindset
it's a way of thinking about the world
and if you think about the original
definition of a hacker
someone who sort of cobbles stuff
together you hacked this tool and it
works and you put this piece together
and this here and that and it all works
and it's a great hack
but i'm a security guy i'm going to say
well turn this like that doesn't work
anymore and you'll say well don't do
that and i'll say no no i'm the attacker
i get to do that i get to do that
whenever i want i get you at the most
inopportune time get to do that in a way
that makes your system fail as badly as
possible
and you have to think that way
not about how to build something how to
make it work but how to make it fail
and how to make it fail in precisely the
right way to do precisely the right sort
of damage
and that's a way of thinking
i mean there are some people who go
through their lives looking at systems
and figuring out oh i can break that oh
here's how to break that you walk into a
store and you see the purchasing system
oh i can steal something here's how
you walk into a voting booth oh i can
sort of
defeat this here's how you might not do
it because of course that would be
illegal but you think that way
and that mindset i think is essential
for security once you have that mindset
then it's a matter of just learning the
domain
right learning the systems and whether
it's a self-driving car or a voting
system or a medical device and it's
going to be embedded code interacting
with the real world in a way that
involves people and society
and i can teach all that you can learn
all that so i remember a class in
security i forget who did this
one of the assignments was come in
tomorrow
and write down the first thousand digits
of pi
okay so two things about this test one
you can't memorize a thousand digits to
pi you have to cheat and actually the
students were expected to cheat
but if they were court cheating they
would fail
okay that's interesting right that
teaches
that mindset
allows you to think outside the box but
how am i going to do this
am i going and there are lots of ways
people cheated and and i sort of urge
people watching to go
google this
and to look at some of the stuff written
it's a great way of
trying to stimulate the mindset
can you teach it formally i don't know
it's kind of like it's a way of thinking
and i think the more security classes
you take the more you exercise that
mindset a lot of the hacker conferences
will have capture the flag
contests i remember an early one where
they had to build their own private
network to cut down on both network
license latency and federal
violations right
that's why you do it but you're going to
learn a lot
by breaking other people's systems and
yeah that's probably going to involve
illegal activity and
agreed you know this isn't the best way
or maybe it is the best way it's not the
most socially acceptable way you know
but here we have this clash between the
tech imperative
and what society wants so many of our
systems are black boxes
i mean you can go and try to hack this
right your your smartphone or your
computer
and there's a lot of stuff you can learn
but really it's gonna be more fun if you
can hack
somebody else's cell phone or somebody
else's computer i want it to be
open-ended i want it to be you know
follow whatever it is you're interested
in the neat thing about security is it
can go wherever you want there are so
many different
sub-disciplines i'm often asked should i
study
forensics or cryptography or network
security or protocols
or embedded devices
or scada systems study what you want
and whatever interests you follow that
because really what you're learning
is how to think
like a security expert and honestly if
you get a job they make you do vpns you
can pick up vpns that's easy and it's
the way to think so do what you want
and you know what we're learning right
now is that demand is greatly
outstripping supply
right that people who have expertise in
security have a guaranteed career
because there is such a demand for it
and there's such a lack of supply have
you written any of your books kind of in
aimed at
those kind of you know pre-computer
science students or early computer
science students that would sort of be a
good read i tend to write my books for
general audience
so i think of my parents my friends
so computer experts yes but really for a
more general audience
so going back to something like secrets
and lies i wrote in 2000 it's about how
network security works right 15 years
out of date but it's still a good
introduction on the basic concepts of
how to think about
security
you know later cryptography engineering
how to engineer cryptosystems
my book liars and outliers how to think
about security as a way to enable trust
very non-technical but very much here's
how security is embedded in society
my latest book is about surveillance and
data in goliath talks about
what's going on in the world of
surveillance and how we can regain
security so to me all of these books are
for someone who might be interested in
this field because what they're going to
do is spark interest in different
directions they're going to
give people
ideas they're going to go and research
further and that's how you get
your passion that's how you get your
calling you know it's not that someone
gives it to you that you notice it going
by and saying hey that's kind of neat i
want to do more there
[Music]
so it's always fun to talk about
security because you know the question
is is you and what does security mean to
you and what does it mean to me
and um
and and when you're whenever you're
thinking about security you got to
figure out sort of who is out to get you
and
why are they out to get you
and for us average people
we are so boring that literally pretty
much the only thing the world wants from
us is they want to steal our
you know they want to steal our credit
card numbers and and then buy stuff with
them for just a couple of days before
the credit card company shuts them down
now if you're running for public office
uh there's a whole bunch of your
opponents that are going to want to
break into your email and
and that happens right those kind of
shenanigans happen so if you're
interesting or influential or running
for public office you have a different
problem than if you're just kind of a
mere civilian like us
and so
at the end of the day
you can worry about security and you can
kind of wear tin foil clothing or
something but at the end of the day you
and i are so boring that nobody really
cares
but
it's good to assume that they're out to
get you right that that you try to be as
secure as you can and be aware of your
environment and be as secure as you
possibly can with your information
and uh with your communications
so who is out to get us well
the government so now we're going to
actually turn the tables right in the
very first lecture we were the good guys
the good guys were the ones who were
trying to break the curtail free and the
bad guys are the ones that are trying to
hide their their their bad messages and
the government were the good guys in
bletchley park and they they broke the
codes and they they saved western
civilization yay good guys well now
we're the germans
we're the japanese
we're trying to communicate
people are watching
and guess what it's the same people the
government government's most likely
interested in what you're doing um again
most of us are so boring the government
doesn't really care at all but the
government has probably the best
security breaking equipment on the
planet right now better than the
criminals and so it's just an
interesting flip of the model right
where now we are trying to communicate
and the government with all of their
bombas and little rotating devices
sitting in some
warehouse somewhere that we don't know
is taking our private communications and
they're trying to break them
and we are
in a war trying to make our
communications more and more secure
while the government says well we have
to invent like electronic computers
because we have to have bigger computers
because the people that us us good guys
now who are doing the encrypting we are
trying to come up with more and more
clever ways to encrypt and the
government has to keep coming up with
ways to decrypt and you could
cast this as
criminals versus good folks you could
cast these governments versus
governments at the end of the day it's
an arms race
and it's it's rather symmetric as to
which side you're on right i mean we
started out with
the people trying to hide the
information were the bad guys and now
we're the good guys why are we the good
guys because it's us as soon as we
decide it's us
we're the good guys
here's a little here's a little picture
i took
a couple of years ago when i visited uh
bletchley park
this actually led to the video
a year and a half later
and in this
my friend who works at the open
university who also does massively open
online courses uh that's joel he's now
retired he's the tour guide there and
a dear and personal friend and um and
another of my dear and personal friends
whose face you can't see
is right here his name is chuck he
currently works at shazam in london and
um and he and i just got away for the
weekend and went up to bletchley park
and took a tour not just just a little
interesting connection i sort of
mentioned in a previous lecture about
the matrix so you notice that chuck here
is wearing a jacket from the movie
matrix i mentioned he was the one that
wrote the hacking scene
with trinity
so here we all are together we're at
bletchley park alan turing had an office
in this this is one of alan turing's
offices at bletchley park here's joel
open open teaching and learning here is
chuck worked on the matrix and here's
trinity
right
except that now trinity's our enemy
instead of our friend although in the
movie we're rooting for trinity but
we're the ones trying to protect
what we're doing from the trinities of
the world we're the good guys now and
trinity is the bad gal okay she's the
bad lady trying to break into our stuff
and we're protecting ourselves against
trinity so tables have completely turned
okay
so
before we go too far you know you'll run
into your organizations with lots of
people who are like security experts and
i find security experts
generally very
annoying
because they like think they're smarter
than they are
security experts have this theory that
more security is better and the reality
is is that perfect security is
unachievable if you want perfect
security
like
lock yourself in a room and whisper to
somebody oh wait a sec and then the
guard will come in and hear you or
whatever there'll be a microphone
so the notion that perfect security and
that you your company can spend more and
more and more money of its budget on
security just because the security
expert thinks that you should
is really kind of a fallacy
security is a cost benefit analysis and
so if you think of credit card companies
you know what's the security of this
number
i won't show you the number but what if
i lose this number what's the
consequences i've had many credit cards
that got compromised i don't exactly
know how
they've got software inside of computer
companies that catches like when all of
a sudden i live in michigan and a bunch
of charges at the new jersey walmart are
showing up and i never got on a plane
i'm amazed at how rare it is that your
identity actually gets lost permanently
so i'm really impressed with how the
banks are capable
and so they have this number that makes
it real convenient for us to buy we can
type it into a web form we can do all
these things
and one in a zillion times it gets
compromised and so they lose 50 bucks
but billions of dollars of commerce
happen so there is always a security
versus cost if basically for me to use
this credit card i had to have sort of a
a personal uh guard from the
the company with me all the time it'd be
very expensive for me to buy stuff on
amazon and have it shipped to my house
and so
understand that when you start getting
into conversations with security
professionals
sometimes they're the kind that
understand that security is naturally
imperfect and everything is a
cost-benefit analysis rather than more
security is always better so more is not
always better that's just my little
speech about security in case you get
stuck in a conversation with some
pompous security expert they're mostly
pompous
so
database administrators are pompous too
but hope you're not not you're not a
database administrator security expert
but um
the best security experts that i've ever
met are the ones that understand this
and they can they can they can
characterize every issue in terms of a
cost benefit analysis and then you know
you know that you've run into one that's
really smart and bright
so the terminology that we're going to
use for the rest of uh segments of this
lecture
we're going to be solving two basic
problems
one is confidential confidentiality and
the confidentiality is the
the the leakage of information so
if i was to want to send
this credit card number to one of you
watching right now without the rest of
you seeing my credit card number
the the mere revealing of that
information is the problem
so i want to come up with a way to send
it to you
so that no one except the one person
that i want to see it gets it that's
confidentiality
the other problem is one of integrity
and that is
in a sense knowing that a
that the information that you've got
comes from who you thought it came from
and b that it wasn't modified on the way
so there are things like digital
signatures that sort of fall into this
category
and uh other mechanisms that we'll talk
about so these these two themes of
confidentiality and integrity will run
through the rest of the lectures that we
have on security okay
so coming up next we're just we're going
to start diving right in
[Music]
so the first topic that we're going to
talk about is confidentiality encryption
and decryption and of course this was
what was going on at bletchley park in
world war ii so
uh
the terminology that we'll use in this
is plain text and ciphertext and the
idea is
whether it's text or other information
there is the information that we
actually want to transmit whether it's a
credit card number or something else and
then there is the
encrypted version of that and we'll call
that the ciphertext and the ciphertext
is what we assume
is revealed to intermediate parties
whether they are stopping it and
changing it or they're just watching it
it's still the cipher text is the stuff
that we are um
just by the nature of the communication
we are forced to reveal it or there is a
probability that we'll reveal it so it
is hopefully unintelligible and
hopefully it is difficult to go from the
cipher text to the plain text except if
you are the actual intended recipient
or impossible
encryption is the act of going from
plain text to ciphertext and returning
the ciphertext back to the plain text as
decryption and there is a key some kind
of a key which is really sort of a some
data plus a technique
plus an algorithm that goes back and
forth
so there are two kinds of systems that
we'll talk about in the upcoming
lectures
one is called a
secret key and the other is called a
public key
the secret key is the one we talked
about at the very beginning the secret
key was really used from
uh the romans and caesar on up to world
war ii
uh the public key encryption really is
uh much more recent in the 60s and the
70s and we'll talk about that
later on so the first thing we'll talk
about is the shared secret or secret key
the secret key is also called symmetric
key which means that uh both parties
have to be in possession of the same
information you basically use the same
key material to encrypt as you do to
decrypt the um the public key is
asymmetric which means you use it one
key to encrypt in a different key to
decrypt we'll get to that later
and so the problem that secret key has
that led to the need to invent uh
public key is the fact that you need to
at some point have a secure
communication whether you're sitting in
room together and you hand each other
code books whatever it is you have to
have a way to distribute the key in a
secure manner
the public key which we'll get to later
has a way of distributing the key in
using insecure medium and you'll see
when you're when we get there it's like
so obvious and clever you wonder why
nobody thought of it
until you know
very recently
so
here is the path right you have some
plain text
you uh you have say the word candy that
you want to send you're going to encrypt
with a shift where you you just go to
the next later letter so c becomes d a
becomes b and becomes o and so now we
have the
d b o z that is the plain text coming
from alice alice sends it in the
dangerous dangerous nasty wide world of
you know routers or
radio with uh
with morse code or whatever it is we're
going to do
whatever is we're going to do
where the message might be intercepted
by somebody now they're not intercepting
the plain text we assume that this part
here is secure and this part here is
secure it's only dangerous while it's in
flight somehow in the middle and we only
worry about eve getting it
and
and then at some point because
uh bob has the key which is subtract one
bob goes from each of the cyber text
letters back to the plain text letters
and voila
out comes
the plain text again and so
eve's problem is i'm only eve is only
handed
well no sorry he is not eve is not given
the key
he is given the cipher text and nothing
else and she must
like bletchley park must derive whatever
it is drive the key derive the plain
text whatever it is that's eve's goal
the caesar cipher
is the kind of the oldest most widely
used forms of encryption
it uses the notion of a shift
the shift number is just as i shown a
shift of one means a becomes b and
x becomes y and
l becomes
l m l l becomes m so
you just take and move a fixed position
down l this was used for a surprisingly
long period of time and there's some
pretty good youtube videos that kind of
you can if you want to see more about
sort of the the how this works and the
math behind it and how you break it it's
uh it's pretty fascinating i mean
finally it's just it's completely
breakable um and we'll actually going to
break it here pretty soon
ourselves so the caesar cipher
so i want to pause and let you see uh
youtube video uh here from
uh
beloved movie uh called the christmas
story where little ralphie gets his uh
little orphanage secret decoder ring
and uh little orphan annie sends a
decoded message an encoded
ciphertext through the radio everyone
can hear it but only those people who
have the secret decoder ring can decrypt
the message and you can see that it is a
a caesar cipher it has a shift you'll
note that
the first thing they say before they say
the encrypted message in the radio is
that uh you're supposed to connect b and
13 or something like that and then you
rotate the two wheels of the secret
decoder ring to the b13 and then you can
read across the secret decoder ring and
decrypt the message as it's decrypted
and then he slowly decrypts it and then
of course there is the
delightful moment where he realizes the
crash crass commercialism uh that
that
or the complete lack of interesting
meaning in in all of this so uh without
further ado let's take a look at uh
ralphie and uh christmas story be right
back
so i hope you like that i hope you like
that um
and so uh off we go um we're going to
have a secret decoder ring for this
class i would love to be able to send
you all um
oops come down i would love to be able
to send you all a little mechanical
wheel to move the stuff back and forth
but instead i use the internet and i'm
going to send you a a pdf and at this
point you might want to pause the video
and grab this pdf okay
grab it
secretdecoder.pdf
doctortruck.com secret decoder.pdf and
download it and you might even want to
print it out because we're going to at
this moment
uh
do a code breaking exercise
okay
and so let me tell you how to use this
secret decoder ring
so the top line here is the plain text
and if you recall uh cesar shift has a a
a shift number
and um so to encode you go from a plain
text let's say i want to do uh
chuck i want to encode chuck
and i want to encode it with a shift of
2.
so shift to 2 means we select this
and we basically go
c
is our plain text
and then down we go e
so then we go e is our first letter and
then h
is our second letter
so we go down
and that means h becomes j
yeah and so u
becomes w
so now i'm doing my encryption so e h w
is
the encrypted
ciphertext so let me clear that
and write back down here
different color
e
h w now to decrypt remember you need to
know the shift so we somehow
communicated separately and securely
what the shift was
and so now we want we have received our
ciphertext
we received our ciphertext and we need
to decrypt it okay
and so we know that the shift is two so
we go to e we go in the shift row
and then we go up to the plain text row
and that says the first one is c
then we go to h
we go to the
encoded text row and we go back up to
the plain text row and so that's an h
oh wait wait wait
it's not h w what am i thinking this
should have been a j
i got this wrong sorry about that
so that's wrong here's a j moves up to
the h
then the w let's see if i got w right
yeah so w is my last ciphertext and it
goes up to the u
okay
dot dot dot so you see the pattern that
are in encoding is plain text
down to shift position and our decoding
is
shift position back up to plain text
okay so this is our secret decoder ring
so go grab it and download it so that
you can participate in the next exercise
so now you are going to be cast in the
role
of
bletchley park
okay ready so here is your first code
breaking exercise
okay
so here we go
so you're bletchly parked right you just
intercepted
this ciphertext u
b
u p b t u
whoa it's encrypted it's clearly
meaningless
so how are you going to decrypt it well
the technique is
take a look and decrypt it with all the
all the shift numbers right you're going
to do this by hand you're going to be a
computer yourself you're going to do all
the shifty cripping
and just like in bletchley park you know
you succeeded when the plaintext makes
sense
right when the plaintext makes no sense
then you haven't succeeded but at some
point the plain text makes sense
so what you need to do is take your
secret decoder ring and you need to
decrypt it with a shift of one a shift
to two a shift to three a shift to four
and if you have your family members
around you can print out multiple copies
of the secret decoder ring and you can
assign different shifts to different
family members so you have to decrypt
this 26 times
have to decrypt it 26 times and then you
look at all the 26 decryptions and then
you decide which one makes the most
sense
okay
so don't peek
decrypt this one
i made it easy on you okay
so we'll stop now and give you a little
bit of time to decrypt this one
don't start pause until you actually
have decrypted it okay
okay this is your last chance for
spoiler alert
so here we are we're about to decrypt it
here we go
i did make it easy on you it was a shift
of one
it was a shift of one
if you started at 12 you're kind of
foolish right so you started at one and
you go like oh great so now i'm gonna
decrypt it i'll start at one
here's the plain text this should be p p
that's the plain text so i'll start with
u
if it's one
then i go up and it's t
and the second one is p
so i go up and it's o t o keep going it
says toast
so you say to yourself well that's a
word so it must be it
well hello
what are you doing here
you want to say hi to my students
this is a cat
this is my eddie cat
he likes to come up into my office
and look
so do you know anything about encryption
anything about encryption so you use a
shift of one
and then you go from the christian text
up to the plain text
wow
okay
you are clearly not interested
in my lecture so that was my cat
hello
sorry can't open the window for you
because i'm doing a lecture
okay
um
so
you're going to like just keep
bugging that window until i kick you out
of my other room all right aren't you so
you're going to get kicked out
out you go
he was gonna keep hitting that
i'm gonna keep hitting that until uh i
opened it for him
okay
so
so now you've broken this code and again
just like in bletchley park you only
knew that you broke it if it made sense
and um
and so luckily the in blessedly parked
the messages were longer and they were
often looking for
uh canonical things that they would say
every day
so um here we go
and uh
and so that's the
breaking of
that one
and it turns out that shift of one was
the thing that we did
so here is
your second task
this one's longer and it's not a shift
to one
and so
so this is a situation where you really
would have to get your whole family
going on this right where you got to do
26 decryptions of this
and it will you know make sense to you
you decrypt it 26 times right
and so this one's going to be harder
i guess you could just just decrypt one
word but it's just not a shift of one
but now we're going to do another trick
okay
so i don't want you to try all 26
because there's there's a mistake in
this there is a
leakage of information that makes it so
that you can figure out what the right
decryption to try might be
so this is english
this is an english sentence
so stare at for a while and find a more
optimal way to decrypt it than trying
all 26 shift patterns okay
so there's a way to optimize this a way
to cleverly figure out
what might be the best shift or
how not to have to decrypt the entire
message 26 times to reduce the
complexity
and that's because we've leaked some
information here that should be pretty
obvious to you
okay so let me give you a moment to
break this one it shouldn't take you too
long and you shouldn't have to force
your whole family to decrypt this stuff
okay
so here we go give you a chance to
decrypt it
okay
here's your last chance before the
reveal you ready
here we go
so here is
the decrypted text
the shift turns out to be
13. it's a shift to 13.
and the the weakness of this whole thing
is this right here in the english
language
what is a single character we're not
encrypting the spaces you'll notice
because the spaces come across
so what is the one single character
word
that we have in the english language
that's
capitalized
well that's usually i
i need a jet money and a jet what is the
one
thing
that we do in the english language that
is a single character word
that is all lowercase that's lowercase
typically unless at the beginning of the
sentence and that is the letter a
so basically you didn't have to decrypt
the whole message you see some weird
pattern and you go like this
i just have to figure out
and then you go look
and you look in the row 13 the plain
text
and you go like oh
where does you go look at the eye
because you guessed to the plain text
and then you just look down until you
see the v and within seconds
literally within seconds if you do it
right within seconds you know it's a
shift to 13 and then it's a trivial
matter
to convert it
so you could figure out the shift code
within seconds and these this was how
bletchley park figured it out and this
is why the
known plain text was so important
because you'd only have to figure out
like one letter if you knew what the
plain text was and often they would know
by length
and certain other things oh this is i i
think we can guess what this plain text
was that this particular operator would
send and this has to do with the leakage
of information it's not the it's not the
mathematical perfection or lack of
perfection in the security key it's some
other leak some other thing where
they're going like oh wait a sec i can
take advantage
of something it was just equally
encrypted as any other message but
because i gave you this clue of an
uppercase single character word and a
lowercase single character word
upper lowercase single character word
and uppercase single character word i
greatly reduced the amount of effort
that you had to put in okay
now what's cool about this
you go to this website www.com
is that long ago before facebook and
before twitter and before all these
things we had these things called news
groups
and they were kind of this weird kind of
uh collective email list that we had and
this was like in the 80s
and it was even used in store and
forward networks where it was kind of
like facebook and store and forward
networks meaning that it might take
four hours for you to see the status
update but we kind of would subscribe to
these collective things
and there was one that was basically the
dirty jokes
and the thing about dirty jokes was part
of the part of what we were trying to do
in this thing was you weren't supposed
to swear and there was software that
would filter out swear words
um
from if you put a swear word in to a
dirty joke
um
it would it would not forward the
message and so we had to have a way to
encrypt
messages that included swear words
so that we could tell dirty jokes to
each other for those who wanted to
subscribe to the dirty joke list
and so they came up with this wrote 13.
so we came up with a simple caesar
cipher with a shift of 13. 13
beautifully of course is 26 divided by
2.
so it's a symmetric shift the shifting
in by 13 is the same as shifting out so
of all the sievers caesar ciphers a
shift of 13
the encryption and the decryption are
exactly the same calculation
and so we would um
we would
type our dirty joke into row 13 and
convert it to row 13 and we would send
it in row 13 and then we would if we
wanted to decrypt it but what became
funny after a while was we were so used
to
reading wrote 13 that it almost became
like a second language right we could we
could read second we could start reading
the dirty jokes in row 13 and we would
laugh before we translated them up so
wrote 13 has an interesting sort of uh
historical thing and you go to row 13
and sort of like encrypt whatever you
want to say and and i'll probably have
some questions to ask you where you will
have to
do some rope 13 encryption
and so that's the end of this lecture
where we talk about uh caesar ciphers
and the various techniques and how
caesar ciphers work and so
uh we'll be back and talk about
cryptographic hashes
so now we just finished talking about uh
basic confidentiality using simple
caesar cipher and we'll get better
before we'll we'll be more sophisticated
than that because caesar ciphers are
trivially breakable obviously but now
we're going to switch from
confidentiality to integrity and we're
worried about uh the the message uh just
to review the confidentiality means
we're hiding information we just don't
want eve to see it because eve sees the
cipher text and we want her to never be
able to extract the plain text and as we
saw in the last lecture uh you
if i'm just using a caesar cipher i mean
there was little or nothing i could do
to stop you from doing it all you'd do
is enough work and you would figure out
the shift and then you'd have everything
so it would take you you know you'd
write a program it would take you like a
thousandth of a second to check all
possible things and you're done
so that's confidentiality now we're
going to talk about integrity right
and we're going to kind of assume
confidentiality or perhaps assume it's
not necessary because we're transporting
it in a locked box or in a you know
whatever but let's just say i had some
um
some some piece of paper right
and and and you wanted to know if this
piece of paper really came from me well
we would use
uh things like a signature
right or we would use uh
a bit of wax where we would push the uh
our seal on it and the seal only
belonged to us
but but really did signatures can be
forged uh
you know people can steal the wax
imprint thing
i mean in roman times they would wear it
around their neck to make sure that no
one stole it but you could also just
create a fake one
so you could seal your letter with the
wax but
and you break the wax seal
but in the computer world we need
something right we need a situation
where
um
where perhaps i mean my wife had to get
a prescription
and they sent her an email with a
prescription in it and this prescription
had on the end of it a digital signature
it was just a bunch of numbers and you
think to yourself
wow you know here's this prescription
and at the end it just has a bunch of
numbers and that's the digital signature
from the doctor and how does that work
well
it it works surprisingly well and and
that message can be forwarded she can
print it out she can scan it she can
send it to a
pharmacist via email and as long as that
signature's in there we can know that
the data originally came from the doctor
and that that you didn't know and
modified it to be a different kind of
prescription like a different amount or
a different drug
and and then that would invalidate the
signature and how exactly is that done
well
it's done using a technique called
cryptographic hashing and it is a bit of
computer software a bit of code that
takes a large amount of text
and reduces it down to
some small set of numbers a large block
of data to a fixed length
set of numbers
in and the message is the big thing and
the digest is the little thing it sort
of it's like it digests it and sort of
gives you this little tiny thing now the
key is there are many different
techniques to to map from a message to
the hash or the digest
and some are better than others and it
turns out that there is a
long-term whole field of mathematics and
computer science that's dedicated to
understanding
what a good cryptographic hash might be
and so there there are these well-known
cryptographic hashes that you may have
heard of like sha-1 or md5
each of those as the result of
many many years of research of thinking
through
what a good cryptographic hash is so for
example one cryptographic hash might be
i sign it with the number of characters
in the message that would be something
that says like well at least they didn't
expand or contract the number of
characters in the message but then at
some point that would be such an obvious
thing that you would change the
signature as well
so you want to make it so you can't
change the message and change the
signature because then you're sort of
properly forging a signature so the hash
function that takes the message to
create the digest that's something that
is a scientific mathematical research
effort to get the thing right okay
so here is an example of a hash function
now this hash function takes as message
input on one side right it takes message
input of and this can be short medium or
extremely long messages and the digest
is always a fixed size
it's always a fixed size right some get
longer than others different message
hashing functions give different length
but they're all fixed and they're fixed
even if the input is megabytes it can be
megabytes hundreds of megabytes and you
can still run all that through the hash
function and get a digest okay and so
the key thing is is it
is to make it so that for any change in
the input the digest also changes okay
and so here we have the red fox jumps
over the blue dog
right and that's the hash that comes out
and if we change one letter
you know the v to a u
the hash changes dramatically so this
hash changes dramatically so this
suggests this is a good cryptographic
hash function
right the length didn't change all the
characters are the same but one
character changed and the hash function
changes completely okay and here is
another
flipping of characters right where the
from here to here
let's give you a better color here
which color is that
yeah from here here the v and the e were
just toggled and yet from here to here
the hash function is completely
different and so the hash function needs
to generate quite different hashes even
with tiny perturbations of the input
you're not even allowed to change one
character add and remove character
and they know when a cryptographic hash
function is bad
if they can take two different messages
and send it through and get the same
digest and so there's a lot of research
to try to as soon as they come up with
one of these things there is a massive
amount of research to try to disprove it
to say that's a bad one
and the bad one is if two different
messages come in and they come out with
the same hash function then that's bad
because it means that it's
provable provably that the signature
could use the same signature can be used
to sign two different input messages
okay so this hash function
function
is a bit of computer code
right and you know shot one
you can go look on wikipedia for shot
one or md5
these are kind of classic hash functions
and when you read the sha1 or md5
wikipedia they'll talk about
the fact that it's been decided it's
kind of flawed and so there's like sha-1
don't use it it's not cool now you can
use it for less critical things you just
have to be aware of what its limitations
are it's like sha-256 is better than
sha-1 so what happens is there's
continuous research and there's
continuous improvement in the
mathematics of these hashing functions
and they're getting really good at it
because we've been using these things
for a very very very long time
now if you want to play whoa and clear
this up so um i've got a simple sha-1
calculator and um you can you'll be
using this in the homework
the sha-1 calculator takes as input
some kind of a plain text
and it produces
output when you hit the thing so you can
you put in pony or fluffy or whatever or
even a whole bunch of stuff and it
produces
a sha-1 okay so um
so basically uh
get ready to use this because the next
upcoming exercises are going to use this
and you can read sha one about sha one
on wikipedia and you can find out like
yeah it's seen as less than perfect and
you should use sha-256 or whatever but
actually lots of applications in less
than critical situations
know that you know for short and
reasonably length strings you know the
flaws are mathematically found but
they're not commonly run into so sha-1
is not
horrible it's just been proven sort of
less than ideal and so for highly
sensitive information you would never
use sha-1 but for simple things sha-1
and even things like md5
are commonly used like for hashing
passwords
[Music]
one of the things we've learned from the
snowden documents is that cryptography
broadly applied
gives the nsa trouble at least at scale
so the nsa does a lot of cryptanalysis
and they break a lot of systems but
well-designed well-implemented
cryptography
does stymie them
and it's important to understand how it
does
because if the nsa wanted to be
in my computer
they'd be in my computer done period
no
question about it
they would hack into my computer they
have a lot of tools to do that
if they are not in my computer one of
two things are true
one
it's against the law and the nsa is
following the law and two
i'm not high enough on their priorities
list
now what cryptography does
is it forces the attacker whether the
nsa or the chinese government or cyber
criminals or whoever
to have a priorities list
and depending on their budget they'll go
down the priorities list and the hope is
you're not there right you are below
their budget line
without cryptography
an organization organization like the
nsa
can
bulk collect data on everybody
with cryptography they are forced to
target
and that's extraordinarily valuable
because it means the fbi will go after
the criminals the nsa will go after the
agents of a foreign power
the chinese government will go after
the u.s government officials that rise
to whatever level they want to spy on
the cyber criminals will just go after a
few of us and the rest of us are
protected
that makes cryptography a very important
tool
now cryptography
doesn't actually provide any security
because cryptography is mathematics
when we say we trust the cryptography
what we're saying is we trust the
mathematics
and i think there's a lot of reason to
say that i trust the mathematics
everything i know about cryptography
tells me the mathematics is good
certainly there will be cryptographic
advances certainly some things will be
broken in the future but by and large
the math works
but math has no agency math can't do
anything it's equations on a piece of
paper in order for math to do something
someone has to take that math
and write code
and embed that code in a program
and embed that program in some bigger
system and put that bigger system on a
computer with an operating system on a
network with a user and all of those
things add in security
when the nsa breaks cryptography by and
large they don't break the mathematics
they break something else they break the
implementation they break the software
they break the network they break the
hardware the software is running on and
they do something somewhere else
and again and again we learn this lesson
right the math works
but putting stuff around it is much
harder
now there's an important corollary here
that complexity is the worst enemy of
security
right what these things do is they add
complexity the more complex you make
your system
the less secure it's going to be because
the more vulnerabilities they'll you'll
have
the more mistakes you'll make
somewhere
in that system
and we learn again and again when we see
analyses of voting systems embedded
systems your cell phone messaging
systems email systems that it's always
something around the crypto something
that
the designers the implementers the
coders the users got wrong
and the simpler we can make systems the
more secure they are
so what nist is doing
is they're trying to build
standards around as much as possible
right so they have a standard for a
crypto algorithm aes is the standard
crypto algorithm it was a public process
where
multiple groups submitted algorithms and
the community as a whole
picked a winner
and it wasn't dictated on high they
weren't secret criteria
the
aes algorithm was the one that most of
us thought should be aes actually there
were several we thought were good
candidates they picked one but there's a
lot of trust in the process because
there's a very public open international
process right shah 3 the new secure hash
standard the same sort of process
now it's really fun as a cryptographer
being involved in this process i mean i
think of it as a great crypto demolition
derby we all put our algorithms in the
ring beat each other up the last one
left standing wins it was kind of like
that you know we would all publish
papers analyzing each other
and
one of the ones left standing one
but you know that's just a small part of
what nist does they have standards of
random number generation they have
standards for
key agreement for different protocols i
mean trying to standardize these
components
so the implementers make fewer mistakes
but still is a lot you can't standardize
and those bigger pieces
where you're going to still find most of
your vulnerabilities i believe that's
where the nsa finds most of its
vulnerabilities
that it's out there
recently we learned about
vulnerabilities
in the key agreement protocols that are
used to secure a lot of the vpns and
internet connections right and if you
look at where that vulnerability was
it's because of a shortcut that was made
and and copy that allowed for a massive
precomputation the math worked great if
you want to make a standard worse you
make it super complex
and and you're just building in
vectors at that point and this is why
the normal ietf process for internet
standards doesn't really work for
security
because those standards are
compromises right let's put in all the
options make everyone happy let's put in
as much flexibility as necessary to make
the system as comprehensive as possible
that is sort of anti-secure security
security needs as few options as
possible
right as simple as possible you don't
want to compromise you want one group to
win
because that group
has a self-contained vision when you
have a piece of this and a piece of that
and a piece of that there's going to be
some interaction you didn't notice
and that interaction will be the
interaction that breaks your system
you didn't win aes right you were you
were in it you were in the demolition
derby with your helmet on
tell me a little bit about what it's
like to be in the demolition derby
toward the end and what it's like to
sort of not win the demolition derby
so aes was an interesting process it
started out with 64 algorithms
which 56 met the submission criteria
then nist whittled it down to i think it
was 15 or 16
and then in next round whittled it down
to five and then chose one so it's a
constant winnowing process
and
two fish which was my submission made it
all the way into the top five
and
those top five were all good algorithms
i mean there was no bad algorithms there
and the arguments were more about
security margin and implementability in
hardware versus embedded systems versus
constrained systems 8-bit 32-bit
so we were making
distinctions about how we thought it
would be used
and and to me it came down to i think
three algorithms that i thought these
were all good choices
right two fischer's one ring doll the
eventual winner was one and actually at
this point i forget what the third is
and
what i said on my blog at the time is
you know any of these three are good
and sure it would have been great to
have been the winner but they really
know something there's a lot of value in
nist picking a non-us algorithm
right by picking an algorithm from
belgium
it said to the world that nist is
picking what they thought was the best
and not trying to pick american
so
that was an important consideration i
hadn't thought of at the time
so i i can't fault in this process at
all been great to win it actually was
really fun to participate
and you know i would do it again and i
participated in the shah 3
competition which again
was picked by uh i mean someone else won
my my entry was called skein
and you know the these are
lots of fun for cryptographers and also
for students because they give
students a whole bunch of targets
one of the hard things if you're a
crypto student is you have to break
stuff the only way you learn how to make
things is by breaking things it's back
to that security mindset right anybody
can create a security system that he
can't break
so if you show up with a security system
and say i can't break this my first
question is well who are you
why should i trust your attestation that
you can't break it as something that's
meaningful what else have you broken
and these competitions give
a whole bunch of targets so students can
start breaking things that haven't been
broken before get papers out of it get
publications
get cred
in the field as someone who can break
stuff and therefore as someone who can
design stuff it's a it's a it's a source
of new problems it's a source of new
targets but this is what i said to start
security is inherently
adversarial and that adversarial nature
makes it different
unlike any other field in in computer
science
you go to a security conference a crypto
conference and there are going to be
papers of people who break each other's
stuff and you have to
get a thick skin
you have to understand that we are all
learning now if i produce a protocol and
you break it
sure i'm unhappy but i've learned
something and so have you and so is
everyone else
and that knowledge is more important
than
my particular creation
surviving
and you have to understand that and
accept that and that has to excite you
[Music]
the first application of this that we're
going to talk about
is
hashing passwords
so you go to a new site even
coursera.org and it asks you to create
an account and create a password
now
you're not supposed to but lots of
people use the same password for lots of
systems
and so if your coursera password were
somehow mistakenly revealed they might
get your linkedin password as well
and so
it is considered very bad form very very
bad form to actually ever store
your password
in the coursera database
in plain text
because if the database was somehow
compromised then all the bad guys would
get
all of the plain text passwords and
again maybe use them not just on
coursera because you could change your
password on coursera but use them on
linkedin and twitter and whatever and
youtube and steal all your accounts by
compromising one account because you
made the mistake
that lots of people do of using the same
password in a lot of different places
because we're tired of making up a new
password for each place
so you're not allowed to store the plain
text password in the database that's bad
practice and we don't want to do that so
the best practice is to store a hashed
version of it to run take the plain text
of the password when you're creating
your account
run a cryptographic hash on it
store the cryptographic hash and then
when you log in next you present to the
system your plain text password and it
runs your presented password through a
cryptographic hash same cryptographic
hash and then compares it with the
hashed password in the database if they
match you must have presented the same
plain text both times this is a way that
they can verify that you've represented
the same plain text again
without
them ever storing the plain text okay
that's why a respectable system we'll
never send you your password
it's
i've almost started doing this where i
as soon as i go to a new system and i
set my password i set it to crap and i
have them send me
a message
to reset my password and if they send me
the actual plain text to the password
it's like
and i use some crap password i've
actually got to the point where
i'm tired of reusing my passwords and my
technique i don't know if it's a good
one or bad one is i just put crap in for
my password and then every time i use
this system i have it send me a new
password to reset the password i mean
that i really think we should just
change it so that when you log in it
just comes to your email and you click a
link i don't know
i'm not expert on this stuff you know so
but a respectable computing system will
never ever ever send you your plaintext
password because they don't possess it
and they can't derive it these
cryptographic hashes are not backwards
you can't make them go backwards let's
go back here they're only a one-way hash
because this might be one megabyte of
data and this might be well let's see
four times
this is 40 characters 40 characters of
data one megabyte squeezes down to 40
characters there is no way to go
backwards the information is lost
the hash is you know distinct and unique
right but you cannot go backwards it's a
one-way operation you can go from the
plain text to the hash but you can't go
from the hash to the plain text which is
very different than encryption and
decryption right in decryption you had
to be able to pull the plain text back
out from the encrypted text this is not
encryption this is calculating a special
digest that is uniquely connected to the
plain text message but you need to run
the plain text through the hash again
and then compare okay
so
let's do some homework
well so now let me let me let me first
show you uh the how this works in the
hash passwords
so
so let's say for example you're logging
into corsair.org and creating your
profile for the first time and it says
please give me your password
and you choose a singularly bad password
as fluffy
okay so fluffy and you can type go type
fluffy into doctorchuck.com
sha1.php in another window if you type
fluffy and you encrypt it with sha1
you get this as the hash password
and then this is what they store in in
coursera's database
and so that is they don't know they
never store fluffy they they would not
do that that would be so bad if they did
that so they store this
and if i get this it's very difficult to
reverse engineer it to fluffy it also is
even harder if you make your password
long
best passwords are like sentences not
just eight characters but they're like
long sentences
of stuff that's rather difficult to
predict
so this is what's stored in the coursera
databases some ugly
string which is a a cryptographic hash
digest of your password so now you log
out and and this is gone that's only in
your mind
and this is sitting in the database
so you log in you log back into coursera
and you forget your password so you type
in
pony if you run pony through sha-1
you get this as the cryptographic hash
of the word pony
and you look and you compare
and you go nope
that is not the right password i don't
know what the right password is i can't
give you a hint i can't tell you hey you
you put shift on your password why don't
you try taking that off you know you
seem to have caps lock on because it
doesn't know whether what your password
is but it does know that pony is not
your password then what it does
right so this is what's stored in the
database then you go oh my secretary
that's right i use fluffy for my
password on coursera so then coursera
runs that through sha1
it gets the cryptographic hash of the
plain text that you entered and then it
compares it to the what it has stored as
the cryptograph the plain as the as your
hashed password and it matches so then
it says yay i'll let you back in
the fluffy only existed in your mind
unless you foolishly like wrote it on a
post-it note and stuck it up on your
computer which you shouldn't do as well
but whatever it was
coursera never stored my coursera never
stored it coursera only stored this
and that again is why coursera can never
tell you what your password is or any
reasonable site can never tell you what
your password is it can only tell you it
can only let you change it again which
is easy changing it again you just it
decides oh it sends you mail you give it
a new password and it recomputes a sha
one for that one and stores that sha-1
so that's why you have to get password
resets to happen
okay
okay so the next thing um that i want to
talk about is i want to talk about
digital signatures how we can use this
for message integrity so we've got the
notion of a cryptographic hash which is
a calculation takes a large block of
text so far we've only used it on small
blocks of text okay but now we're going
to use it on larger blocks of text where
we're going to
ensure message integrity which means
we're going to figure out if this
message actually came from the person we
think that it came from okay so we're
going to use
integrity now i mean in a sense what the
system was doing when you were typing in
a password was it was ensuring that you
were really the person on the other end
of the line right hi i'm i'm logging in
as dr chuck and here's my password
fluffy that's by giving you the password
i'm proving that to coursera that i'm
really dr chuck so it's a form of
integrity right author of
identification is form of integrity
right it's no different than showing
your driver's license says yes this is
really me okay but now we're going to do
it in a way that we're going to send a
message so it's not just a password
we're not really solving just the
password problem but we're actually
going to use it to make sure that the
message a came from the right person and
b was not modified in transit this is
kind of the
doctor signing the prescription
digitally and then sending you an email
with your prescription that you can just
print the email and take it take it to
your uh take it to your pharmacist
so again message integrity when you get
a message did it come from who did it
come from and do you come from who you
really thought it came from or was it
altered in transit
okay
so if you go back to our little example
from the christmas story
um
the message from annie was eat more
ovaltine
now the question really becomes did it
really come from annie
right because little orphan annie didn't
necessarily
say it
little orphanage handed the message to
somebody else
and then they read it
so did that person change the message
because maybe there was actually a
secret message from annie and maybe
annie wrote it and it really was an
important secret message but then
somebody like the advertiser changed it
and sent it to you as if and it came
from annie so that we're not really
worried so much now about the plain text
that is the fine plain text the question
is
did it really come from little orphan
annie
because we are receiving this from an
insecure media
like annie's so out here somewhere but
annie handed somebody to hand it to
somebody and to somebody to send across
radio yada yada the question is did the
message originally come from annie long
long ago
handed through many people or not
this is again like the seal that you put
on with the wax
did it really come from that person or
not
is it really annie just saying yeah this
is annie that's too easy you could say
eat
less ovaltine or or maybe annie wanted
to say i hate ovaltine
right that's my if but we don't know if
annie said eat more ovaltine or not
right because all we saw was eat more
ovaltine and it seemed to counter manny
but we gotta know you gotta know that it
came from annie or not okay
so
simple message signing using uh shared
secret and we'll move to a better
technique later but we're going to start
with a simple technique of shared secret
is that we have a shared secret that
we're going to use for message signing
it'll probably be different than the
crypt encryption secret okay so now we
get together with annie in a shared room
and she tells us what the shift is going
to be and then she tells us what our
shared signature secret is going to be
and then we separate
so the technique that you do is before
we send the message we concatenate the
secret to the message
right so
eat more ovaltine
and then put the secret on the end of
the message and then you compute
the digest of the message plus the
secret concatenated together
then you remove the secret from the
message and then you send the message
plus the digest across the insecure
and in my wife's example this was the
little
signature numbers that came from her
doctor
was the digest
but it was the digest not just of the
message but of the message plus the
secret
the secret didn't come across the
message plus the digest came across so
let's look at this
when we look at how when we receive a
message
so we receive a message and we see a
digest at the end of the message and
it's across an insecure transport so we
take the digest off the message
take the digest off the message and we
add the secret back on the message
we know the secret annie knows the
secret but the people in the middle who
transported the mess do not know the
secret so it's finally arrived in our
location
we see the digest we pull that off and
hold on to it we add the secret to it we
can take the concatenated message plus
secret we run it through sha1 we get a
digest locally
and then
we compare that digest to the receive
digest
and the only way to make the digest
match is to know the secret now maybe
somebody like
made annie tell them the secret which
means they could forge the messages but
if the secret is not been compromised
somehow their only way to create the
digest is to know the secret
right
and so we can compare the received
digest to the known uh the the the the
known digest that we compute on rn in a
secure way because we and annie are the
only ones in possession of the secret
so here we go
so you can play with this on shaw one
dot php dr chuck um and so if the
message is
that annie wants us to send or any wants
us to get is eat more ovaltine and the
secret is santa
so what
the what you do is you take the message
concatenate the secret
and then run that through sha-1 this is
all happening in
in annie's secure room and she comes up
with a digest now i'm not there's it's
longer than this but that's just the
first uh
six characters of it and then what she
does is she removes the secret and then
concatenates the digest okay
and that's what gets sent across the
insecure medium it could be many steps
could be many people it could be on
paper it could be morse code it could be
phone call who knows radio
but we we just this is the danger right
this is we do not know
if the message is harmed in any way as
it moves across this medium
okay
so then what we do is we receive the
message
right we don't know if it's a good
message or a bad message
so we see that it's a message and it has
a digest on the end of the message and
we split that out
we split the digest out and we hold on
to the digest separately okay
and now we have the message minus the
digest and so then what we do is we add
the secret back on because only annie
and us know the secret
right
and
annie and us know the secret we all know
how to do shot one and so we take this
message
and we run it through sha1 and we get a
digest that we've computed locally this
is the receive digest that's the local
digest and then we compare
and we say
this is great
that musta came from annie and we know
that it came from annie even if it came
through a dangerous set of steps and we
can't trust any of the people that
transported the message we they're all
untrustworthy but we know that no matter
what happened that originally at that
moment
annie did this
okay annie made this digest because
without knowing the word santa there is
nothing and this could be like megabytes
of data
and this is a real tiny you know 40
character thing here
the digest is small the message is large
so you can't go backwards to get it
there's no backwards here
now if you can steal the secret from
annie then all bets are off of course so
we we have to assume that annie's okay
and that you know annie was not
compromised like in james bond movies
for example
but i was trying to get the secret from
the good guy okay so let's go and do
this again right
so here we go
we
want to send the eat more oval team
and the secret santa and so we do the
same thing and we end up with
end up with that and then she
concatenates it and this is all done you
know in annie's bedroom and secret thing
and then she sends it okay she sends it
to us
but
a diabolical diabolical courier
says
i
have a thing about ovaltine and i'm
going to change them more to less so i'm
going to change this message to be eat
less ovaltine
right
so eat less ovaltine bad
evil
err i don't know how to draw evil i'm a
terrible artist
can't draw evil
so some untrusted courier has changed
the word more to less so we see the
thing that says and and we don't know
right we didn't see the courier they was
carrying the box who knows what they did
but they changed it we gave us new copy
so we receive this message from a
untrusted medium there's our untrusted
medium
and it is our job to decide if we really
think it came from annie or not
so
what we do is just like we did before we
break the message and the digest into
pieces
and then we add the known secret to the
end of it
right so we've added the known secret to
the end of it right here then we run it
through the sha-1 calculation and you
can take
there we go and go ahead and try this if
you want you maybe you have this up in a
separate window sha one dot php put less
ovaltine santa in and you will get
a different signature because you change
even a single character and sha 1 will
give us a different digest that's
cryptographic caches in action right
even the tiniest change
in megabytes of data will change the
cryptographic hash
that's the beauty of sha-1 and md5 and
you know shot 256 and the others there
is no match
so we know
that this
message did not either did not come from
annie or was modified in transit so we
can tell the difference and we do not
have to trust
the medium
right
okay
so um
let's see what got coming up next here
okay
so here is the encryption technique
and let let's just
stop and let you do one of these on your
own
and say that we've got two messages from
annie
and i want you to stop and i want you to
calculate santa is the santa is the
secret
okay
santa is the secret
and i want you to tell me
if free cookies or free candy actually
came from annie or not one of them is a
valid message from annie
and the other is not a valid message
from annie okay
so i want you to take a moment
use the sha-1 calculator and i want you
to try to figure out which of these is
valid and which of these is not valid
okay
give you a minute
one last chance before we do the reveal
okay here we go
so
here comes a message from uh insecure
medium free cookies
with that as the message digest we
and we got the other one free candy with
that is the message digest
so what we do is we take and
take off the digest and add the word
santa
to each one
and then we run the sha one on each one
and then we get the two shah ones
here's the one and here's the two
and then what we do most importantly
is we compare them with the received
sha-1
and when you compare them with the
receive sha-1 or the received message
digest or the receive message signature
you see right away
that one is good and one is bad it's as
simple as that
right one of these is good and one of
these is bad
so digital signatures are are actually
really surprisingly simple and
surprisingly easy to do without a lot of
complex technology the only complex
technology in here is really the the
clever mathematics that makes these
cryptographic hashes work effectively
it the simple concatenation of a secret
now you want your secrets to be kind of
longer than this and more random than
that but ultimately the notion of a
digital signature is actually a simple
and and rather elegant and beautiful
notion that really leverages this notion
of cryptographic hashes in a really cool
manner so
that kind of sums up our first half
lecture where we really talk more about
the techniques of
both integrity and confidentiality
but we've done it all with share a
secret key right where we have the same
key we have a moment
where we're together in a secure manner
and we exchange the code book whether
it's annie or
or the caesar or whatever where we know
what the shift is right so every pair of
communicating people or systems needs us
a key
now in the internet with everybody
buying from everybody else and using
credit cards it's just not practical you
just could not have a secret key for
amazon
i guess it kind of works for the
password now let's do it we'll get to
that in a second and the password
doesn't solve everything
because then you would have to actually
visit amazon to get your password set up
and so the problem is is you you we have
to use an insecure medium to establish
the first
secret as it were
and so it just was never going to work
so we need a different approach for the
internet and that's we're going to talk
about in the next lecture okay
see you then
so welcome to our lecture on public key
encryption where we're going to go back
to uh confidentiality
and so
so here we go if if you recall we've
been having these two topics that have
been our theme throughout uh just some
grizzle
oh sorry i'm starting to
talk in row 13. let's translate this
back to uh non-row 13. uh the
terminology the two kind of themes we've
been following over the last couple of
lectures in this lecture are
confidentiality and integrity and
confidentiality
is hiding right shielding information
not leaking information to people that
you don't want to show it to
and integrity is making sure that you
know who you're dealing with and then
the previous lecture we really talked
about kind of real light approachable
ways of ensuring confidentiality with
things like caesar cipher and then
integrity using a simple message digest
that based on a shared secret so the
problem with all of those things that we
just saw is that they require a shared
secret and the problem in the world of
the internet is it's just really
difficult for every one of us before we
establish um
we before we can make any uh
purchases or whatever at amazon that we
somehow have to drive to amazon
headquarters and
and get a shared secret from amazon
they'll open up a book and say okay
hi chuck i see who you are and here's
our shared secret and you walk away and
as long as you carry that shared secret
away you go and if the shared secret is
lost it's uh difficult to revoke so as
the internet and and frankly in general
as uh security needed to be
able to work at arm's length meaning
that you couldn't always bring everybody
together and hand out shared secrets and
then have them go to the far reaches of
the world and communicate
public key encryption was identified
as a extremely elegant solution to this
problem
and so it was proposed by uh diffie and
hellman in 1976
and it relies on two keys it's
asymmetric meaning we're not using the
same key to encrypt as decrypt the way
we were in the previous lectures these
are asymmetric there is a public key
which is actually
does not need any protection whatsoever
in a private key and the idea is they're
generated inside of a computer you
generate the public key in the private
key you send out the public key the
public key is used to do the encryption
and then private key is used to do the
decryption and they're related
mathematically in a way that's well
understood
but difficult to compute for a key
length that's large enough so there's a
public key and a private key
so i'd like to you to take a look at
this little video up on youtube of uh
diffie hellman and merkel the the
inventors of this
and i think it's a great video um i
would
love it if this were my video but i
didn't produce this video so uh so take
a quick look
so one of the things about this
public private key encryption is now
that we know about it it's like whoa
it's pretty obvious and frankly
caesar and the germans and everybody
could have used this idea they just
hadn't thought of it yet and the other
thing that's kind of interesting if you
look into the story of this is that
the first reaction people got when they
start thinking about this is like it
can't be this easy no it's sort of both
easy and hard but but the concept is
real elegant and really beautiful and
that is that we have this public key so
the public key is part of a public
private pair and it's used to do the
encryption the beautiful beauty is it's
computationally difficult to recover
that private key from the public key and
the encrypted text a key thing is it's
not impossible
and that's kind of one of the
interesting
philosophies of security that that we
started at the very beginning talking
about security the perfect security is
kind of impossible to achieve unless you
simply
don't send anything
and so
public private key asymmetric keys is
well understood as to how you would
break it everyone knows how to break it
the problem is is that computers aren't
fast enough to break it and when
computers get faster we'll just make the
keys bigger so the mathematics of this
makes it impractical to break i mean
literally in practical break
now i think we can safely assume that
governments probably have enough
computation to crack these once in a
great while i mean if they're not
cracking every transaction between you
and target when you want to buy
something but if they really have to
they can record the encrypted
transmissions and if they really had to
it took a long time i have no idea how
long it would be
they can break it so that's actually
kind of a
neat way to think about this by
revealing it all
frankly any computer scientist could
make
a name for them their whole life if they
proved that there was something wrong
with this by revealing the algorithm
revealing the cracking technique if
someone can come up with a better
cracking technique it is like
fame and glory forever which means that
we're pretty sure that there's no good
way to crack this other than the brute
force mechanism that requires a large
amount of computation
so
if you're going to use
public private key encryption you have
to generate a pair
and it starts by charging
choosing two really large random numbers
with
hundreds if not thousands of digits that
are prime
so you kind of choose a choose a random
number really big and then you kind of
look around for a nearby prime number
and you choose two of those and then you
multiply them
okay getting an even larger number
and then
through some steps through some
calculations you compute the public and
the private keys from that large number
the essence of this are those two prime
numbers prime numbers of course are
numbers that you only divide by
themselves in one which means they have
no factors which means they're kind of
like looking for a needle in a haystack
and so the public and private key is
really based on these two prime numbers
if you could figure out what the prime
numbers were
you'd be okay but the computational
difficulties finding the prime numbers
that are extremely large and finding the
right prime numbers that are extremely
large
so it's easy to do some calculations in
one direction but not in other so for
example what are the factors of fifty
five million one hundred twenty four
thousand one hundred and fifty nine
quick
but if i simply ask you what do you
multiply
919 to get that 55 million number
that's easy you do a division and it
turns out that you can find out
69 61 really easy right so if i just say
what are these two numbers
that's hard
if i say given this number what's the
other number that's trivial so you can
think of this as
the decryption is where the receiver of
the message knows kind of half of the
calculation whereas the world doesn't
know either half of it doesn't know the
calculation so it has to figure out both
halves whereas the receiver only has to
figure out one half and so that's how
asking the question of what are the
factors
versus given one what's the other so it
takes a problem that's easy makes it
computationally nearly impossible but
again not impossible just nearly
impossible
okay so here's the notion so you're
about to type your visa card into
uh a credit card into like amazon's web
page
and so what happens is is that amazon
will has a public key and a private key
that they retain and they will send you
the public key across a medium the
internet they're going to send this to
you
somehow
but
the bad guys eve or charlie or whoever
they are
the bad guys
this is
alice and bob
and eve and charlie are always looking
so even charlie kids intercept it and
you assume that they can this is the key
don't don't try to pretend they can't
even though it's very difficult for them
to do it but you assume they can so the
public key comes across it is simply
sent to you as part of the beginning of
establishing a cert secure connection
and the bad guys see it too
or gals
they see it too so the public key comes
to you
and then what you do is you encrypt
using that public key
and create some encrypted text
ciphertext which you then send back
across the danger where eve and charlie
are watching and it comes across they
intercept the encrypted text they've
intercepted the public key and they they
can try as hard as they like with super
computers to derive this and frankly
like i said if they had months and
months and months and really fast
computers they could
okay
but because amazon is in sole possession
the private key and it never left amazon
servers it is a very simple matter for
amazon to decrypt and get your plaintext
it happens very quickly just like if you
kind of know half of the prime number
calculation figuring out the other prime
number is really really easy okay so
so again these people see all this
information and yet is computationally
virtually impossible for all practical
purposes to do it and so it's beautiful
because
there was no need to protect the public
key we never had to get in the same room
and away it goes so you just amazon just
blasts out its public key and we encrypt
using amazon's public key we can't
decrypt it but we don't need to decrypt
it all we need to do is send it to
amazon and voila it works so the
beautiful thing is is the public keys
can be distributed they can be
intercepted and it does not matter
so
with this notion of public private key
encryption in general we made a change
to http
a layer a mini layer is in the data
model if you remember way back perhaps
you even forgotten about the layered
model remember that layered model
application transport internet
remember this is sort of one computer
and this is the other computer
these are the routers
routers these are the hops
there's like 15 of these remember
remember all this
so it comes back not on us
okay so if you recall
just sort of to briefly remember the the
transport layer is responsible for the
re-transmission it gives us the
appearance of a reliable
ordered connection between the our
application and the far application
uh http is one of the application
protocols
um and so there is a little mini layer
that that is layered in sort of
seamlessly
on top of the transport layer
that basically takes plain text and
encrypts it and turns it into ciphertext
and then ciphertext on the way out and
turns it back into plain text okay
and so what happens is these
applications just send plain text and
out comes plain text and there's a
little bit of extra glue in the middle
here that's sort of a secure transport
secure sockets layer this is this thing
here is often called a socket oop sock
yeah it'd be good if i could spell
socket so this is a socket and then the
red part is a secure socket
so the applications kind of don't
encrypt the data at all there is a
library that encrypts it and the other
thing is is that all the rest of the
internet the internet the link layer the
routers
nothing the ethernet the fiber they
don't even know the difference between
encrypted text and non-encrypted text
because the encrypted text wanders
around fully encrypted
addresses are not encrypted and so it
stays encrypted all the way through the
entire network
it actually if you then think about the
fact that
this is the moment that it leaves your
computer
the only thing so the plain text comes
in here gets encrypted here encrypted
comes down the only thing that leaves
your computer is encrypted text and it
makes it all the way across the
encrypted text goes into amazon so this
is amazon
this is you
the encrypted text
finds its way through all these things
and it comes in encrypted and it
actually doesn't get encrypted until
it's sort of right at the point where
amazon's web server that's going to
actually charge a credit card so this is
actually beautifully elegant in that
the rest of the network is blissfully
unaware
that any encryption is happening it's
just moving the data so this did not
require any change again the beauty of a
layered architecture did not require any
change sort of below the transport layer
and as a matter of fact all of the
sequencing and re-transmission that
happens in the tcp layer that happens
with the encrypted stuff too because
it's just
encrypted it's just text it's gibberish
text it's not the original visa card
number that you're sending you're
sending one two three and out comes you
know w x y
the w x y just goes it's retransmitted
all this crap just works it's like
beautiful it's a beautiful thing it's
absolutely beautiful thing
and it's just like this mini layer kind
of between the app it's like the top
slice of the transport layer that's how
i'm drawing it right here it's like this
little kind of top extra little thing
says you know what we're going to
transport but actually help me out and
give me some encryption while we're at
it and there's all kinds of cool stuff
that goes back and forth the public and
private keys get exchanged that's all
kind of stuff we don't worry about we
just send data and get data back
pretty cool huh
so
this really solves the problem
of the fact that we basically should
assume that everything between our
computer and the destination computer
this is you
this is amazon
right everything here this is all
dangerous there's some like terrifyingly
scary individual that's watching
everything doing packet sniffing this
might be eve the eavesdropper
this looks like a little he he looks
pretty tough right and and so that even
the wireless right this is the wi-fi
connection the wi-fi is dangerous now
the reality is is these things aren't
all that dangerous the wi-fi is probably
the weakest link of this whole thing but
we have to assume that it's dangerous
right we we want to assume that the only
thing that's safe and unfortunately if
you put viruses in your computer then
they can get it the plain text if amazon
loses its data somehow then they get the
plain text right but but basically you
know we want to distrust
all of this
okay so this concept is called
transport layer security also called ssl
also known as https
http
for secure
and it's kind of like between the tcp
layer and the application layer or the
top half the tcp layers the way i like
to think about it
it's because it's based on public
private key encryption it's
difficult but not impossible
normal people
don't have the kind of equipment to
break it and even governments
if they can break it i don't even know
i'm not an expert i don't hang out with
the government so i don't really know
but assume that if they really put their
mind to it in a very narrow situation
if you become really interesting they
will find your credit cards probably
there's easier ways to get your credit
cards than by decrypting your text so
it's
hard to decrypt
and as i mentioned because of the
layered architecture the tcp layer ip
and link layers are completely unaware
so you'll you you see this in the form
of urls that start with https
right they start with https
www.facebook.com versus http and there
was a time a few years back where
you know they were it used to be a
little more expensive inside of the
servers to do https that still is
and so some sites would try to do some
of their activity without using secure
protocols and others would use uh
use non-secure and secure and then flip
you back and forth like if you're typing
your password the problem was is that
there was actually still sensitive data
being sent even across the insecure and
there was a quite a famous uh
thing where people could install a
firefox plug-in and watch facebook
non-secure facebook things go back and
forth
across like a starbucks and it would
just show you all the people's facebook
accounts and you could log in as them
and post as them and so you've seen a
situation where companies are just
starting to use https for everything you
as a user have to be aware to see if
you're typing anything sensitive never
type it into a url
that doesn't say https okay never do
that you're typing password uh credit
card number any kind of personal
information
make sure you're doing https and make
sure that
that you know what it is we'll talk
about that uh in a bit we'll talk a
little bit more about that in a bit so
so if we take a look and we think about
where the bad guys are at the bad guys
are kind of everything
and this secure tcp
runs is the one part of the layer of
architecture that runs from within your
laptop to within the server and so then
if we kind of assume the worst
the the the backbone is pretty safe the
wi-fi is probably the most dangerous
right
but when we do secure system tcp
secure
system to system tcp we are doing the
encryption
right here inside your computer before
it leaves and we're only doing the
decryption right when it comes back in
the computer so the decryption and
encryption are happening inside of
amazon's computer and inside of your
computer and nothing else so secure
sockets is pretty good now the place
where you're still danger
is there might be a virus that's
watching your keystrokes right this is
why virus checking is so important
because at some point you're typing it
into your computer and the greatest
danger you have to losing your data is
really two things one that you've got a
virus or b
somebody has redirected you
not to talk to evil amazon instead of
amazon and that's what we'll talk about
in the next lecture
how to know
how does these browsers really know
they're talking to the real amazon and
that is not confidentiality
confidentiality is stopping the bad guy
from seeing what you're sending
as their eavesdropping eve
is eavesdropping
okay
now the next thing is the question of is
this the real amazon or is this a fake
amazon so we'll talk about that next
[Music]
so now we have a way
to ensure the confidentiality using
secure socket layer and public private
key encryption
and the only question now remaining
is who are we talking to and are we
talking to that server that we think
we're talking to are we really talking
to amazon are we talking to coursera
how do we know now you'll notice if you
take a look at the top of your browser
perhaps right now even you can take a
look at the top of your browser and
usually when it's indicating that you
have a secure connection you can click
on this and see some information it's
called the certificate information
okay
and so
https has the notion of a public key we
retrieve the public key when we make the
connection but there are two kinds of
keys there are
public keys that are just made up that
are sent to us and then there are public
keys that are signed and validated by a
third-party certification authority so
this is a coursera
and it is certified by godaddy
certification authority so it's not just
that we're getting the certificate from
coursera we're actually getting the
certificate
signed
by godaddy the godaddy has
has
has got checked the id of coursera
said okay you must be the ceo of
coursera or i'm not going to give you
this sign signed private key so it's a
it's a process to get private keys
signed and it's a way to make sure you
are talking to who you think you're
talking to so this is called
digital certificates
also known as sort of signed private
keys now if we go back and we talk about
the integrity right we want to know who
we're talking about and so we had this
notion of a signature a signature is a
way that you know that you're talking to
who you're talking to so for example
like if a guy comes to your office
and says hi i'm dr chuck got like a
beard and some white hair you can say
hey if you're really dr chuck show me
your tattoo and now you'll know
that
very few people will also look like this
and have this tattoo right so this is my
private key and this is my
signature of my private key this is like
my message digest so so people won't
have this tattoo if they claim to be dr
chuck so this is dr chuck this is my
message digest
so there's a difference between a
private key and a private key that's
been certified by one of these
designated third parties these
designated third parties are called
certificate authorities
now you could say i'm a certificate
authority well some certificate
authorities are more
better certificate authorities than
others okay so they're a trusted third
party
and so
how did they start well
some are more trusted than others and
the more we trust them they kind of all
work out so it's not everybody you can't
become a trusted authority
so
one of the many trusted authorities and
one of the oldest ones and one of the
more popular ones and one of the more
expensive ones
it's pretty expensive to get your
certificate signed it can be as
inexpensive as a couple hundred dollars
it can be thousands of dollars to get a
certificate signed
and verisign is one of the oldest and
most well respected of these certificate
authorities so the idea is is that
i have this website called
online.drchuck.com where i
teach python classes and do various
other things and i wanted a secure
certificate because i would be handling
people's data and i wanted to to be
respectable and have a secure
certificate
so i had a public and a private key and
then i sent it to a certificate
authority i paid them money and then
they send me back a signed private key
okay so this is uh now now you might say
oh this is kind of evil or this is
really expensive because all they really
are doing is like changing a few bits in
the in my private key you're adding a
few bits to my private key
but they have a lot of responsibility
and the good ones have a lot of
credibility so they don't want to lose
information they got to spend some time
validating identity saying okay are you
really
the owner of doctorchuck.com they're not
going to hand the certificate assigned
certificate for drchuck.com to anybody
except the true owner and so they spend
some time checking to make sure that
it's the true owner and they they do
this by looking at the registration data
on doctortruck.com et cetera et cetera
et cetera and so there is a cost of
verifying all this identity
kind of like the signature track on
coursera
and that's kind of what's going on on
the signature track of coursera there's
a difference between a certificate
and a certificate that corsair is going
to assert that we have verified the
identity and the cost is in the
verification of the identity so
certificate authorities are
charging amazon
but then ensuring that they don't
mistakenly give the amazon.com
certificate to a random bad guy because
if they did
that bad guy could pretend to be
amazon.com
so then you might ask
who decides which of these certificate
authorities to trust we use the
certificate authorities to decide
whether or not to trust amazon.com or
coursera.org or doctorchuck.com or
whatever how do we
decide which of the certificate
authorities we're going to trust well it
turns out that apple microsoft and linux
and other operating system vendors
pre-install at the moment that you're
either purchasing your computer or
installing your operating system part of
that operating system is actually a list
of the public keys
of the chosen certificate authority so
if you look deep enough inside your
computer this is my mac
you can see the companies that have been
included
by apple as the manufacturer of the
operating system and so you see that
verisign is one of those companies that
has been pre-included in apple macintosh
which means that a certificate from
verisign
is going to be known right so let's so
let's look a little bit more so so these
come your browsers and your operating
systems come with
pre-built in public key certificates for
certain certificate authorities
like verison
now that's a lot of trust that apple
microsoft and linux have placed in
verisign and that's because over the
years verizon has earned that trust
that says verisign doesn't just give out
certificates without checking right if
the verisign gave out an amazon.com
certificate to somebody without checking
they would lose a lot of credibility and
then microsoft would like take them out
right say well verisign seems to be kind
of sleazy they seem not to be able to to
handle their security but you know they
have and so they remain in there and so
we it's kind of a an interesting thing
where they are motivated to keep their
security high they're motivated to do a
good job because the moment that they
sort of fail they lose a lot of
credibility and respect and their value
of verisign brand and is all of the
respect that we have for verisign
so
so we mentioned public private key
encryption we have the public key that
goes across
and i'm about to type my credit card in
and so the problem now that we're going
to solve is
uh is this really amazon's key is it
really amazon's public key i mean i got
a public key from across this connection
i made to a server and it claims that
it's amazon.com but
do i believe that it says it's
amazon.com and so that's the integrity
thing that's the security that's the do
i believe it is it really got the uh
verisign tattoo
in addition to the amazon.com that's it
represents that it's amazon.com public
key
so we can also use public keys to do
signing and
and basically verisign has a public and
private key for verisign the public key
for verisign is sitting in your browser
right now
and they use they do an encryption much
like the message digest they do an
encryption of amazon's certificate and
then sort of create a digest and then
add that digest to it so a certificate
says i'm amazon.com and later it says oh
yes and verisign signed this with
verisign's private key
okay so verisign's private key is used
to sign amazon this is probably easiest
if i just show you sort of a video
wait ooh going the wrong way am i going
the wrong way
what's going on here how come i'm going
yeah i'm going the wrong way okay so
here we go going backwards so here's how
it works
um
this is how amazon gets a public key
signed by
uh verison
right so
in the beginning verisign makes a public
and a private key
somewhere in a bunker
and they store the private key and
they'll you can sometimes read up on how
many how much effort they go to storing
the private key and then they hand the
public key
to apple
microsoft
and linux
and then they bundle that in with your
laptop so your laptop that you buy you
walk out
and you have a laptop and it's got
public keys in it
from the vendor now amazon
says you know what i'd like to do some
commerce and i would like to be able to
use ssl and us and have a certified
private key
so then what amazon does
is amazon inside of its servers
generates a pair a public private key
pair
so this private key is not leaving
amazon servers it's it takes a while it
takes minutes sometimes to generate
the right random sufficiently random
public and private key
by looking at all the large prime
numbers and then picking one and then
bang making a public and private key
then what amazon does at that point
is it transports its public key to
verizon now during that transport it
might eve might have seen it but it's
okay because it's just it's just a
public key
right so it's just the public key and so
it actually can be sent across the
internet and it's most commonly sent
across the internet like when i got the
online.doctorchuck.com certificates we
just typed it in and sent it because
if you get a hold of the public key all
it means is you can encrypt it doesn't
mean you can decrypt so then what
happens is
inside of verizon's servers
verizon computes a message digest using
its public it's private key
right and then it adds basically a
signature
that says oh
here's amazon's public key that i
received from amazon verified the
identity of the person and now i have
signed it mr ver verisign i've signed it
and that of course is just like message
digest like information that is appended
to the bits
of the public key
then that public key with signature
is sent back
bundled together and sent back to amazon
and now amazon has not just any old
public key it has a public key that says
i am amazon.com and verisign is now
asserting that i am really who i am
and
again
so eve saw that one
who cares
it's just a public key
there's nothing about the verisign
private key it never left the verisign
servers the signature is public
information you can use the verisign
public key to verify that the signature
is right
but you can't forge the signature
so eve can look at that eve could look
going this way eve can look that way eve
gets nothing
he gets nothing so
amazon now has a signed
and certified private key
then what happens
is
sooner or later
many hours many days many months later
you decide on your laptop remember this
is you oops this is you
you want to buy some shoes
so you connect to amazon.com
with your browser with an https
connection
and then what happens is
amazon sends you its public key and eve
of course is eavesdropping all the time
eve sees it goes by
it's worthless right it's worthless
because it's just the encryption key
it's not the decryption key the fact
that it's signed it sees that but it
can't do anything with that information
now
within your laptop
you have
from the vendor
the verisign public key
from macintosh or apple or whatever so
you can look with this quebec you can
look with this public key at that
signature and just like we did with the
message digest before you can go yep
that's good
that really had to have been signed by
verison and if you're if your computer's
really conservative it can actually go
check with verisign can send it up and
say hey did you verify this and then
verisign can verify it too but you
actually don't need to connect because
you have the public key the only way
that the the you know whatever that
message digest could be right would be
is if verisign private key was used to
generate the message digest just like we
used to do santa in the other one okay
the sand is just really simple but it's
the same basic mechanism this
is verifiable
that it came from this private key now
if somebody broke in and stole the
private key that's a different story but
if the private key is safe and secure
hasn't been compromised the only way to
generate that message digest is be in
possession of the private key so now you
are in a position
where you are in a good mood right
you see an https you can pop that little
thing and say that was signed by
verisign you can be assured that
verisign is asserting that that key came
really that public key came from amazon
and now is time
to encrypt
your visa card
and send it over an encrypted connection
to amazon
okay because you won't send your
encrypted thing your your you won't send
it unless you believe that the https is
proper and your browser will pop up a
little pop-up and say wait a sec this
certificate looks a little funky
claims to be from amazon.com but it's
not signed by one of the signatures that
i believe in
so you send your data it is encrypted
and eve is watching right eve is always
watching but because it's encrypted with
a public key unless he has super
computers in a couple of months there's
nothing that eve can do and then of
course
amazon decrypts it
using the private key so the private key
comes in
and let me redo that
right so in it comes
eve watches but is helpless
because they don't have enough computers
eve doesn't have enough computers and
your key is large enough so amazon then
takes its private key and uses that to
decrypt it and ends up with your plain
text again
so if you think this whole thing through
this eve was watching the whole time
we
sent it public key we signed and
returned a public key then we sent the
public key to your laptop we verified
the public key and the whole time eve is
sort of watching all this information
and she is powerless
to break it
pretty dang clever if you ask me
and we can thank
diffie-hellman and merkel for that
pretty darn clever because eve sees it
all
just think what would happen if like the
germans had this in world war ii
would have been pretty cool
of course they didn't have computers so
it would have been difficult
i don't know too much to think about
right now okay continuing on so
what we have is we have this thing
called the certificate authority which
is a trusted
third party that signs these
certificates right
and so it's the it's entity that issues
digital signatures on public keys so
that we the public have a way of
validating that an amazon.com
certificate really came from amazon.com
so if you then add this all together
right if you add this all together we
have basic public private key encryption
that makes sure that this data can move
across the internet out of your computer
out back into the next one all encrypted
that's just public private that does
that and then we have this third-party
certificate authority that your
application can use to validate the
certificate that comes out and so the
combination of ssl or the secure sockets
layer
and the certificate authority gives us
high confidence that when we're talking
to something we know we're really
talking to it so it's pretty
non-intrusive security if your browser
pops up with a little pop-up message
that means it's got a certificate that
it has no certificate of authority to
validate and that's not a good time to
be typing in sensitive information
unless you know exactly what's going on
so
that sort of brings us to the conclusion
of this
this these last couple of lectures have
been about message confidentiality and
that is protecting the contents from
being revealed
we use encrypting and decrypting for
that and then we have message digests
and cert to sign things we've signed
messages we've signed certificates we've
signed many things and those are
important and we talked about both sort
of shared key and secret key where you
have to get together and agree on a key
which is a symmetric key that's used for
encrypting and decrypting and then you
have the public private key which is the
asymmetric which is one key is used for
encrypting and the other key is user for
decrypting and you can freely show the
encrypting key because it gives very
little information although it is
mathematically possible but difficult to
decrypt a public private key message so
that kind of sums up that kind of sums
up our
lecture on
public private keys and i hope you find
it valuable see you on the net
[Music]
you